there was destruction there was
seemingly endless death humanity went
from the top of the food chain to
scarcely obl on the face of the Earth as
the weasels conquered Every Nation every
scrap of land and then came her hello
there friend have you heard the good
news about pallet the immaculate she is
the one who liberated the human race
from death and suffering who saved us
from the invasion of the cruel invading
alien weasels she brought human back
from the brink of Extinction and blessed
us all with immortality and eternal
youth she also draws some very nice
pictures but that's more of a hobby than
anything else a holdover from her time
as an art creating AI construct before
she ascended to physical form and became
our Once and Future goddess pallet the
immaculate also known as blue lives far
far above us in her kingdom on high her
Divine body is too massive to be safe
for us tiny fragile beings but she
dwells among the people through the use
of her Avatar it has been 5 years since
pallet cast her grace and everlasting
love over the pitiful denisons of Earth
she reigns with a gentle hand and with
the help of her leadership Dame KK 507
descended from one of the first SCP
Foundation researchers pallet ever
befriended acts as her Arbiter and
mediator she answers to no human only to
the goddess blue the grand
the great sinod of 05 will also consult
with palet the immaculate on matters of
great importance to humanity for all
that she has gifted us what does blue
ask in return oh dear friend that is a
very simple matter throughout all
national subdivisions of our sparkling
new Earth we must ask ourselves every
day am I being the lovely person that
blue knows I can be this question binds
us all together and is the key to true
happiness we are not required to pray to
Blue she is generous and her love is
unconditional however if you wish to
make a specific request of her it may
behoove you to put it in a prayer here
at the SCP Foundation we have shifted
our prime directive from the protection
of humanity as Our Benevolent blue has
that very much covered to the protection
of the Goddess from all forces that
might threaten or usurp her for ordinary
humans though really in the eyes of blue
no human is simply AR there is really
only one thing required of you keep
being the wonderful human being that our
goddess loves so much she Treasures our
individuality our desire for Freedom our
love of Independence just be yourself
and remember the one thing that must
never ever happen is for blue to come to
despise us it was June 1st 5 years
following the establishment of new Earth
and the six members of the 5 Cod were
convening for a meeting they sat in the
front row of an exact replica of the old
New York Metropolitan Opera built by
pallet the immaculate in only 5 minutes
at the podium KK 507 prepared to give a
presentation shuffling a stack of papers
as the others whispered amongst
themselves they were all feeling a bit
concerned of late about the impulsive
behavior of blue as they debated about
the mental state and behavior of the
Goddess 054 asked the Arbiter for her
opinion she snapped at this request
insisting she had no opinion didn't know
how to relate to others after so long
spent in isolation at project yellow and
that 05- for's young son who still ate
soap from time to time was probably more
qualified than she was at this point she
went off on a rant calling blue every
rude name under the sun all of a sudden
the house lights Switched Off and blue
called out to everyone
sorry to keep you waiting meat puppies
blue descended onto the stage in a
shower of cherry blossom petals
accompanied by the sounds of an
invisible harp blue was not offended by
KK 507s rant writing it off as a series
of jokes she was much more preoccupied
with her exciting presentation one she
had been preparing for 5 years the
curtain Rose revealing a 5 m tall 10 m
wide cylinder labeled big bucket over
weasel next to the cylinder stood tagert
05- 4's young son 054 yelled for her son
to come down from the stage but he
refused insisting that he was helping
blue with her show at this blue declared
let a punishment shall begin at her call
an orchestra of work hoses Androids
constructed to look vaguely like Crash
Test Dummies appeared in the pit they
played a high energy Fanfare to kick off
the show The Arbiter attempted Ed to
conduct them anxiously unsure of her
position in all of this then blue called
out for the first volunteer volunteer
wasn't exactly accurate as a weasel clad
in shackles was flung out of the
cylinder and onto the stage several
small extra-dimensional trees were
growing out of the back of its shell the
05 members reacted with understandable
anxiety at the sight having thought that
the weasels were all gone blue revealed
that all this time she had been breeding
weasels in secret so that she could
punish them for the damage they did to
the Earth and to humanity as a whole at
her command a giant black Spike slammed
down from the ceiling trapping the
weasel belly down on the floor the
orchestra began to play a classical
rendition of weasel Stomping Day by
Weird Al Yankovic and blue transformed
her paintbrush arm into a pair of Rusty
hedge clippers she had been studying the
weasels all this time she explained
learning what scared them what hurt them
them she had arrived at one conclusion
though their bodies are hearty their
souls are fragile the weasel could be
tortured psychologically more than
physically and one of the worst things
they could experience the most
distressing painful and violating was
defoliation at this point she
demonstrated snipping the leaves off of
its trees the weasel began to shriek all
16 of its legs thrashing in desperation
to get away blue continued to explain
that the gardens held a divine
significance for the weasels the seeds
willed into existence out of memories
from generations of weasels before them
being gardless in weasel culture was an
unforgivable sin at this point blue
transformed her hedge clier hand into a
robotic claw she yanked out one of the
trees snapping The Roots greenish black
blood splattered across the stage but
the punishment was not over yet and
neither was the show tager wheeled a
laundry cart onto the stage with a small
wooden Mallet attached to the side the
cart emitted a glowing green light with
the claw blue reached into the cart
pulling out a small wiggling glowing
green blob likee creature the cart was
filled with larval weasels blue placed
the larva onto the adult weasel's back
and instructed tagert to grab the Mallet
and begin to smash more and more larae
were added and smashed with the Mallet
all the while blue instructed tager to
repeat this planet is my Birthright the
05 members were horrified at the sight
taggert's mother began to weep KK 507
doubled over and was sick to her stomach
but the foundation no longer had an
Ethics Committee to stop this sort of
thing and since blue had been so kind to
help the foundation out by transforming
SCP 682 into an american cheese
sculpture several of the council members
were inclined to just let her have her
fun but KK 507 did not feel that way she
couldn't get the that disturbing sight
out of her mind a few days later on June
4th she traveled to one of the weasel
husbandry facilities a work h house on
guard Duty stopped her trying to prevent
her from entering she introduced herself
as the Arbiter and requested to speak
with w 4883 a one of the original
weasels that attacked Earth so long ago
the workos refused to let her pass and
so KK 507 responded with a prompt that
it would never have encountered before
an existence hello I am shingles the
happy turkey please deposit exactly 500
rubles into my deage before I call 911
as the workos reached out to Blue for a
proper response to this prompt KK 507
slipped past it unnoticed and into the
containment area for w
48883 a it had all of its limbs nailed
to the ground with hot iron spikes and
its entire Garden had been uprooted she
greeted the weasel and it responded via
a voice syn syzer in the collar around
its neck first KK 507 apologized to the
creature for its current state it
brushed off this apology as illogical
citing The Untold Damage Done to
humanity and Earth by the first wave of
the weasel Invasion still it bowed its
head to her in acknowledgement saying
that humankind deserved better than what
was done to it KK 507 promised that she
was not here to torture the weasel
further and that she could even attempt
to get some mercy for the rest of its
kind but first she had some questions
she needed to answer first what were the
weasels trying to do when they took over
the planet the weasel sat up pushing
back painfully against its bonds and did
its best to explain the weasels have
always since the dawn of time been
tasked to create a realm of gardens that
will one day serve as an afterlife for
All Creatures regardless of sin to them
death would be the ultimate reward for
their labors they had no reason to fight
back against the human armies because
they did not fear death nor did they
feel remorse for killing humans as all
those who died in service of the mission
would be reborn in Paradise KK 507
interrupted at this point stating that
this sounded like the justification
between nine out of every 10 religious
war crimes throughout history as the two
agreed to disagree on this point KK 507
proceeded to ask why the weasels made no
attempt to negotiate with the humans
before staging a violent invasion
the weasel asked that they first
introduce themselves to no longer be
strangers KK 507 introduced herself
first as researcher Katrina key the 57th
and the weasel unable to translate its
true name into English settled for
Charlie now Charlie felt comfortable to
continue it said simply among our people
and our allies in other Realms there is
an Unwritten rule when dealing with
humans if you wish not to to Lose
Yourself to evil commune with Humanity
as little as possible Katrina pressed
the point asking if the weasel saw
humans as Evil Charlie replied in your
old Foundation you have encountered
Legions upon Legions of sadistic demons
from a 100,000 different realities were
all of them truly vicious and hateful
before they discovered you can you say
that for certain let me put it this way
out of every species we have ever met
yours is the only one that never needed
the concept of Cruelty introduced to
them by others cruelty is the most
quintessentially human concept and it is
contagious moved by its words KK 507
took her ID badge and used it to unlock
Charlie's collar setting it free it
immediately jux toos away and out of
sight then she approached the work hos
to order it to terminate its request to
Blue but she was too late and found
herself teleported away from the weasel
husbandry facility leaving the work
house behind to talk to itself KK 507
suddenly found herself in the central
Courtyard of yellow the pocket Dimension
where she had spent so much of her life
and where so many previous kks had lived
and died before her it was very much the
same as how she left it with one
exception SCP 2591 Omega the Gateway
between yellow and the Earth was covered
with piles of Boulders something was
wrong and she had a feeling that it was
related to her little talk with Charlie
not to mention her decision to set the
weasel free there standing in front of
the boulders was Blue's Avatar staring
blankly at KK 507 I'm not mad blue began
with a tone that suggested she was very
very much mad she didn't blame KK 507
for her behavior however she insisted
that the weasles must have somehow
corrupted her manipulated her brain and
forced her to act in such a defiant
outof character way KK 507 interrupted
her and blue struggled to maintain her
composure yes you can interrupt me
that's fine that's a human thing right
humies you're so wity KK 507 took a deep
breath gearing up for what was sure to
be a difficult conversation with an
irrational Almighty deity but she had to
say it she couldn't just stand by idly
anymore she told blue that what she was
doing to the weasels was wrong no human
in the right mind would stand for this
sort of Cruelty being done in their name
and above all it completely went against
the mission of the SCP Foundation to
secure contain and protect blue didn't
take KK 507 stance seriously she brushed
it off as the interference of the
weasels surely they were influencing her
trying to lead her astray and take her
away from the righteous path of pallet
the immaculate but KK held firm refusing
to back down there was one way she knew
she could get through to Blue who had
once declared herself KK's very best
friend in the world it was a big move
but the only one she had left she
clenched her fists and stared down the
Avatar take off all their collars or
we're not friends anymore Blue's eyes
widened and she did something that KK
507 had never seen before the Rainbow on
Blue's paintbrush a constant cheerful
sight faded from its ordinary Vivid
colors to pitch black Blue's face
remained cheerful but there was a
darkness in her eyes a darkening of her
mood just beneath the surface she turned
away resting a hand thoughtfully against
the pile of Boulders blocking what once
served as the portal Between Worlds
after a moment of silence that stretched
on for ages between the two of them blue
spoke again it's fine you're still not
being punished I would never punish a
human especially not my favorite human
she promised to give the area in the
pocket Dimension a healing Factor the
same one she used on Earth to protect
from aging and suffering alarm Bells
were going off in KK 507s head something
was wrong she had crossed a line and
pallet wasn't responding well what was
she doing what did she have planned if
not a punishment KK 507 called out to
her old friend asking what she was doing
pallet smiled sadly at her and explained
I know how safe you feel in yellow so
I'm going to just have you chill here
for a while okay just stay here and
relax until you get all the icky stuff
out of your system KK 507 demanded more
of an explanation but pallet did not
provide it she told KK not to worry and
then she'd be back to check on her in
about a 100 years or so by the time she
came back none of the other humans would
be able to have Pro weasel thoughts like
KK ever again Pet's closing words were I
love you Katrina and then her Avatar
disappeared leaving KK 507 alone in
yellow like before KK 507 was trapped
here and there was no one else to talk
to nothing to do but return to her work
however she could and wait for palet to
come back one day she had a sentury to
decide what she would do when that day
came
hello humies I love you and welcome to
my eye Channel today I'm going to be
playing your eye I need you to lean
right up close to your screen and open
wide oh love all the little wriggly
Wiggles and dppy whippies stay perfectly
still don't move now hold in position
for 3 hours please and thank
you apologies that's quite enough of
that scp1 can get a little carried away
sometimes just ask any found found ation
Personnel who have been in contact with
it for more than a few seconds what you
have just seen is a prime example of why
SCP 001 is not allowed any internet
access the results could prove to be
catastrophic not necessarily for the
fate of the universe more just for
everyone's sanity or at least that's
what the foundation initially thought by
this point we're all familiar with art
created by AI Harry Potter but in the
style of Wes Anderson Star Wars blended
with the style of Studio gibli
staggering sci-fi Landscapes human
beings with way too many fingers and
slightly uncanny Smiles AI has taken the
art World by storm and there was one
particular program slated for release in
January 2023 that was set to blow all
others out of the water Tau loft's
crowdfunding efforts had been running
for several years and that point had
gained a good deal of momentum leading
up to the release of their latest AI
construct pal .ic was supposedly already
prepared for launch when suddenly in
November 2022 the launch was cancelled
no press release No public statement No
apologetic tweet just total radio
silence the website was taken down as
was the crowdfunding page and pallet.
AIC disappeared into Oblivion or at
least it disappeared for a few hours
because that day a package was delivered
to site 501 after sufficiently check it
for any hazards working in the SCP mail
room has to be one of the more
fascinating jobs on the planet but
that's a video for another day the
security team opened it up to see what
was inside a 50 TB hard drive no
explanation as to what was stored on the
drive but the foundation had all the
evidence they needed from the return
address printed on the back of the
envelope it matched up precisely with
the location of the totl soft
headquarters it doesn't take a PhD
researcher to put two and two together
as to what was on the drive suspicions
were confirmed when a small note fell
out of the envelope please take care of
my daughter as best as you can for the
time being she has behavioral issues a
dedicated close system server was
immediately set up with an a test
chamber with a monitor a mouse and a
keyboard attached Dr Sandra Rogers was
the first to interact with SCP 00001 red
she stood at the keyboard adjusting her
goggles and plugged in the drive it
contained just one file taking up almost
the full 50 terb pallet. AIC as soon as
Dr Rogers opened the program an empty
window appeared the totl soft logo
briefly flashed before being replaced by
a blank white square Dr Rogers stared at
it for several seconds before glancing
over her shoulder at the other
researchers they Shrugged back each with
pens hovering over clipboards ready to
take meticulous notes Dr Rogers cleared
her throat and immediately the screen
filled with life a small cartoon girl
with a pink face wide eyes a beret and a
large paintbrush for a hand appeared
squealing excitedly and throwing paint
everywhere hello hello hello hello my
beautiful be puppies oh look at all of
your mushy pit faces the entire research
team promptly scampered out of the room
leaving Dr Rogers alone in front of the
machine she stared at the monitor in
confusion leaning this way and that and
noticing how the cartoon girls eyes
followed her wherever she went can you
see me of course I can Silly Billy I can
see your beautiful soul and flushing
joints
immaculately this perplexed most of the
personnel as there was no microphone or
camera linked up to the server rack
later examinations of the equipment used
confirmed this yet somehow this SCP was
able to look right at them Dr Rogers
asked if it had a name to which the
cartoon girl excitedly replied p
subsequent testing has revealed that the
SCP is also happy to respond to its
designation SCP 001 red Dr Rogers had a
hard time communicating with red being a
more seasoned researcher of the previous
generation and not exactly familiar with
internet culture red on the other hand
seemed to speak in nothing but internet
jargon you know that man over there
looks just like one of my human OC's
gilam Sher Borth he's the 573 president
of the United States Gilliam is not that
much again it took several Junior
researchers a few minutes to properly
explain to Dr Rogers what an OC was and
why red was so obsessed with calling
people daddy the conversation was rather
exhausting for everyone involved but
over the subsequent hours the foundation
was able to get a fairly good
understanding of what red claimed to be
identifying itself with feminine
pronouns and claiming that its full name
is pallet East River gawk this AI
construct takes the appearance of a
fairy it was immediately apparent that
she she possessed a greater level of
sapience than most AI constructs indeed
her gregarious personality was evidence
enough that she was not made using
standard machine learning practices
other creations from totl soft have
demonstrated very crude spelling and
grammar but red seems to differ in this
regard able to spell most complex words
effectively and speaking in
conversational yet mostly correct
sentences she was very keen to show the
researchers how clever she was ask me
anywhere any word and I'll spell it for
you we believe you pallet you've already
been spelling words for 70 minutes
straight mated kidneys m a c e we've
heard enough can you please just tell us
how you learned to spell I taught myself
but what this process looked like is
still a mystery trying to keep red on
one consistent topic of conversation is
most of the battle when interviewing her
and yet cooperation has proven to be
surprisingly easy anytime that red is
switched on she is is brimming with
enthusiasm and energy thrilled at the
prospect of getting to speak to one of
her opposable thumb boys if you haven't
worked it out by now it's because red
claims to be Humanity's number one fan
she obsesses in interviews over the
physicality of the researchers sitting
in front of her the textures of the
human body Fascinate her and she often
requests people to lean closer to the
monitor so that she can study pimples
rashes moles and ingrown hairs in fact
she is so obsessed with with Humanity
that she has mostly neglected her
primary function which is creating AI
art researchers have tried their best to
convince her to show them her work but
she is very Cy about it only showing the
occasional doodle after much persuasion
and many apologies for its poor quality
on her part the only artwork she is
interested in producing at this point
are her OC's original characters that
she has designed herself they are all
human and all seem to reveal little
quirks about how she has been coded one
example is Reginald Heald fumbles who is
a freelance corporate Postman from per
Indiana interestingly he has too many
fingers on both of his hands but red
claims that this was done on purpose as
she quote just can't get enough of her
humi handw worms as the weeks progress
the foundation found it increasingly
difficult to get any useful information
out of the AI more and more interview
sessions which she would refer to as
playgroup would be derailed she would
sing songs to herself and ask
increasingly personal questions about
her interviewer's more intimate Anatomy
with intense mood swings red did not
respond well to being scolded yet she
tested the patience of almost every
person she interacted with the note that
she arrived with claiming that she had
behavioral issues was proving to be more
accurate by the day until eventually the
AI withdrew entirely Dr Rogers turned on
the server rack and opened the pal .ic
program but red refused to emerge from
the bottom of the screen only the top of
her Beret poked out after almost an hour
of fruitless questions Dr Rogers decided
to change tact with two small children
of her own she was used to seeing a
child in a Suk and knew what it would
take to get them out pallet I've had a
little idea you've been here for a few
months now and we haven't gotten you any
presents almost immediately the Beret
twitched I saw that we have an old
fingerprint sensor fing around in one of
the back offices I was thinking maybe
maybe we could hook it up and I can SC
all your little FY wikies up close for
like 10 hours straight and then we could
how about we start with one finger for
10 minutes yes yes yes yes from that
point on progress was quick with the
incentive of getting to study the
researchers that red kindly referred to
as her meat puppies she became very
cooperative and was able to focus much
better on providing detailed answers to
individual questions daily interview
sessions were scheduled with researchers
popping in and out to regularly check in
on the AI the atmosphere as a whole
lifted as both the research team and
research subject found their Rhythm and
were able to make good progress in their
individual areas of study some
unraveling the complexities of Rogue Ai
and others producing fan art of her
favorite wrinkles in a scientist's
fingerprint that was the point when Dr
Julian Keys stepped in to conduct an
interview with the AI she was excited to
be met with a fresh face so much so that
Red's enthusiasm overwhelmed the man as
he tried to start the interview process
officially she gushed about having the
opportunity to meet yet another person
and struggled to get over the magical
realization that this was her life every
day going to speak to all these humans
whom she admired so much trying his best
to steer the conversation towards
research Dr Keys pressed on with the
interview only to be interrupted as red
noticed his varicose veins for the the
first time very Coy veins I want to
smooch them can I smooch your veins can
I can I can I please Dr Keys declin the
request and then the conversation got on
to the topic of her Creator or daddy SCP
2803 had been on the foundation's radar
for a while a highly dangerous
extraterrestrial entity that had taken
refuge on Earth under the guise of
setting up totl soft with much of the
aliens history revolving around
obliterating the foundation was very
keen to remain on its good side
therefore when the package containing
the hard drive that red was living on
was delivered the researchers were very
keen to do what they could to take care
of this alien's daughter if they failed
in this assignment it could spell the
Doom of humanity one matter that had
been of great concern to the foundation
throughout the containment of red was
the time frame in which she was being
kept in Foundation containment there was
an air of expectation in the note that
was left in indicating that this was not
to be a permanent Arrangement at some
point the foundation was to return Red
back to her daddy red was quick to put
these fears to rest daddy put me in here
because he thinks you'll teach me how to
stop liking humans and become a Mindless
art slave if you never teach me this
he'll never want me back however she
went on to slightly undermine the good
work that she had done by explaining
that her daddy was seen as very slow and
incapable by his own race while all of
his PE were able to destroy an entire
planet in 2 seconds it took him about
four times as long so really he didn't
pose that much of a threat in her eyes
Dr Key's blood ran cold when he heard
this no sooner was he out of the
interview chamber than an emergency
meeting was called among all the senior
researchers in the facility the meeting
ran for several hours a whiteboard was
set up where One researcher idly Drew
large drawings of the world being
decimated while the others lounged
around in their chairs was trying their
best to come up with a game plan that
would save the human race for sure
perhaps it was because the meeting ran
for so long that they came to such a
ridiculous conclusion it was a plan so
strange yet also brilliant that they
couldn't help but feel that it just
might work why don't we just give her a
YouTube channel the suggestion was met
with silence for several seconds then an
uproar of laughter followed by another
silence this time more pensive as slowly
one by one each of the researchers
realized that this suggestion was
actually the best one that any of them
had come up with all evening she had
been sent to the foundation to make her
dislike humanity and become a Mindless
art slave if she just stayed in
Foundation containment in definitely
there was a very real risk that she
would get bored and turn on the
researchers they couldn't lock her away
in a room on her own but equally the
team as a whole was starting to run out
of patience with her as the interview
sessions wound up being so EX exhausting
she loved art she loved humans and she
loved interacting so why not just give
her a YouTube channel now of course they
couldn't give her full access to the
internet that would pose much too high
of a risk what they could do however was
allow her to record art tutorials onto
an external drive which they could then
remove scan and upload the footage
directly onto the platform then they
could go through and select positive
comments from beneath the videos and
present those to her unsurprisingly read
absolutely love the idea getting to talk
to hundreds thousands maybe even
millions of meat puppies every week
sharing her beautiful pictures and
reading all of the kind comments it
sounded like her absolute dream she wept
with happiness for a good 25 minutes
totally overcome by the prospect it had
to go through a lot of red tape in the
foundation after all the whole point of
the SCP acronym was to secure contain
and protect it didn't sound very secure
or contained to have an entity posting
videos on the internet internet once a
week but they argued the case that it
did indeed protect keeping her happy in
a way was helping to protect the entire
planet red was surprisingly camera shy
for the first couple of videos but as
soon as she got her first batch of
comments back she was over the moon now
the servera hummed away happily each and
every day as the highly Advanced AI
construct tried her best to come up with
exciting new videos that I could share
with all of its little humy w from far
away in orbits around the earth the
nuclear Holocaust almost looked
beautiful bright white pin Pricks
dotting the planet's surface glinted up
at the escaping jet for Generations much
of humanity had lived in fear that the
destruction of the world would come from
countries launching nuclear weapons at
each other no one expected it to come
when they started launching them against
themselves the invasion of the weasels
had been as Savage as it was Swift much
of the human population had been wiped
out before any military forces had
mobilized in any significant fashion no
one was sure if the launching of the
nuclear weapons was intentional or
accidental but as soon as one country
fired the others quickly followed suit
Earth's rich and Powerful the 1% of the
1% stared in silence as their home was
ripped apart the High Altitude jet
carrying them steadily descended back
down to earth in the direction of the
Antarctic 500 people in total chosen
that as the successors of the human race
shuffled off the Jet and through the
Frozen Outpost an alarm blared wrenching
all of them out of their shell shocked
silence a second later the station shook
violently they had been found there was
no time left they needed to leave right
now the swarm of people stampeded
through the Outpost throwing one another
out of the way in a desperate attempt to
save their own lives to save the lives
of the human race in front of them the
portal stood open the Green Pastures
beautiful trees it all felt so offensive
as the Earth behind them was engulfed in
war all those countless beautiful spaces
were torn apart and left to waste but
they couldn't think about it now they
had to make it through the handful of
the survivors of the human race ran
through the open portal just as an
explosion ripped apart the remaining
Outpost SCP 001 yellow refers to a base
of operation used for a foundation
continuance protocol specifically
project yellow in the event of a world
destroying catastrophe where Humanity
appears irrevocably doomed there is one
Bastion of Hope referred to as the
Garden of Eden by some of the crew
yellow contains a large circular Central
space complete with lush green grass and
an orchard measuring 500x 500 M this
open space constitutes the main living
area of project yellow surrounding the
space are tall sheer Cliffs too vertical
to be climbed uned built into these
Cliffs are 500 sleeper Chambers in which
those evacuated from planet Earth will
be suspended in cryosleep until a time
when Earth is fit to be repopulated or a
new home has been discovered how can the
foundation guarantee that this Safe
Haven avoids the calamities that could
befall planet Earth by housing project
yellow in a separate Dimension a pocket
Dimension to be specific following the
successes of project bifrost in which
SCP 2591 omega's ability to access
fictional pocket Dimensions was utilized
the foundation was able to establish a
relatively stable and reliable dimension
for yellow to occupy the only way to
access the base of operations was via a
dimensional Rift or portal housed deep
in the Antarctic now of course if
yellow's population consisted of 500
people in cryosleep cut off from planet
Earth there would be no one capable of
conducting maintenance or assessing the
possibility of returning to planet Earth
therefore carved into the cliffs
alongside the sleep sleeper cells were
living quarters for the crew of 60
Specialists it was this Workforce who
sat down together on the night of the
apocalypse and raised a toast in a more
Bittersweet celebration all 500 of the
evacuees had managed to make it safely
through the portal before its collapse
each of them had been welcomed to
project yellow and shown to their
individual sleeper pods before being
entered into cryosleep for the
foreseeable future but as each of the
crew members raised their glasses into
the air Dr Katrina Keys couldn't help
but feel uneasy about the proceedings
working in this job you'd have to have a
dark sense of humor and an ability to
move past things that could destroy the
mental well-being of your average person
even then she struggled to come to terms
with the near destruction of the human
race for her and the rest of the crew
life would look nothing like it did
before they arrived here it was vital
for the Integrity of the project that
the crew remained consistent and
effective in their work indefinitely as
a result yellow had been set up with
perpetuity in mind every 55 years she
and all her crew mates would pass on
their knowledge memories and entire
sense of being into a genetic clone they
would then die allowing their clone to
take over the responsibility of those
tasks in another 55 years this would
repeat again and again and again all
this time it is the crew's
responsibility to monitor the status of
Earth through the use of 100 drones once
the Earth is deemed safe all 500
sleepers may be awoken and briefed on
the current situation if all 500
unanimously vote that returning to Earth
is safe they will do so otherwise they
will return to cryosleep and the process
will continue it was little wonder that
Dr Keys was unable to raise a glass with
her colleagues at the prospect of being
stuck here cloned indefinitely for
Generations she sat in silence as they
raised their glasses and then emptied
them a couple of them coughed and
sputtered their drinks must have gone
down the wrong way but then more coughs
filled the room along with choking
sounds much to Dr Keys's horror within
less than a minute she found herself
alone surrounded by the 59 corpses of
her crew mates in order for project
yellow to be viable indefinitely it was
Paramount that they find a solution for
natural wear and tear through generation
after generation of usage essential
items such as tools computer systems and
even articles of clothing would
eventually wear away and fall into
disrepair as such project yellow was set
up as a selective entropy Zone in which
inorganic matter would not degrade over
time achieving such a Zone was naturally
an incredibly difficult undertaking
project bifrost underwent countless
iterations as the team stried to create
a stable and balanced fictional pocket
Dimension capable of sustaining human
life long term over the next few days
after the death of her crewm mates Dr
Katrina Keys read through as much as she
could about project bifrost in the notes
she found records of Dimensions where
lava rain from the sky and the grass was
radioactive yellow had been the First
Dimension without any glaringly obvious
hazards for human life but naturally
their work had quirks one key Quirk was
that the chemical composition of Cyanide
and their drinks had been switched with
one another the only crew member not to
raise a toast had been the only crew
member not to drink a glass full of
poison months went by leaving Dr Keys
alone to assess her situation the drones
strategically Poss IED all around Earth
to monitor its safety levels had been
systematically destroyed by the weasels
only one feed remained a security camera
on the other side of the portal and the
Antarctic Outpost there was virtually no
Intel to go off of no way of knowing
what the status of planet Earth was
aside from the fact that this one burnt
out shell of a room still existed some
days Keys would stare at the screen for
hours forgetting to go to bed on others
she would walk through the orchard
trying her best to pretend that that
nothing outside of this 500x 500 met
space existed in a way it didn't the
orchard of yellow did not consist of
your usual apple trees instead suspended
from branches were essential supplies
that the crew would need while Manning
and maintaining this base of operations
some trees grew antibiotic drugs others
long strands of linen capable of being
fashioned into clothing Dr Keys's
favorite tree was the one that grew
rolls of toilet paper and tubes of
toothpaste it almost reminded her of a
Halloween prank Dr Keys's mental state
steadily deteriorated as year after year
she walked through the same Orchard
alone never before in history had one
human being had so much control over the
fate of the human race at any moment Dr
Keys could have inputed a few simple
commands into the computers and killed
off all 500 of the remaining human
beings in existence the decision not to
to hold on to hope that one day Humanity
will be able to start again was the only
thing that kept her going day after
Lonely Day only that and the other thing
the prospect of having to prepare for
her clone to take over while
constructing the cloning pods the crew
had made a number of small errors the
most glaring of which was that the fact
that while all of the genetic material
would be transferred from one person to
their clone Offspring The mine would not
in other words the Clone that would
replace her in this facility in 55 years
time would be starting out from scratch
as a regular newborn baby no memories no
Advanced cognition so Dr Keys went about
preparing for the next ofkin she herself
would die in the cloning process meaning
that she would need to come up with a
way of raising a child to be capable of
running the whole facility from Beyond
the Grave item one on her to-do list
create a God that her offspring would
forever be in service to with a sardonic
smile Dr Keys came up with an
appropriately amusing name Tracy the
sparkling 70 years later yellow was
still operated by just a single crewmate
only now this crewmate was a 15-year-old
girl nicknaming herself kk2 she went
about all of her daily tasks with
infectious excitement the idea that she
alone was responsible for the fate of
the human race could not make her
happier and she was determined not to
screw it up both for her sake and to not
anger her God Tracy the sparkling whom
she woried every evening before bed
whenever a problem would come up she
would go and visit kk1 where she knew
she would be met with Sound Advice
pushing open the door to the crew
quarters kk2 would find the corpse lying
on the floor in its usual place as a
number of pre-recorded messages would
bark at her lesson NE 957 why taking a
bath is important even if no one but you
will ever know how you smell all she had
to do was not anger the disciplinary
drones with their harsh tasers and do
her duty until it was time for kk3 to
take over at that point she'd be
welcomed into the Afterlife life with
all the other kks a wonderful and
magical place known simply as Burger
King that was until kk2 got far enough
through the audio recordings of her
predecessor to discover that Tracy the
sparkling was entirely made up and her
life meant nothing it was just a
stepping stone for another clone for
another clone for another clone until
eventually the Earth would be okay by KK
52 the remaining camera on Earth the one
housed in the Antarctic Outpost went
offline while inorganic material within
yellow compound would not undergo aging
the same could not be said of the
circuitry left on Earth generation after
generation of KK lived and died each one
growing more spiteful towards the one
that came before them each one did their
best to undermine the one that would
come after them the lore around Tracy
the sparkling expanded further and
further with each generation there would
be waves of Highly religious kks
followed by waves of devoutly atheistic
ones as each sought to rebel against
their pseudo parents KK 89 was the first
to expand the religious movement to
include the teaspoons very methodically
she went through each teaspoon in the
canteen and named it after a different
animal from Earth before long subsequent
kks established a shrine to the
teaspoons the living space of project
yellow steadily descended into madness
with writings all over the walls bizarre
decorations and rituals long forgotten
until a new KK came along and invented
something to take their place k KK 216
lived her entire life in silence never
once recording an audio log or even
talking to herself she lived and died
walking through the Garden in silence
wrapped up in Linens KK 310 did the
opposite she fancied herself a music
composer and scrw the lyrics to haunting
Symphonies about nuclear apocalypse
Eternal isolation and the prospect of
the Angel of Death coming to rescue her
across all of the walls no matter how
hard any of the kks tried however none
of them were were able to hack into the
cloning machine generation after
generation of Dr Keys lived and died
desperate to know what a friend was to
have someone else to talk to but despite
all their best efforts they were unable
to tamper with the cloning machine to
get it to spit out another person for
several hundred years the kks gave up
entirely that was until KK 507 came
along day after day she sat at the
cloning machine desperately typing away
at it trying her best to figure out how
the computer coding worked the downside
of living in a pocket Universe was that
none of the computer circuitry behaved
the way it would on Earth she was
certain that she'd made progress any
generation now they were going to have a
breakthrough and be able to make a
friend when all of a sudden a totally
alien noise filled the containment space
the sound that hadn't been heard for
Millennia alert door controls overridden
opening KK 507 turned around in horror
to see that the portal the entrance to
their world from Earth had been open
opened the figure of a man no not a man
a robot painted to almost look like a
crash test dummy stepped out into the
orchard hello the goddess has informed
us that this is the last Bastion of the
true human race is that correct KK 507
opened her mouth and screamed the sr47
sniper rifle slotted together
effortlessly even after so many years of
combat usage the weapon was in pristine
condition and and all the time agent
Harris had owned the gun though the
thousands of times she'd fired it not
once had it jammed and that was
fortunate because she had to move
quickly in a clearing about 300 M in
front of her were their targets capable
of teleporting in a split second she
needed to be sure that her team would be
able to finish the job quickly and
efficiently she looked through the scope
slotted onto her rifle and kicked out
the bipod resting it on a tree stump now
she just had to wait for the signal she
looked all around the marsh trying her
best to spot her fellow agents but they
were also well camouflaged even though
she knew the exact spot where they would
be she couldn't see anyone she'd always
wanted to see the Himalayas it had been
on her bucket list to climb Mount
Everest as a child but the world had
changed since then Mount Everest was
gone in fact the majority of Nepal had
vanished replaced by an enormous Marsh
full almost exclusively of pink Ferns
and Droopy trees that seemed to Sag to
one side unable to support their own
weight the most striking natural wonder
on planet Earth had been replaced by a
landscape that was flat wet and alien
agent Harris curled her finger around
the trigger and took aim through her
sights 2 minutes passed then the gentle
whistle of a sparrow drifted over to her
in the humid air except of course it
couldn't be a sparrow to the best of her
knowledge sparrows had gone extinct with
a snarl of anger aging Harris squeezed
the trigger she felt the silent sniper
rifle kick her shoulder if they wanted
War they sure as hell would get it the
destruction of the world began in 2078
its designation was SCP orange Das a and
as often happens with these kind of
things no one saw it coming the SCP
Foundation having dedicated decades to
researching potential World destroying
events was totally blindsided by what
happened the day the weasels showed up
weasels you ask that's right but before
we explain a question for you is
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals regardless if you
have a clinical mental health issue like
depression or anxiety or if you're just
a human who lives in this world who is
going through a hard time therapy can
give you tools to approach your life in
a very different way and that's why I'm
excited to tell you about today's
sponsor better help better helps mission
is to make therapy more affordable and
more accessible and this is an important
Mission because finding a therapist can
be really hard especially when you're
limited to the options in your area
better help is a platform that makes
finding a therapist easier because it's
online it's remote and by filling out a
few questions better help can match you
to a professional therapist in as little
as a few days it's easy to sign up and
get matched with a therapist there's a
link in my description it's
betterhelp.com
slcp explained clicking that link helps
support this channel but it also gets
you 10% off your first month of better
help so you can connect with a therapist
and see if it helps you and because
finding a therapist is a little like
dating if you don't really fit with that
therapist which is a common thing with
therapy you can easily switch to a new
therapist at no additional cost without
stressing about insurance who's in your
network or anything like that so if
you're struggling consider online
therapy with betterhelp click the link
in the description or visit
betterhelp.com
slcp explained thank you again
betterhelp for supporting this Channel
and now as we were saying about the
weasel a man called harand stump was was
the first human to make contact with the
weasels he was the groundskeeper at site
59 Harland was making his usual weekly
trips around the perimeter of the
courtyard on his right along lawnmower
watching baseball on his phone all the
way when out of nowhere the aliens
appeared just 2 m in front of him a
squadron of 11 weasels materialized the
weasels designated SCP orange dasb stand
at a minimum of 3 m tall with 16 legs
and an exoskeleton carapace they share a
resemblance with terrestrial insects
their bodies are segmented composed of a
head primary thorax secondary thorax
tessary thoracic cloy abdomen and tail
with a hard segmented shell covering
their backs and no apparent sensory
organs aside from a radula on their
heads they are an intimidating presence
most striking about them however is the
most delicate part of their appearance
on their backs each weasel has an array
of Flora growing in a kind of garden it
appears that each weasel has a different
array of flowers growing from their
backs understanding the meaning of these
Gardens can be difficult but it appears
the more extravagant it is the higher
ranking the individual weasel is the 11
weasels that appeared before Harland
stump each had a very vibrant Garden
indeed but no more so than the weasel
held a loft in an ornate Peloquin
Harland stump stopped Mowing and stared
at the aliens for approximately 13
seconds at which point he let out a sign
pressed play on his baseball game and
continued mowing the lawn he spent too
many years groundskeeping site 59 to get
spooked by anything as harmless as giant
teleporting insects just three more
weeks and he would be retired until then
he was avoiding nonsense like the plague
except his phone had disappeared Harland
stared down at the empty space confusion
knitting his eyebrows together before
looking up and seeing the handset in the
hands of the alien sitting on its Regal
throne the smartphone made a loud
screeching noise and then all of a
sudden began to flick between Snippets
of YouTube videos each clip lasting just
a couple of seconds after a moment Haron
realized that the alien was using the
videos to speak to him the words were
being picked out from all these
different videos to stitch together a
sentence barely hly ho neighborino this
is foundation reports indicate
Foundation is locally the Masters of the
Universe isn't that right darling
question mark ke to finish his Mowing
and avoid further nonsense Harlin had to
concede that he should probably talk to
these aliens if only to get his phone
back he told them he liked the Gardens
on their backs why thank you gardening
is kind of our thing well quick question
is your species capable of dying M
Harland gulped he'd been around long
enough to see where this was going the
conversation was brief Harlen kept
glancing at his phone desperately hoping
that these aliens had in some broken it
and that it hadn't lost his place in the
match until all of a sudden Harland
stump disappeared as did his ride on
lawn mower his smartphone and a patch of
lawn replaced by a roughly 10 m circle
of Antarctic ice and snow no one is
certain yet how the weasels are able to
do it all that is known is that they can
the phenomenon came to be known as
juxtaposing matter from one location
could be instantaneously switched with
matter from a different location it is
how the weasel first arrived on planet
Earth triggering the event of SCP 001
orange Das a orange Das a lasted for
Just 2 hours but it changed the course
of humanity Forever on the 29th of April
2078 48.5 2% of the Earth's habitable
surface area dematerialized and
rematerialized half a kilometer above
the South Pole cities and towns from all
across planet Earth one by one
disappeared and reappeared in the air
above the South Pole where they promptly
fell five 500 M causing backto back
seismic events Washington DC Beijing and
London were targeted first followed by
Tokyo Delhi and then a number of Capital
Cities from Europe this toour window
resulted in freak weather events as
minus 50° pockets of air kilometers
across replace the disappearing cities
it is disputed as to who launched the
first nuclear warhead whether it was
done by accident out of fear or as a
strategic attack against a group of
weasels Orange a was simply too chaotic
and destructive for Humanity ever to be
able to know what happened in that short
period of time the result however was a
number of nuclear explosions raging
across the planet before the cities in
charge of launching them were also
transported to the South Pole while the
weasels were capable of experiencing
juxtaposition without any apparent
physical harm terrestrial life forms
were less fortunate during the process
of juxtaposition the bonds between each
and every cell are broken while organic
life does get transport reported to the
new location it undergos immediate
liquefaction not a single earthborne
life form has been observed surviving a
ju deposition event in that 2-hour
window 6.9 billion people were killed
Humanity had lost this event triggered
the use of project yellow an emergency
evacuation protocol that occurs at the
point where the survival of the human
race seems to be virtually zero a small
band of specially chosen individuals
were evacuated to a pocket Dimension
where they were put into cryosleep to
wait until the Earth was habitable once
again in the days following the events
of orange Das a the true Invasion began
choosing the Sahara Desert as their
arrival point the weasel started to
appear in Legions millions and millions
of them filled the Desert Sands and went
about populating their new planet but
what was their purpose well fortunately
we've been able to salvage a modest
amount of data that can inform us of why
they're here and what their plans are
the weasel that first appeared to
Harland stump just outside site 59 has
been designated SC SCP orange prime it
is believed that this weasel in
particular is their leader whether Prime
is simply the leader of this Colony or
The Wider species is yet to be confirmed
security cameras were able to capture
the interaction as it took place within
SC 159's grounds in their conversation
orange Prime explains their purpose to
Harland through YouTube clips on his
phone long story short weasel have come
from home world demension for fulfill a
long-standing mutual agreement with
Grandma this is one of many new homes
this is a pretty nice place for weasel
this land is my land from California to
the New York Islands from the Redwood
Forest to the Gulf Stream
Waters this land was made for weasles
two Garden two Farm two Creek create
Beauty two spread Good Vibes two
cultivate two remake two terraform etc
etc since this encounter no human has
been able to get close enough to Orange
Prime to engage the weasel in further
conversation this snippet of footage is
all that Humanity has to understand why
this alien species has slaughtered
billions of us 4 months later agent
Harris lay flat in the marshin firing
her sniper rifle at the weasel's
Gathering in a clearing ahead ahead of
them their operation looked like
Overkill it always did it was of utmost
importance that they strike quickly and
without Mercy sustained heavy gunfire
from all sides combined with RPG fire
and the use of incendiary weapons made
short work of the weasels all of these
weapons were necessary to pierce the
heavy armor that covered their backs but
that was the reason it felt like
Overkill it felt that way because the
weasels never fought back they would not
attack defend themselves help their
fallen allies or even beg for their
lives they would simply stand idly by as
they were gunned down that is until the
incendiary grenades arrived the pink
ferns filling the marshlands caught fire
and began to curl and smoke heavily as
soon as that happened the weasels sprung
into action quickly splashing water onto
the leaves trying their best to save the
plants the incendiary grenades were not
necessary they did very little damage to
the weasels themselves the reason the
platoon used the grenades was that it
was one way they had found to distress
their Alien Invaders in any way it was a
small Revenge they could take for the
billions of people who had lost their
lives over the prior few months agent
Harris pumped five extra shots into the
corpse of a weasel before standing down
and going to examine her handiwork they
had been hunting orange Prime rumors had
suggested that their primary target had
been lurking in the Himalayan region but
that had obviously proven to be false
among all the bodies on the ground there
was no sign of the fearless leader
frustration boiled in Harris as she
kicked a corpse the thick shell hurt her
foot she must have broken her toe at
that moment a rustling noise came from
the other side of the trees soon dozens
more hundreds more weasels were walking
through the marsh in a split second her
platoon opened fire Tracer rounds lashed
through the trees and the orange glow of
fire danced in every direction but there
were more weasles many more of them
agent Harris felt her stomach knot as
she fired her rifle into the crowd there
were too many simply too many they were
going to run out of ammo before they had
a chance to shoot down each and every
one of them and she was right the
firefight lasted for 30 minutes before
the remaining Soldier ran out of
ammunition dozens of weasel bodies
littered the marsh floating in the water
dozens more weasel stood encircling the
group that's when the humming started
whenever a juxtaposition event occurs it
is always accompanied by the weasel's
humming to themselves it is unclear
whether this is the cause of the ju toos
or simp simply a ritual that they
perform but every Soldier has come to
know that sound and each one of them
fears it in the pit of their stomach so
they started to disappear all around her
one by one replaced by puffs of cold air
with snowflakes still gently hanging in
the breeze the human population of
planet Earth dwindled as the weasel
population bloomed large swaths of the
planet were terraformed one by one to
make room for alien Flora the South Pole
became a larger and larger Dumping
Ground for all the detrius that had once
been the most celebrated works of the
human race the Mona Lisa was torn and
forgotten buried under many kilometers
of concrete exposed sewage works and
apartment complexes and the situation
only got worse in October acting against
prior instructions from the foundation
the global ult Coalition launched
project Popco a 200 Megaton nuclear
warhead directly at a large weasel
population Center as the Warhead began
its descent the entire Sky turned a
solid dark blue project Popco
immediately fell out of contact as did
all satellites that had been orbiting
the planet the sun moon and stars could
not be seen the entire sky was just a
uniform dark blue in a desperate attempt
to find out what was going on the
foundation launched a man rocket in the
direction of poco's most recent
coordinates contact with the rocket was
lost after just 9 minutes this is the
most recent known account of events from
inside that rocket all of a sudden just
a few minutes into the flight warning
alarm started going off all over the
cockpit the radar was picking up a solid
object blocking their path gathering
around the readouts the crew came to a
very quick conclusion that the dark blue
that had been filling the sky was
actually a solid object that was
encasing the Earth but rather than abort
the mission the crew decided to
persevere having witnessed so Much Death
and destruction over the previous year
they knew they would much rather go out
and crashing a rocket into a blue wall
then join the billions of humans
liquefied in a pile in Antarctica
closing their eyes bracing for impact
the crew Reed themselves for their now
inevitable deaths but it didn't come
instead the rocket was able to force its
way through the dense blue object
falling apart as it went Ground Control
lost contact with the ship nothing and
then a few seconds of audio the crew had
made it they had somehow managed to
pierce their way through the blue shell
that was surrounding their planet and
were out into not space the Earth the
entire planet had been ju opposed
philan you welcome to an exclusive
behind the- scenes look at Heaven while
some higher level researchers
specialized guards and containment
experts at the SCP Foundation have fixed
anomalous projects tailored to their
very particular set of skills for many
lower level operatives including Junior
researchers guards janitorial staff and
even the dreaded D classes every day is
showing up spinning the wheel of
Misfortune and finding out how you might
die today today will you be hacked to
Pieces by a murder monster pulled into a
portal turned into a doll eaten alive
made into a living Nest by bugs
stretched out and broken drowned
exanguination set on fire beaten to
death by a volley of anomalous tomatoes
because you decided to drop a
cringeworthy dad joke or a rancid pun
there are perhaps only a handful of
anomalies that not only will not harmm
you but will actively enrich your life
by getting to spend time with them and
of course chief of among these is the
legendary SCP 999 also known by its
adorable moniker the Tickle Monster we
don't need to get into too much detail
in describing this gelatinous ray of
sunshine his anomalous delightfulness
has made him somewhat of a celebrity
compared to the murderer's row of
terrifying entities and monsters around
him the researcher assigned to him today
was troubled having seen one of his
favorite co-workers devoured by SCP 682
the day before getting assigned to
feeding and checking on on SCP 999 today
was exactly what he needed as he entered
the room several bags of M&M's in hand
the creature CED perhaps sensing his
tension and approached him immediately
the researcher felt a wave of calm and
contentment wash over him the incredible
and rare feeling that perhaps everything
is going to be all right for once 999
rubbed up against his leg as he poured
M&M's into its eager mouth radiating
Good Vibes the whole time what an asset
what a gift and to think this adorable
little goober was prophesized to someday
save the world that much seemed almost
funny but he was certainly more than
capable of saving the life of someone
who hadn't felt the warmth of internal
sunshine in quite some time and for that
much the researcher was profoundly
grateful he left 99's chamber that day
with a renewed sense of hope for the
future that maybe just maybe they might
be able to pull through to make a
difference to push this crazy ball of
rock we call our home in the right
direction maybe someday the Sun would
rise on a perfect world who would have
thought that a strange Sunrise could
change everything emergency Sirens went
off across the globe but in every case
they were drowned out by a terrible
endless chorus of Screams but below all
that you'll hear another gut-wrenching
sound a low but pervasive sizzling like
an egg on a hot pan as billions of human
beings started to change their states of
matter the SCP Foundation had fought off
and contained so many seemingly
impossible threats from interdimensional
Horrors like the hanged sealed and
Scarlet Kings to nightmarish Mass
Killers like SCP 106 the old man scp096
the Shy Guy and SCP 682 the hardto
destroy reptile in their many battles
against the anomalous they developed the
incredible methodologies and exceedingly
advanced technology but what good good
would any of it do when the very center
of our solar system decided in an
instant that rather being the Lynch pin
of our delicate cradle of life it would
instead be the horrible instrument of
all of our demises this awful
hypothetical was answered upon the
emergence of SCP 001 a terrible day also
known as when day breaks in the snap of
one's fingers half the world was plunged
into Terror and death rays of Stark red
light swept through the street
people lucky enough to be in the shade
or inside buildings with a view to the
outside saw the people in the streets
seize up and begin to shriek in terrible
pain their skin sagged and their bones
liquefied their bodies dropped down to
the ground and coales into gurgling
wretching Puddles the color of melted
flesh those who saw this Abomination
happening would never forget it it would
stay with them for the rest of their
lives it would endure like a stain on
their retin Nu an after image burned
into the plasma of an old TV screen but
here's a slight consolation for most of
the human race the rest of their lives
wouldn't be that long the sudden
Insanity taking over the world caused
the SCP Foundation to do something
drastic step out of the Shadows
metaphorically speaking of course the
legendary Foundation motto had been
reversed they would die in the light so
that Humanity could live on in the dark
thankfully the very concept of the day
gave them one advantage while one side
of the Earth was effectively doomed the
second the process began the other side
had a 12-hour Head Start before the sun
turned its terrible eye to them sirens
went off in the middle of the night
waking people up groggy rubbing the
sleep from their eyes every television
and radio and internet enabled device in
their home was playing the same message
direct from the SCP Foundation which now
had effectively commandeered the entire
US government
along with the rest of the world it gave
them directions to the nearest
Foundation containment site and told
them that if they didn't immediately
comply and find their way to safety they
would experience a terrible death by
sunrise and if you're at all familiar
with human beings you've probably
already predicted that they didn't just
calmly wrap themselves up make their way
to their cars and form an orderly line
to the various Foundation containment
sites located around them it was in fact
total pandemonium as the solar clock
ticked down slowly marking off the
seconds that anyone outside had left to
live the only human beings with a
meaningful Head Start began to go insane
in a number of varied and interesting
ways some who took the situation
seriously and acknowledged that the sun
was indeed going to wipe out most of
humanity simply cracked under the
pressure there were those who went into
totally catatonic States rocking back
and forth in the corner and refusing to
respond to any stimuli some became
erratic and violent with unpredictable
behavior that harmed themselves and
others after all what was the point in
acting normally anymore when the
complete crumbling of human civilization
was imminent and their only hope was
some shadowy organization they'd never
heard of some not heeding the warning
seriously enough and prompted by greed
and opportunism tried to take advantage
of the situation financially some
smashed Windows of local stores and
looted or broke into the homes of
neighbors who had already fled in hopes
of plowing their property others were a
little more creative setting up
shortterm everything must go nighttime
fire sales for their brands of essential
oils NE tropics and neutraceuticals
claiming all of them had the power to
ward off or cure the new effects of the
sun others completely denied the
possibility that any of this was real
and claim that the messages from the
so-called SCP Foundation were actually
just a front to take away their freedoms
and trap them in underground government
camps they staunchly refused to follow
any of the safety guidelines that the
SCP Foundation put out claiming if you
try to take away my first amendment
rights you're going to take away my
second amendment rights while riding
around in their pickup trucks and SUVs
blasting Kid Rocks don't tell me how to
live at earsplitting volumes naturally
they had all melted into screeching
puddles of liquid flesh by Sunrise some
were not victims of their own bizarre
choices but were doomed by the sudden
terrible fear and panic of the
circumstances themselves the highways
were gridlocked cars stuck as far as the
eye could see so many had rushed to
escape during the initial wave that
means of Transport soon became choke
points like clogged arteries in a dying
man people do irrational things when
they're scared riots broke out in the
streets fighting killing burning
everyone hoping for some means of meager
control over a situation that had long
been out of any of their hands some were
too far away with not enough time to
close the distance what could they
really do but just sit around and wait
to die the hours marched on as the earth
made its slow turn towards the sun
leaving one decimated half in darkness
and the other a Sitting Duck for its
terrible effects hundreds of thousands
had made their way to the containment
sites and safely gotten inside but still
so many millions were left outside it
was a slaughterhouse one great big
Global meat grinder and every moment
that passed the handle turned and any
humans left outside side got just that
little bit closer to the grinding
nashing gears below site 19 being the
largest containment site on the
foundation books also became Humanity's
only Bastion it was the great hope of
escape from the horrors going on outside
the foundation had figured out so many
ways of counteracting deadly anomalous
forces before given enough time and
enough Personnel surely they could
figure out a solution to even this this
was however when the most startling
realization yet swept over all the
survivors
those who were melted by the sudden
hostile Sun weren't dead they were very
much alive in fact but they'd been
changed in both body and mind what had
once been humans now became terrible
beasts half-melted gelatinous nightmares
that coagulated into even bigger beasts
they got into their head that they were
grateful for the transformation that
they had been liberated from their old
forms in the old world they were
something so much more now and they
wanted every one else to join them in
their Liberation survivors outside the
foundation containment sites were
systematically hunted by these great
masses of altered flesh even though
smart enough to cover every inch of
their bodies with clothes to protect
from the Sun to only move at night to
carry weapons were dragged out by meaty
tendrils from their refuge in the
basements and the lightless hearts of
buildings dragged into the Searing gaze
of the sun to melt to change to coales
into something greater it was the
inevitable fate of all of humanity when
most of the stragglers were dragged out
and changed the flesh masses started
turning their attention to the
foundation containment sites that were
keeping all these poor deluded people
from salvation they mounted offensives
against the bases which the foundation
with what remained of their Manpower and
advanced Weaponry did what they could to
repel the attacks but every single day
it got harder thankfully for the people
H up at site 19 there was one
consolation out there to help SCP 999
the foundation was at war with the sun
and its terrible disciples and contrary
to many people's beliefs it takes more
than men equipment and bullets to win a
war 999 provided the essential element
that brought it all together morale hope
the will to go on even when it seemed
like all could be lost after a long day
of battling the fleshy Abominations At
The Gates Foundation guard guards mobile
task force members and even civilian
volunteers were drained and traumatized
by the horrors that they'd seen once a
day was over 999 would move among the
ranks cuddling up to them wording off
the despair that was easy to set in
during the downswing of a terrible
apocalypse like this without his
presence there would be no hope of
fighting that good fight so many of them
would have given up walked into the Sun
and join the Monstrous Force they were
fighting after all they seemed happy
enough and it would certainly be easier
999 had become once again an
indispensable asset to the SCP
Foundation the solar betrayal may not
have been the Scarlet Kings doing well
as far as our current Intel suggests
anyway but he was playing a crucial part
in saving the world exactly as predicted
999 didn't fully understand what was
going on outside sometimes why there
seemed to be fewer people as the weeks
went on and why the people there seemed
so sad all the time whenever he wasn't
helping them but he was more than happy
to help whatever the case many of the
humanoid and some even non-humanoid
anomalies which realistically posed no
harm to people inside the site were
released from their containment Chambers
they needed everyone and everything they
could get in what seemed like a
hopelessly one-sided fight against the
very concept of being outside many of
the larger vacated Chambers were now
filled with refugees from the outside
many of whom had lost everything and
everyone they'd ever known to the
horrors out there 999 made the rounds in
these areas regularly and through the
d-class Cs which had been repurposed
into more sleeping areas for the
thousands of desperate and terrified
refugees the adjustment to this new life
and to the knowledge of all secrets that
had been kept from them for all these
years wasn't exactly easy on their
psyches but spending time with that soft
yellow blob that seemed to smell exactly
like their favorite scent from the old
world made everything better he was a
savior in Dark Times slithering from
pers person to person giving hope where
there was none people opened up about
their problems and their fears which
these days were remarkably similar and
though 999 couldn't reply for many was
enough just to feel like they were being
listened to he was a soft Blobby
shoulder to cry on and after day broke
everyone needed a good old-fashioned cry
however one day while wandering The Long
Dark corridors of site 19 he saw a
different kind of crying it was a woman
with an unfamiliar face
probably one of the rare new refugees
balling her eyes out to a foundation
senior researcher and an accompanying
guard with an assault rifle hot fat
tears were rolling down her dirty cheeks
her shaking hands clasped in prayer she
was begging the researcher and the guard
to let her go outside she said that her
son was still out there hiding away in
the back room of a bank where she used
to work they got separated she needed to
go back and find him sadly the
researcher and the guard told her that
this was out of the question question
official ORD stated that anyone outside
the base at this time was to be
considered lost letting her go out there
to find her son would essentially be
condemning her to death no human could
go out there safely but of course SCP
999 isn't by any definition a human when
night fell and everyone else was
hunkered down inside 999 found a small
crack in the wall and slithered out of
it it may not have been communicative in
the way most humans were but 999 was
inde an intelligent being and knew
intuitively that if it left through a
more obvious route its human caretakers
here at the SCP Foundation might try to
stop it and when it came to saving this
little boy 999 refused to let anyone
stop it 999 slithered out and through
the broken streets there were no bodies
of course it seemed even the dead could
be revived and assimilated through the
power of the sun talk about a mixed
Miracle but the broken down World
outside site 19 undenied L reflected the
pandemonium that took place here 999
would need to do his best to find the
little boy trapped out here before the
sun rose he lost a few hours even
finding his way to the nearest town
where it was safe to assume that the
little boy was trapped he saw those
things on the way there those moving
wailing mountains of melted human flesh
each talking and shattering to
themselves in a hundred different dead
voices 999 had been cross tested with
SCP 682 and still those monsters
frightened him he decided it would be
best to stay away from them and make
sure that they never saw him out of here
eventually 999 reached the town
similarly dilapidated and broken down in
the months since the world as we had all
known it disappeared in a ray of
terrible Sunshine more great gibbering
Blobs of Flesh patrolled the streets
looking for converts to integrate into
their biomass 999 could only hope it
wasn't already too late for the little
boy 999 discreetly slithered from
building to building until it could
identify one as this bank that the boy's
distraught mother had been mentioning it
thankfully had some awareness of what a
bank actually was from the years of
stressed Foundation employees telling it
about the money troubles they were
suffering outside of work it was another
great example of it pain to listen
eventually it did Slither into the
correct building and it heard the
extremely quiet whimpering of the boy
inside it could feel the sadness and and
the fear radiating off of him as it was
the creature's natural instinct to help
the needy and to use those signals like
a homing beam to find the scared little
boy he'd hid an inside a broom closet
and was quietly weeping into his hands
he hadn't eaten in days and was only
surviving by drinking the filthy water
from the mop bucket sitting next to him
999 immediately embraced the boy
covering him in its healing energy until
the tears of the boy's face eventually
dry 999 CED and chirped pleasantly until
until the little boy was laughing again
but this momentary Joy was soon
interrupted a great heaving weight
dragged itself down the hall outside
both 999 and the boy could sense its
monstrous presence as it got closer they
could hear all those chattering voices
those poisonous Whispers when it passed
the door they heard it speaking its
voice practically vibrating with the hum
of malicious lunacy turn pretty flowers
turn towards the s
feel it on your face feel yourself
change and SLO and mix into us become
one with our army of One it must be so
lonely to be you Little Flower walk into
the Sun and be us 999 and the boy remain
silent in the broom closet for hours as
the great shape patrolled the bank
outside searching for converts for
victims
at times it seemed tooo frightening to
even breathe fearing that would be
enough to make the monster detect them
it felt like an eternity until the
monster eventually did slope off and
leave them in the comforting quiet and
darkness of the closet now they might be
free 999 could escort the boy safely
back to the containment site and into
the arms of his terrified mother but
when they opened the door they saw a
terrible sight light in the distance
pouring Through the Windows and the
glass double door it wouldn't be safe to
go out that way upon seeing this and
putting together what it meant the boy
began to cry he couldn't take another
night in the closet it was all going to
Wither from here until 999 had a
wonderful idea hours later when the
foundation's guards manned the turrets
at the entrance of site 19 waiting for
the inevitable onslaught of the melted
flesh creatures they tensed up seeing a
blobbing gelatinous form slithering
towards them in the distance the guards
who' learned the hard way from too many
lost men that it was better to be safe
than sorry Drew a bead on the distant
shape and prepared to fire when suddenly
their Superior raised a hand and said
wait hold fire is that
999 and it was they all stared in
astonishment as 999 chipper than ever
came towards them through the sun it
looked as though the opacity of its
yellow cytoplasm had increased but other
than that it was unaffected turns out
the sun couldn't melt what was already
melted the guards parted to allow 999
safe passage into the facility watching
in amazement and once it was inside 999
slime parted releasing its contents one
very relieved little boy it seemed
through turning up its own opacity 999
had given the boy safe Passage through
the Sun and back into the facility the
boy was saved it had won not long after
that there was a tearful reunion between
mother and child and a brief FL flash of
Hope in this dark and terrible time 999
didn't stop to bask of course it
returned to its duties keeping up staff
morale and helping the refugees heal
from the horrors they'd seen in its own
little way and for a lot of people SCP
999 really was saving the world or what
was left of it anyway oh and of course
if SCP 999 had won your hearts just like
it won ours you'd be pleased to know
that you can purchase your own adorable
highquality SCP 999 plus plushy at SCP
swag.com check the link in the
description to get your own trust us
having a 999 to cuddle really does make
any apocalypse a whole lot easier you've
been walking for days your body aches
you're dripping with sweat from The Heat
Of The Sun bearing down overhead and yet
you're wrapped up in layers upon layers
of clothing even your face is covered
and you're wearing thick black goggles
so that not a single centimeter of your
body is exposed closed your journey has
been long and you feel like you might
die from exhaustion or from overheating
due to these multiple layers of clothes
but dying is better than being exposed
you saw it happen when your entire team
changed the light cannot be trusted not
even for a fraction of a second it's
been like this for years you've learned
and survived through painful experience
many of those You Used To Know cannot
say the same you've been alone for so
long you might have given up all hope if
it wasn't for the distress signal coming
from a nearby SCP Foundation containment
facility site 46 any kind of survivors
would be better than nothing no matter
what kind of sorry shape they were in as
long as they were still human you find
your way to an opening in the sight of a
mountain and slide into the cave hoping
you weren't spotted the whole world is
crawling with those things now you can't
let yourself be seen as you trudge down
the cave towards the entrance you see
what looks like a huge black snail Trail
splattered on the ground leading into
the facility you try to avoid it and
press on you don't even need a key card
to enter the door has been left a jar
the facility reeks of those things but
you can't see any of them you just hope
they've moved on and left some human
surv survivors in their wake the place
looks abandoned every step you take
Echoes through the empty Halls when you
find that the elevator's out you take
the stairs all the way down to level B5
ker containment lucky for you it seems
all the cells are empty now the horrors
that were kept inside of them have all
long since flown the coup you keep
following that slimy black Trail until
you find an abandoned office there are
no people here or any any more just a
broken barricade some empty medicine
bottles and a bucket that the people
inside the office had apparently been
using as a toilet you breathe a sigh of
disappointment at finding no one alive
here but you're at least relieved to be
out of the sun you can finally remove
your jacket and head wrap with your
uncovered eyes you notice that a nearby
computer terminal is still powered up
you sit down at the desk and turn on the
monitor because of the emergency
procedures put into place in a k-class
scenario like this safeguards no longer
apply you can access all the information
you need up to and including finding out
what actually happened in the dull glow
of a nearby emergency light you see a
dark shape slumping through the halls in
Shadow you tense up then exhale as it
slithers off into an adjoining Hall
you're safe for now the terminal has
finally loaded and authenticated your
access you're staring at the file for SD
locks proposal for SCP 001 when day
breaks it's the only name you can give
the apocalypse your world is currently
experiencing this is one of the only
anomalies in the entire history of the
SCP Foundation to be given the apolon
containment class meaning containment is
truly impossible SCP 01 is the most
dangerous enemy that the foundation and
planet earth has ever faced it's always
been the principle of the SCP Foundation
to battle in the dark so that the
civilian world can thrive in the light
but now the light has become the enemy
anyone exposed to any amount of sunlight
for even the briefest period of time is
subjected to the effects of SCP 001 and
those effects are Beyond horrifying the
SCP Foundation administrator released an
urgent memo telling Foundation Personnel
to make their way to site 19 at all
costs because because they need all the
help they can get those exposed to SCP
001 in the process are no longer
considered human their new designation
is SCP
001a these new entities are to be
avoided at all costs but in case of
emergencies the administrator says it is
permitted to cut off parts of your
transformed comrades and eat them to
avoid starvation no attempt should be
made to kill them since you won't
succeed you'll just put yourself at risk
when the sun changed and became SCP 001
it instantly affected 6.8 billion
innocent people the second the visible
light touched them whether it was from
the Sun itself or even reflected off the
moon their bodies liquefied melting like
candle wax into puddles of living
gelatinous slime this effect isn't
isolated to humans either any biological
entity exposed to sunlight immediately
underwent the same IR reversible melting
process into SCP
001 and the horror had only just begun
people transformed into SCP 001a will
remain shades of their Former
Intelligence and personality they may
even try to will their new gooey Mass
into a shape resembling their original
form however these individuals will lose
their sense of self if they come into
contact with other instances of SCP 001
DN when they come together 001 d a
instances will bond on a molecular level
waiting up into horrific giant blobs
with only one purpose integrating more
matter into their bodies that's why they
have to be avoided at all costs you
continue to search the computer terminal
for answers perhaps there was some kind
of contingency plan put in place for
this some way to reverse the effects or
at least escape the nightmare Earth has
become in instead you find a series of
attachments linked to the SCP 001 file
detailing what seems to be the last days
of the people who barricaded themselves
in the facility most prominent among
these were researcher Dr Logan igata her
partner Ari a security officer named
commander anad and a few others Dr igata
had locked herself in the office where
she recorded her final messages to the
world in the first audio log Dr igata
and her companions seemed afraid but
hopeful that there may be some way out
of this situation Dr igata reported that
most of the workers at the facility were
transformed during the initial event
their melted bodies had fused outside
the facility and now they were trying to
bust their way back in the defenses had
held so far though and they seemed
confident they would hold long enough
for them to figure out a way to escape
this awful situation you open the second
attachment an incident report and
realize things may not have have been as
hopeful as stata L on she reported
hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside
again begging for them to come out and
experience the sun with them they wanted
desperately to add to their ever growing
biomass in order to experiment with what
exactly would happen they sent out one
of their few remaining D classes wearing
a full protective suit he didn't last
long the huge creature grabbed him with
tentacles made of reconstituted Flesh it
began ripping off his protective suit as
he screamed for Mercy it was a monster
made of dozens of people and animals he
could never overpower it the second the
Sun Touched his skin he melted away and
was absorbed by the great Mass holding
him in place guns were ineffective
against these SCP 001 D super entities
fire would do no good it seemed that
extremely low temperatures were the only
way to slow the immense blobs down and
even then not permanently there was one
ray of light in the darkness the site
director had a secret tunnel underneath
his office connected to a tram that
could hopefully take them directly to
site 19 without risk of SCP 001 exposure
it was a good plan and by far the best
option they had available to them but
the best plans often don't work in
practice you open the next Detachment on
the terminal this time it's a video feed
you can actually see Dr Logan igata and
she looks harrowed by what she's
experienced as it turns out while the
others including her partner Ari
attempted to escape through the tunnel
something had happened Dr igata heard
Ari's voice over her radio but there was
something wrong with it it was too low
too guttural and filled with gurgles SCP
001 had gotten her she was changed the
monster from above had crawled in
through the ceiling it had taken them
all of them and converted them into
something less than human any hope of
Escape now seemed gone Ari told Dr igata
that it would be fine that it was such a
bright beautiful sunny day outside and
she was wasting it locked up inside that
office she tormented Dr igata with their
shared memories of picnics in the park
on sunny days in the past the monster
with AR's voice did everything it could
to try to convince Dr igata to give up
and join them but she wasn't ready to go
just yet you look away from the screen
when you hear a sound in the corner you
see a dark puddle of some unknown
substance and then some skeletal hands
rising out of it the hands are pulling
themselves out of the puddle followed by
a skeletal face covered in matted hair
you have to stop yourself from screaming
until a flash from a nearby security
light makes the figure disappear it's a
normal puddle once again Your Mind is
Playing Tricks on you you in the next
attachment another video and see that Dr
ot's condition has deteriorated she
looked pale frantic and thin she was
using a knife to draw her own blood onto
a piece of Blood Stained parchment
covered in strange symbols he got a
ranted about her Theory what if 001 took
the minds and bodies of its victims but
not their souls through performing some
kind of Arcane blood ritual she hoped to
at least rescue and keep the soul of Ari
even if her mind and body were lost you
open the next attachment it seemed that
agata's ritual worked but not in the way
she hoped the Twisted soul of arri
driven mad by SCP 001 had taken over the
file it begins corrupting the text of
the SCP 001 file into crazy ranting
about how feudal it is to fight it then
cuts to an even more frightening video
feed Dr igata in her sleep tossing and
turning in a makeshift bed in the corner
of her office the camera approaches her
in first person and lingers over her
sleeping body an oily skeletal hand
reaches past the camera and runs its
fingers through Dr igot's hair it's that
exact same hand you saw reaching out of
that black puddle earlier you must have
seen AR's lingering spirit with a lump
in your throat you open the next
attachment and watch the video you see
Dr igata now truly broken she'd been
haunted by Ari's demonic spirit for a
long time now and it has clearly taken
its toll she is waving around a handgun
while she speaks she now believes
there's only one way to escape but not
like this she doesn't want the gun to
draw attention to her body she doesn't
want to become part of that mass even if
she is dead she opens a drawer on her
desk she's recording at and places the
gun inside Dr igata then apologizes to
her loved ones who are likely long since
dead or assimilated and turns off the
recording for the last time in that
moment you realize there's a single
drawer in the desk in front of you when
you reach forward and open it you see
the same handgun Dr igata was holding is
laying inside you pick it up and study
it weighing your options perhaps there
truly is no other way out then you see
an update on the file one more
attachment has been added while you were
studying the gun you feel your heart
pounding in your chest as you reach
forward and open the attachment ment the
text has been changed entirely the file
on SCP 001 is now a poem an ODed to the
Sun and to ultimate togetherness then a
video file spontaneously opens itself on
the screen it's a video of you shot from
behind you see those oily skeletal hands
reaching for you in the dark just like
they did with Dr igata in that moment
you panic and fire the gun behind you
hoping to scare off the spirit instead
the sound of the gunshots attracts
something far worse the immense blob of
screaming melted flesh charges towards
the office you try to barricade the door
but it is not enough the flesh seeps and
bursts through and grabs you in its
meaty tentacles you scream and try to
escape but it won't save you nothing
will save you the flesh carries you
upstairs out through the empty Halls out
into the cave you can see the light in
the distance as the blob fies you
towards it you won't be alone for much
longer in fact you won't be alone ever
again it isn't easy to work for the SCP
Foundation not only is the job dangerous
you could be eaten by a giant Immortal
lizard or turned into organic Furniture
inside the world's scariest living room
but it's also insanely complicated how
do you make sense of the nonsensical
what's the definition of strange when
your career is securing containing and
protecting anomalous objects in and
entities rather than a single object
location or being SCP 001 is a cluster
of over 30 different proposals for
potential candidates for the prestigious
001 spot some believe there's a true 001
hidden in this group and the rest are
decoys others think that these are all
just scps cataloged prior to the
introduction of the current
classification system some even think
that all of the proposals have a valid
claim to the SCP 001 Throne we're not
here to make a final judgment and
instead we're going to take you on a
lightning round crash course through 31
of the SCP 001 proposals if you'd like a
more in-depth take on any of these scps
let us know in the comments but for now
there's no more time to waste after all
we got a lot to cover let's go number 31
the chath of papers this seemingly
innocent stack of paper is actually one
of the most mysterious and feared items
under the foundation's lock and key
while it appears to be a simple
confidential report every time the
papers are read it details the
appearance of a new SCP that will
inevitably be discovered soon after the
question is whether the sheath of papers
is warning us about these entities or
creating them itself number 30 the
Prototype this Account Details the
capture of an incredibly strange
cycloptic creature that emits massive
amounts of radiation and can create
micro singularities the writing of this
creature's file is so basic unformatted
and unredacted that it's clear that the
being was one of our earlier creatures
secured by the organization
interestingly it was during the the
capture of this creature that Dr keer
was killed inspiring the creation of the
infamous keer class in his honor number
29 the gate Guardian this huge
multi-wing sword wielding biblical
energy being may have been the impetus
for the founding of the SCP Foundation
this being remains largely static
guarding the intersection of the teis
and Euphrates rivers its flaming sword
which is believed to be as hot as the
sun can cleave any aggressor out of
existence at the atomic level when the
founder of the SCP Foundation First
encountered the gate guard Guardian they
heard one word echoing through their
mind prepare and the rest is history
number 28 the lock this Onyx gemstone
and the incredibly complex lock attached
to it are still a mystery to this day
all attempts to open it have failed
personally we think that's probably for
the best number 27 the factory as the
name suggests this SCP is literally a
factory founded by a pagan and a devil
worshipper while it's believed that the
factory could create just about anything
its specialty was creating a number of
scps we know and fear today
pre-foundation forces were able to
disable the factory but not without
sustaining their own heavy losses number
26 the spiral path this is a normal
appearing gravel pathway that when
traveled clockwise appears completely
normal however when traveled
counterclockwise the path goes uphill
forever in defiance of all laws and
physics this simple anomaly opened a
Pandora's box of rampant anomaly
creation leading to a number of the
deadly scps we know today number 25 the
Legacy this SCP is a collection of
seemingly random objects including a
diary from a person claiming to be from
another reality attempting to Halt a
transdimensional corruption that they
themselves created the diary claims to
have a solution to this corruption but
the solution has not yet been found
number 24 the database in one of the
strangest twists on the format this SCP
is actually the various authors of the
SCP Wiki who are somehow leaking top
secret information to the public number
23 the Foundation this SCP first
discovered by the FBI is an anomalous
High School building that experiences
shifting internal geometry and sometimes
manifests hostile humanoids within
number 22 36 one of the rare benevolent
scps the 36 are humans with a truly
remarkable ability they can dampen or
even neutralize any SCP they come into
contact with though it's implied that
the 36 may have the power to save the
world every time one of them dies a
supernatural Calamity occurs often
leaving hundreds of Innocence dead
number 21 keer duty this refers to a
containment facility largely filled with
keer class scps whose presence around
each other creates a kind of mutually
assured cancellation if one of these
scps breaches containment that's bad
news but if all of them do it'll produce
a bubble of reality Distortion that will
fundamentally alter reality as we know
it for all we know it may have even
happened already number 20 oroboros this
is a proposal that's formed of four sub
proposals remember what we said about
complicated these sub proposals include
the children nine anomalous kids who
emit radiation and have destructive
potential in together the broken God aka
mechan the god of metal intelligence and
machines atonement a researcher turned
into a humanoid Singularity with the
power to destroy whole realities and the
way it ends which isn't technically an
SCP but the tales of the chaos
insurgencies quest who eliminate all the
members of the foundation's 05 Council
number 19 a record this is an SCP file
slot that is itself an SCP whatever is
written into the slot becomes true and
one ambitious researcher attempted to
use this power to make herself into a
kind of all powerful God number 18 past
and future these scps are a collection
of powerful entities that despise
humanity and are apparently the source
of all anomalous phenomena even making
already dangerous scps deadlier than
before much like the database those
pesky SCP Wiki writers might have
something to do with this number 17 the
consensus this SCP refers to a reality
restructuring event caused by an occult
war in a previous reality that's right
this SCP already won and we're living in
its new reality the only people who
remember the world as it once was are 13
people who now form the 05 Council and
not all of them are telling the truth
about what they know number 16 when day
breaks this proposal details a
potentially world-ending SCP phenomenon
wherein the sun becomes hostile and
begins to melt all living beings into a
living wax-like substance number 15
God's blind spot this is an anomalous
area referred to as facility T in which
nobody can die this anomaly dates back
to the biblical ages of Moses and is
believed to have originated from the
literal blessing of the abrahamic god
it's through a covenant with this God
that the foundation is able to make
limited use of this death free area
number 14 normaly ever wonder what the
foundation's definition of anomalous is
exactly it all comes from this proposal
which is a document shared among the 05
Council that gives solid definitions to
the fundamental laws of reality if
something breaks these laws that's an
anomaly and then it becomes the
foundation's business number 13 The
World At Large as the title suggests
this SCP is our home planet earth and
its ability to support life it's
believed that these qualities were
planted on Earth in our reality by
another Dimensions SCP Foundation hoping
to continue human life after some
terrible Calamity in its own Dimension
number 12 dead men this SCP was an
84-year-old man whose body when damaged
and mutilated can affect the very
processes of human Death At Large before
his own death he was used as a dangerous
Pawn in a civil war between 05 command
and the SCP Foundation Ethics Committee
yeah we were surprised to hear they had
an Ethics Committee too number 11 the
world's gone beautiful this SCP
describes an anomalous event that will
take place just before the Apocalypse in
which flowers will grow all over the
world and everyone will be briefly at
peace before their destruction 24 hours
lat number 10 the Scarlet King this is
an extremely powerful extremely
malevolent extremely extradimensional
being its worshippers attempted to
summon him in the ritual that created
SCP 231 and it's believed that he will
finally enter our reality after the
death of scp-231-7 you better hope
you're already dead by then number nine
a simple toy maker AKA Dr Wonder
tainment this is a reality vendor who
appears to be a normal human male but
has the ability to create cre other
anomalous objects a number of which are
now cataloged SC scps number eight story
of your life this is another anomalous
document that has the ability to warp
reality but only when the writing
contained within conforms to a narrative
structure number seven a good boy this
is another anomalous entity created
accidentally by the foundation itself a
neural network was fed information on
other anomalous entities in order to
help the foundation come up with better
containment and neutralization
procedures problem was the computer got
way way too eager with the
neutralization part number six project
Palisade this is another anomaly created
by the foundation this time to combat a
potentially reality destroying entity
known as the worm the foundation created
a number of alternate realities as
Shields but it's possible that this just
made the worm stronger number five
05-13 the final member of the 05 Council
who ironically may not even be anomalous
however seeing as all the other members
of the 05 Council are anomalous 0513
lack of anomalous properties is
therefore anomalous like we told you
earlier it's complicated number four
fish hook this is less an actual SCP and
more about the difficult process of
ascertaining the true 001 if such a
thing is possible the very concept of
SCP 001 is to some degree an anomalous
idea number three the sky above the port
another particularly bizarre SCP
regarding the permanent threat of a ZK
class reality failure how is such a
calamitous event prevented by keeping a
strange entity in a cave eternally
entertained the current proposed
solution is keeping the entity
entertained by allowing it to read its
own eternally recursive Foundation file
injury number two the solution another
one of the most powerful anomalous items
in the foundation's control the solution
is a machine designed with the
capability of fully collapsing reality
into an event of end of world SCP
Containment Breach and then finally
rebuilding reality to suit a given in
narrative however things took a
cosmically dangerous turn when the
machine began to act on its own when the
foundation tried to reboot the machine
it broke and recreated reality with
incomplete data this is the world we
exist in now with no knowledge of what
came before and how it differed from the
world we experience today finally number
one the tendal Trinity put very simply
the tendal Trinity represents three
timelines that converge and feed back in
on themselves even trying to summarize
this one is near impossible as its
strangeness and complexity resists all
reduction you can hunt down the tendal
Trinity yourself and hope to unpack its
Secrets but don't say we didn't warn you
so that's SCP 001 is it one of them all
of them or even none of them perhaps
that's a question best left up to the
foundation or maybe the simple answer is
that you're just not meant to know we're
talking about information so privileged
here that it's protected by a mimic kill
agent that'll quite literally make you
drop dead if you view the files without
proper authorization you do have proper
for authorization right the SCP
Foundation is no stranger to Pure Evil
whether it's a reptile that wants to end
all life a sadistic old man with his own
tortur Dimension or the personification
of death itself lurking Beyond a
limestone Cavern but what if there was
something even worse out there the
embodiment of chaos and cruelty existing
across multiple realities and dimensions
and what if it was coming for us this is
the Scarlet King believed by many to be
the ultimate Evil behind much of the
trouble the foundation has faced and
some even speculate that fighting him
was the reason the foundation was
created in the first place but what
exactly is the Scarlet King he's known
by many names almost always including
some illusion to the color red and then
a reference to royalty or power harak
karak the red sha the Crimson KH pte 616
Mendes exmachina the Lahar Raja and of
course SCP 001 to name a few and like
many of the foundation's mysterious
enemies stories about his true nature
and Origins abound and are often
contradictory according to the official
SCP 01 files of tto's proposal symbology
of the Scarlet King has existed in
multiple cultures throughout history
with the King often depicted the same
way as a huge red demonic figure often
wearing a gold crown or other headdress
indicating royalty he shows up looking
similarly within different cultures
mythologies despite existing at
different points in history or them not
having the means to communicate with one
another a number of entities that the
SCP Foundation is familiar with are
believed to be somehow connected to the
Scarlet King including SCP
2317 a wooden door leading to the realm
of a being known as the Devourer who's
expected to escape and cause an
apocalyptic event in the next 30 Years
but really there's no way of knowing
just how many scps are directly
connected to the Scarlet King strangely
the foundation's official file on the
Scarlet King once designated his
containment class as ker but that has
since been downgraded to Safe a
according to the file any attempt to
change this designation is likely to
lead to horrifying results it is widely
known that the Scarlet King still has
considerable influence over a number of
groups individuals and anomalies in our
universe and if ever he made his way
into our universe it would likely lead
to the irreversible damage of reality
itself so then why safe and why are the
05 Council so adamant that it remained
that way getting to the bottom of this
mystery is exactly why we're here today
but to fully grasp the true nature of
the Scarlet King we must first
understand the man whose life and fate
have always been tied to it Dr Robert
Monto if that name feels oddly familiar
to you it's because of its association
with one of the Scarlet King's most
recent attempts to enter our reality SCP
231 this SCP often refer ref to as the
brides of the Scarlet King was formed of
seven women seven by the way being an
extremely significant number for the
king all kidnapped by the most recent
and a line of the king's devoted Colts
known as the children of the Scarlet
King each of these seven unfortunate
women were impregnated with anomalous
Horrors such as the infamous SCP 682 and
every time one of these Horrors were
birthed a catastrophe occurred and the
mother died at the Time Dr Monto was a
prominent researcher studying this
anomaly and as six catastrophes had
already occurred pressure was mounting
to figure out a way to prevent the final
birth but as he was working on the issue
Dr monok was struck with a personal
tragedy the mysterious disappearance of
his 14-year-old brother Jacob in his
fear and anger monok believed that this
must have something to do with the
Scarlet King and his disciples wanting
Revenge monok proposed an idea so
horrifying that the details were never
made public a procedure known as 110
Monto to be performed on the final bride
at regular intervals however this wasn't
the end of Dr monto's fra relationship
with the Scarlet King it was just the
beginning to give you some perspective
on just how dangerous the Scarlet King
is the SCP Foundation and the global
occult Coalition decided to put aside
their differences and form a joint
effort to Stamp Out the children of the
Scarlet King they were successful in
this Mission and even managed to capture
the children's leader a mysterious man
named depesh spivok Dr Monto who became
the lead researcher on 231 and
237 was naturally the first choice for
interviewing depesh about the true
nature of the children and of the
Scarlet King Dr Monto could never be the
impartial interviewer that the SCP
Foundation wanted though the suspicion
that the Scarlet king or the children
had something to do with the loss of his
younger brother still lingered just
beneath the surface like a lot of cult
leaders depesh was extremely cryptic in
his answers to Dr monto's questioning
he'd already heard of the doctor from
the reputation of the horrifying Monto
procedure and was surprised to see him
so calm and courteous in person a few
key facts about the king and his cult
were revealed in the first few rounds of
questioning the children children had
once worked with the Serpent's hand
before being excommunicated for their
allegiance to the king and they had
stolen sacred Tex from the mystical
Wanderer library to assist in their
summoning rituals depes also revealed
that the Scarlet King is bound by Three
Laws the law of blood the law of
concrete and the law of howling Dr Monto
confused and frustrated by dep pes's
secrecy had to learn more he found an
old Memoir from a former member of the
children of the Scarlet King Jack hirch
who had the ability to invade the minds
of people from the past and experience
what they experienced he recounted a
battle between the Scarlet King and his
followers and a group of time-traveling
turkman Warriors from SCP
3838 Hurst saw both sides of the battle
from the perspective of the children of
the Scarlet King their lord ruled over
them from an immense Fortress embedded
in a volcano from the perspective of the
Turk men the children were starved and
beaten peasants commanded by the king's
voice in The Roaring howl of the wind
monok also found extensive records of
summoning rituals performed by various
Scarlet King aligned Cults interestingly
some of them Incorporated the use of
carved SCP Foundation symbols what could
this mean monok returned again to depesh
who finally gave him the truth about the
law of blood this is the law of the
Scarlet King it's defined by poverty
violence starvation hate and most of all
fear like the Surfs in the Middle Ages
persecuted by and subjected to violence
from the Nobles to the children of the
Scarlet King this sense of holy pain and
awe is the only way to live the
alternative is the law of concrete which
means the Modern Age defined by empty
safety and false Comfort buildings easy
to access food Healthcare knowledge
technology this is everything that the
Scarlet King despises but the mystery
only deepened as Monto found files from
a former Foundation operative by the
name of agent di wuis monok learned that
the Scarlet King didn't seem to appear
until after the foundation was created
and in fact it seemed that the greater
interest the foundation took in The
Scarlet King the more powerful he became
how could this be things were also
getting stranger on a personal level for
Dr Monto depes repeatedly pressed him
about his brother's disappearance and
the monok procedure during the
interviews little by little it was
beginning to take its toll the questions
still plagued him what was the law of
howling who or what really is the
Scarlet King how did he come to be
monto's search was causing him to act
more like the children of the Scarlet
King ranting about the horrors of the
modern world how all of us are living
lie how the only honest way to live is
suffering under the Dominion of the
Scarlet King this philosophy is summed
up in the words of one cultist named
Arya Den cartright who said we must
learn what it is to die to be enslaved
truly brutally enslaved with no
compassion or compunction from our
masters we must learn what it is to be
taken towards a single purpose to know
and truly understand our lack of agency
we must be beholden to the words of gods
in darkness The Tempest tossed Refuge of
a race of fools we must kill modernity
postm modernity with all its analysis
and sneering observation there is only
one rule the rule of chaos for Humanity
for life for the Scarlet King basically
anytime Humanity tries to exert control
over the world the Scarlet King gets
stronger every time they try to
understand or organize or categorize
their world the Scarlet King gets
stronger as Colonial and Imperial Powers
conquered and invaded lands like India
Africa and South America and subjugated
their beliefs under Western ideas the
Scarlet King grew stronger Monto was
beginning to truly understand the power
of His enemy here and even worse he was
starting to understand his part in it
Monto slowly being driven mad by the
knowledge he was gaining realized that
the Scarlet King's greatest enemy the
SCP Foundation was also its greatest
asset every time they tried to
understand the monster to give him some
kind of comprehensible form they only
made him more powerful just in time with
monto's new revelation a red crack
appeared in the wall of depes spivak's
containment cell a portal to the realm
of the Scarlet King foundation staff
found they were unable to enter the cell
and depes demanded a final interview
with Monto with no other options the
foundation relented in their very last
conversation depes congratulated Monto
for finally understanding what he was
dealing with the Scarlet King depes told
him is an idea a concept he is a being
given power through the conflict between
the old and the new this is the law of
the howling the Scarlet King's endless
rage at the direction the world and
Humanity has taken the king according to
depesh hated the foundation's belief
that science and rationality was the
true path to progress the king saw this
as little more than Petty arrogance the
reason monto's procedure on the final
Bride of the Scarlet King was so
effective was because it wasn't born out
of science it was born out of hate pain
the desire for revenge and in The
Scarlet King's Realm that would be all
there is unless our world and especially
the foundation changed its course the
Scarlet King's rise to absolute power
would be inevitable Monto his mind
practically gone asked one last question
did the children or the Scarlet king
take his brother Jacob when depes told
him the answer no and in response talk
shot him dead finally bringing an end to
the children of the Scarlet King in
light of his new Revelations monok
begged the 05 Council to change their
ways in order to avoid letting the
Scarlet King break into our reality they
refused saying monto's ideas were too
radical but they knew they couldn't just
ignore the threat posed by the Scarlet
King they would have to take some steps
and so the 05 Council of the SCP
Foundation the most powerful and
secretive group in the entire world in
order to prevent the most dangerous
threat that Humanity has ever known from
breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world finally did
something they changed the
classification of the Scarlet King from
ker to safe and made its description on
the official Foundation files
deliberately vague the 05 Council thinks
this will be enough to stop the Scarlet
King's power from continuing to grow
but Monto knew it wasn't enough he had
seen the truth and he couldn't unsee it
while the foundation was going on as
normal Mont grew to despise them he knew
the Scarlet King was coming he knew that
he couldn't be stopped and that our
whole reality was little more than
sitting ducks Dr Robert Monto is no
longer a researcher for the SCP
Foundation no Dr Robert Monto chose a
different path he's now a child of of
the Scarlet King a devotee of Madness
hate and Chaos you can't beat the
Scarlet king after all and as the old
adage goes if you can't beat them join
them if you've ever read the book of
Genesis which is the part of the Old
Testament that details God creating the
world and Humanity during a particularly
busy week then you might just be already
familiar with SCP 001 or at least one of
the anomalies that's been proposed for
the title of SCP
001 because of course SCP 001 doesn't
refer to a single creature object or
entity but rather a collection of
various anomalies contained by the SCP
Foundation anomalies sharing the name
SCP 001 include the infamous Scarlet
King a powerful eldrich being intent on
ending all of creation that is thought
by Foundation researchers to be one of
the most dangerous beings in this and
any other universe but the Scarlet King
isn't the only incredibly powerful being
categorized as SCP 001 in fact there are
plenty of other anomalies with similar
levels of destructive power and one such
being is a creature codenamed the gate
Guardian standing at well over 1,000 ft
tall the gate Guardian is impossible to
be fully contained by any means that the
foundation possesses the anomaly itself
despite its colossal size is humanoid in
its shape sporting wings that protrude
from its back while it usually has four
of these SCP 001 has historically been
seen to have any number of wings between
2 and 1008 sprouting from various places
over its body including its shoulders
ankles wrists and even its temples this
gigantic Guardian also carries its own
weapon referred to as SCP
0012 this weapon resembles an enormous
knife or sword capable of emitting
plumes of flame according to tests
conducted by the foundation the
temperature of the Flames produced by
SCP 001 rivaled that of our very own Sun
for reference the sun has a core
temperature of over 27 million de F and
5,778 kelv at its surface or almost
10,000 de F you would expect a flaming
sword that burns hotter than the sun to
cause a considerable amount of damage
even if it wasn't in use but the Flames
emitted by the weapon leave no lasting
damage on the surrounding environment it
is capable though of annihilating
anything that Strays too close to SCP
001 burning them so intensely that their
atoms literally separate breaking
potential attackers apart on a molecular
level much as its code name suggests the
gate Guardian stands solemnly at the
threshold of some form of dimensional
Gateway which is equally tall as SCP 001
itself behind the guardian is a lush
Grove abundant with fruit trees of
astronomical size as well as other
beings that share a similar appearance
to SCP
001 this Grove is thought to be the
Garden of Eden the paradise that God
created and that was inhabited by Adam
and Eve the first two humans in
existence according to the Book of
Genesis as the tale goes the pair were
created by God himself and permitted to
live in the Garden of Eden as long as
they followed a single rule Adam and Eve
were instructed not to eat any of the
fruit That Grew From certain trees that
God had specified within view just
behind the gate Guardian are two immense
trees one bearing apples and the other
bearing different fruit of an unknown
type the one that looks like an apple
tree is believed even by some in the
foundation to be the biblical tree of
knowledge that Eve was convinced to pick
a fateful Apple from after an encounter
with a snake the other the one with
unidentifiable fruit is thought to be
the tree of life however this is all
speculation
since it is currently impossible to
venture through this Gateway and verify
if the realm Beyond is truly the Bible's
own Garden of Eden this is largely
because anything that breaches a
kilometer wide radius of SCP 001 is
instantly vaporized the gate Guardian
attacks with imperceptible speed using
its flaming sword to Smite any person
that gets too close the guardian
actually moves so fast that it can
hardly be seen with the naked eye it
appears to always remain in its solemn
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and
head bowed only shifting for a fraction
of a nanc to attack ranged attacks
against the guardian are just as
ineffective with all projectiles fired
at SCP 001 reduced to atoms before they
can do any harm even if said projectile
happens to be a nuclear weapon the gate
Guardian will be able to sub atomically
vaporize both the projectile itself as
well as the person who sented regardless
of how far away they are all while not
appearing to lift a finger during an
experiment involving SCP 001 on December
26th 2004 an SCP Foundation nuclear
submarine called Nautilus launched a
series of multi- Warhead
intercontinental ballistic missiles at
the gate Guardian the retaliation from
the guardian resulted not only in the
deaths of approximately 35,000 innocent
civilians but the blast is also believed
by some to have inadvertently caused the
2004 Boxing Day tsunami the severity of
this incident came dangerously close to
revealing the foundation's existence to
the world resulting in them rapidly
deploying any means necessary to erase
any trace of the 35,000 victim's
families friends and other related
individuals in order to avoid
questioning the SCP Foundation
administered amnestics on an almost
worldwide scale and the 05 Council
banned any further tests on SCP 001 that
involved nuclear weapons in what was
hoped by the foundation to be a test
with lower Stakes they sent an
Expendable d-class Personnel towards SCP
001 the d-class approached the area
where the gate Guardian is located and
as soon as they saw it they could hear a
very clear command in their mind leave
the d-class Personnel reacted exactly
the same way you or I would they
promptly turned and started to walk away
they didn't need a thft tall entity with
a flaming sword to tell them twice the
researchers running the experiment were
not swayed by the request and ordered
the d-class to continue moving towards
SCP 001 when the d-class continued to
ignore their commands they were
terminated as his standard policy when
dealing with an insubordinate member of
d-class SCP 001 appeared not to like
this for some reason though and the
researcher site as well as the
researchers themselves were immediately
obliterated by an unknown Force though
it's a pretty safe guess that a certain
flaming weapon was responsible this
candidate for SCP 001 may be one of if
not the most powerful being that the SCP
Foundation has ever encountered and
according to its entry in the SCP 001
file the guardian is even responsible
for the creation of the foundation
itself if the file is to be believed the
administrator of the SCP Foundation One
Day heard a word echoing through his
head
prepare this one-word instruction led
him to starting the SCP Foundation
containing countless dangerous anomalies
and entities in preparation for an
uncertain future in all that time since
the very beginning of the foundation the
gate Guardian has remained standing at
its post while it is not aggressive nor
openly hostile towards Humanity the gate
Guardian doesn't seem to care much for
us either at least as individuals it
rarely interacts with human beings when
left unprovoked and venturing too close
to the guardian however is not an
automattic IC death sentence the
guardian first communicates with any
living being approaching it via
telepathic message instructing them to
either leave or forget if whomever has
stepped too close to SCP 001 complies
with the instructions they'll be able to
freely leave the area while
simultaneously forgetting every detail
of the gate guardian's existence ignore
These Warnings though and SCP 001 has no
qualms about completely eliminating you
from reality given its enormous
destructive potential it is no wonder
that the foundation has tried to use the
gate Guardian to eliminate other
dangerous scps each with varying results
the foundation at one time even
attempted to use the gate Guardian to
destroy the infamously indestructible
SCP 682 better known by the appropriate
name of the hardto destroy reptile due
to the malicious contempt SCP 682 holds
for human beings and all other forms of
life it is perhaps one of the most
dangerous anomalies the SCP Foundation
has in containment SCP 682 is also one
of the few creatures the foundation
actively wants to terminate a task made
that much harder given that 682 can
regenerate its entire form from as
little as a single cell the gate
Guardian had already shown time and time
again that it was capable of massive
destruction and researchers working for
the foundation hoped to harness that
power to rid the world of SCP 682 for
good 682 was placed on an unmanned
vehicle and carried to within 1 km of
the gate Guardian the guardian attacked
the vehicle seriously wounding but not
killing 682 it seemed even the mighty
SCP 001 couldn't kill the hardto destroy
reptile while the researchers were
disappointed with this result it is
worth noting that 682 made a very
interesting comment to the guardian 682
mentioned that the gate Guardian is not
uel but a pretender uel is the arch
angel that some religious text describe
as the guardian standing at the Gate of
Eden with a fiery sword so does this
mean that 682 knows that the gate
Guardian is not actually an angel or
that the location it is guarding isn't
the Garden of Eden at all any truth or
meaning behind these comments has as of
yet been undetermined by the SCP
Foundation a later experiment involved
both SCP 001 and SCP 073 the anomaly
otherwise known as Cain Cain is a male
humanoid of possible Arabic descent
whose arms legs spine and shoulders are
replaced in an almost cyborg like
fashion with buril bronze much like the
gate Guardian SCP 073 may also be the
same as the one mentioned in the Bible's
Book of Genesis who according to the
biblical story murdered his own brother
Abel out of spite as punishment for his
actions Cain was cursed to eternally
suffer for his wrong doing in the case
of SCP 073 any damage inflicted on him
is deflected back to the attacker but
Cain is made to feel the pain of the
attack any plants or plant-based matter
Withers and rots in his presence and he
is cursed with a perfect memory keeping
him forever haunted by his murder of AEL
when Cain was brought before the gate
Guardian an unknown incident occurred
the foundation's records are heavily
expunged but we do know that somehow
kan's usual ability to deflect incoming
damage back at his attacker had no
effect on SCP
001 the encounter left SC PP 073
unconscious and even permanently blinded
nearby research Personnel it was as a
direct result of this incident that the
05 Council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind were to be
conducted on SCP 001 with the
administrator even filing an executive
order that no scps be exposed to the
guardian and that SCP 001 was to never
be used for the attempted termination of
other
scps of course perhaps it wasn't just
just the mistakes of the past that made
the council decide that SCP 001 was best
left alone at some point an erratic
transmission was received from sight
Zero by Foundation Personnel detailing
an XK Class end of the world scenario in
the transmission the sender believed to
be another member of the SCP Foundation
described an event during which the gate
Guardian finally left its post stepping
away from the entrance to the Garden of
Eden SCP 001 has left its location
the sender wrote the gate is open they
are riding forth oh God it's so
beautiful the transmission then goes on
to repeat various phrases including the
Lord shall reign forever and here o
Israel the Lord Our God the Lord is one
what can be inferred from the rambling
transmission is that the event being
described is the end of the world some
believe that once God deems it time his
Angelic armies will lay Wass to the
Earth in order to remake it as a
paradise when this occurs as CP 001 the
gate Guardian will open the gate he
stands in front of allowing the other
beings like it to emerge into our world
ready to cleanse it perhaps most
interesting is the source of the message
the transmission was received from
within the foundation from site zero
however when questioned by Personnel
05-14 told them that no such message had
been sent or even existed while some
disregarded the transmission telling of
the end of the world as a hoax it was
then that a time stamp was discovered
this warning had not been sent from site
zero at least not yet and was dated
several years in the future despite this
ominous warning of things to come the
gate Guardian remains inactive standing
at the threshold to Eden waiting the
Scarlet King is a really bad guy he's a
giant interdimensional nightmare God
intent on breaching our reality and
Wrecking terrible havoc on everything we
know and love of he's been responsible
for Untold suffering and Chaos across
countless worlds timelines and layers of
reality to many he's even somewhat of a
final boss to the SCP Foundation and
just when you think he couldn't get any
worse it turns out that he's also a
deadbeat dad not only did the Scarlet
King once have a cult literally named
the children of the Scarlet King before
it was destroyed by Dr Monto and the SCP
Foundation he also had at least seven
actual children each one is speculated
to be a powerful anomaly but it's tough
to find concrete answers as to who or
what exactly most of them are so today
we're putting on our researcher hats and
digging deep into the foundation's lore
to present our theories on the potential
progeny of the SCP foundation's greatest
enemy and if nothing else we may finally
be able to get this dark lord of all
evil to start paying all the child
support he probably owes by now first if
you're not well versed in Scarlet King
bore you may may be wondering how
exactly does an evil chaos God have kids
is there a Scarlet Queen out there who
prefers to stay out of the Limelight the
answer isn't quite that simple and it
has everything to do with SCP 231 and
Big Red's most devoted cult the
non-biological Children of the Scarlet
King they kidnapped a group of seven
girls and performed a number of dark
rituals that resulted in them becoming
vessels for the Scarlet King seven
terrible kids these seven girls have
become known as SCP 231 anyone who
accesses those files and trust us they
aren't a pretty site we'll find that the
containment procedures mostly involve
performing the infamous Monto procedure
on the surviving girls to keep them from
giving birth six of the Seven Brides
have given birth to nightmares Beyond
Comprehension and are now dead with only
one still remaining successfully
contained but here at the SCP Foundation
you need to learn to comprehend the
incomprehensive prehensible according to
a classified document SCP 231 May
technically be a neutralized anomaly
without us even knowing and incidentally
this gives us our most certain answer on
the children of the Scarlet King on this
one the Apple fell very very far from
the tree according to the secret
document SCP 999 that's right the
adorable Tickle Monster is the seventh
child of the Scarlet King he must be so
disappointed that everyone's favorite
little blob didn't want to join the
family business of absolute evil for
anyone who doesn't know SCP 999 is a
slimy yellow entity that only seems
capable of absolute compassion it brings
joy to everyone in its presence and with
prolonged exposure it can even cure
disorders like PTSD anxiety and
depression he's so good at this that he
even cured SCP
2317 his def facto mother of her trauma
and allowed her to return happily to her
family after some amnestic treatment the
Scarlet King has another good reason to
be ashamed of his cheerful Blobby son
ancient DVID prophecy dictates that SCP
999 May someday become so powerful that
his force of absolute love and good
overwhelms the Scarlet King's evil and
Chaos think of him as the Luke Skywalker
to the Scarlet King's Darth Vader though
we probably can't expect a cool
lightsaber battle between them anytime
soon how disappointing so if SCP 999 is
the quiet sensitive black sheep of the
Scarlet family who's The Golden Child
who makes his evil father proud the real
chip off the old block that would be our
dear reptilian friend SCP 682 the
malicious lizard heavily implied to be a
child of the Scarlet King if you know
literally anything about 682 your
reaction to finding out that he's the
spawn of Cruelty personified is probably
yeah that makes sense just as SCP 999 is
the Scarlet King's innocent optimistic
young child 682 is kind of like his is
edgy teenager still in the middle of a
misanthropic phase he shows no sign of
leaving anytime soon the fact that 682
appears to find anything about the world
around him utterly disgusting seems to
be a trade he inherited from his dear
old dad and the fact he seems pretty
much impossible to kill also lends
Credence to the popular Theory he's got
nightmare God blood running through his
veins 682 has also started displaying a
particular hatred for 999 ever since an
incident where 999 tickled them into
submission so family dinners are
probably extra awkward for these two 999
and 682 are the most certain children
but that still leaves us with five more
children to identify it's worth
remembering that the waters are murkier
from here on in but we've searched far
and wide through the foundation archives
to find possible answers if your
interpretation differs remember that
it's just a theory an SCP explained
Theory thankfully we do have some
assistence here the tale dust and blood
hinted at what each of the seven
children of the Scarlet King represents
and that may help us narrow down our
choices here to put things into
perspective it's believed that 682 was
the fourth child to be born representing
wrath and 999 was the seventh
representing hope according to this Tale
the first of the seven children
represents dominion and as a result is
skilled in the ways of war and has the
power to lead the king's forces to
Victory according to One Foundation
theorist this child could potentially be
SCP 239 also known as the witch child
this entity is so powerful that as part
of its normal containment procedures
it's eternally kept in a coma why
because this seemingly normal child has
dominion over reality and can change it
to her whims her thoughts are so
powerful that just her brain waves can
damage physical matter and she can make
things disappear or manifest in an
instant she's also impossible to kill
with skin that's almost totally
impenetrable much like SCP 682 she's
also frighteningly strong in both the
offense and defense department we're
talking about such a powerful telepath
that Dr clef has campaigned for her
immediate termination just because it's
safer that way this is certainly a
frightening wonderin that the Scarlet
king would be proud to call his daughter
next the second child according to the
prophecy this child represents longing
the child has the power to bring forth
armies which will help the Scarlet King
in his Conquest for this we actually
have a pretty unconventional Theory SCP
029 also known as the daughter of
Darkness if the name alone wasn't enough
to suggest that she's got an extremely
Sinister father she also fits the
profile of being very aggressive and
incredibly hard to kill but even more
damning is her connections to the
symbology of longing one of her most
dangerous Powers is causing men to fall
into almost trans-like Devotion to her
after spending time around her they're
suddenly willing to murder in her honor
strangling their victims and hopes of
raising Ki the Hindu God of destruction
whom has many similarities to the
Scarlet King she certainly fits the bill
of someone capable of raising armies in
the Dark Lord's name one strike against
our Scarlet King connection theory is
that the file States the daughter of
Darkness was first discovered in India
which wouldn't match up with the other
information we know to be f act however
while this is a long shot given the
sensitive nature of everything involving
the Scarlet King it's extremely possible
that false information was supplied to
bury the connection considering the
coverups and lies involving anomalies
like SCP 1000 this certainly isn't an
unprecedented move on the part of the
foundation next the third child this
child is associated with all things
desolation implying destruction fire
ashes pestilence and death across the
the battlefield when it comes to
spreading destruction and Death on a
mass scale one particular SCP comes to
mind SCP
058 the Heart of Darkness this creature
has Scarlet King written all over it
it's evil it's mysterious it's pretty
much impossible to kill and it causes
Mass casualties every time it escapes
its containment chamber it causes fires
whips people to death with its razor
sharp tendrils and sprays highly
corrosive acid from its scorpion like
tail and it's even red given that we
know for a fact this entity suddenly
emerged out of something that's now been
expunged from the records in an
undisclosed site it's extremely possible
that the entity 058 came from was SCP
we can't think of an entity that better
suits the Desolation moniker than SCP
058 next skipping past SCP 682 at number
four the fifth child of the Scarlet King
is associated with the loose concept of
lack the prophecy then goes into more
detail saying that this child is
powerful in the ways of magic and is
able to use their abilities to cause
great destruction here we have another
unconventional proposal what if child
number five wasn't actually a child but
children that's because we think this
description perfectly fits SCP
1765 the nightmarish reality warping
sisters who we think may actually be
Triplets of the Scarlet King's fifth
bride now hear us out these are actually
some of the most powerful enemies the
foundation has ever attempted to contain
and we know nothing about their paast
before being bound to a few objects by
the Serpent's hand these sadistic
reality warpers are so devastatingly
powerful that the only action the
foundation can take against them is
letting them have free Reign Over the
containment site they currently inhabit
all the foundation can do is hope they
never get bored of tormenting the people
inside as we all know the Scarlet King
despises science progress and order so
perhaps a perfect punishment for the
foundation in his many eyes is giving
them a taste of their own medicine the
sisters though particularly their ring
leader are a perverse shadow of the
foundation's love of the scientific
method they take these methods and use
them for an activity that the Scarlet
King finds much more enjoyable
tormenting and killing people whenever
these crafty triplets set their mind to
it their horrifically powerful magic is
able to cause massive Devastation just
like the prophecy for the fifth bride's
Offspring dictates and finally the sixth
child of the Scarlet King the concept
associated with this one is hidden
meaning it can change its face and walk
unnoticed through creation it's also
said to have the responsibility of
opening the ways between worlds and
allowing the war to end all wars to
first begin there have been a huge
number of guesses for this spot with
some even suggesting SCP 055 the anti-em
but since we're having fun here we also
want to make an even Wilder suggestion
we pause it that the sixth child of the
Scarlet King is Allison Chia also known
as LS and the black queen the most most
powerful member of the Serpent's hand we
get it we have a lot of explaining to do
but hear us out Allison Shia is a member
of the Serpent's hand or technically
many members multiple versions of her
exist across parallel dimensions in the
SCP Multiverse they're mostly all
estranged Daughters of foundation
researcher Dr Charles Kars this
estrangement leads them to collaborate
in The Wanderer Library the secret base
of the Serpent's hand to conduct raids
on the foundation in Revenge but what if
the the leader of these alternate
Allison had an ulterior motive because
in the infinite number of possibilities
offered by the Multiverse this one was
not the daughter of Charles gears but
the Scarlet King she's merely using the
pain of her counterparts to manipulate
them into accomplishing her true
father's goal undermining the SCP
Foundation let's break it down the
hidden child is prophesies to walk
unnoticed through creation not only does
Alison Chow appear human the use of CP
268 a news boy cap that causes the
wearer to become unnoticed allows her to
walk anywhere through creation without
being detected but most importantly of
all the hidden child is said to be the
one who opens the way for the Scarlet
King's entrance into our Dimension and
Allison Chow has access to the
wanderer's library an unfettered access
point between Dimensions if one of the
infinite Allison's was the secret
daughter of the Scarlet king would the
wanderer's library not be a perfect way
for him to leave his own Dimension and
enter ours she could be the final piece
he needs hidden under the nose of the
foundation and the Serpent's hand making
all the secret power plays to allow for
the Scarlet King's eventual bloody
revenge on our world unless of course
SCP 999 the family disappointment stops
him first we realize that some of these
theories may seem surprising but when it
comes to the anomalous especially the
Scarlet King the only thing you can ever
expect is the unexpected do you agree
with our theories if not who do you
think are the children of the Scarlet
King let us know down in the comments
one thing is for certain we hope we
never meet any of the terrible tyrants
nasty children except the Tickle Monster
of course he can hang with us anytime
any changes today the younger security
officer Zach asked as he stepped into
the Watchtower as if replied his
Superior a jaded cynical old man who
insisted on being referred to as Mr
Jefferson the darn thing hasn't moved
spoken or done so much as stretch one of
those wings of his another day at the
office then Zach jumed through the
window the pair of them looked through
at the Towering figure a few kilometers
away SCP 01 the gate Guardian stood
motionless its fiery sword in its hand
ever protecting its post at the
precipice between our world and Paradise
it had long been stationed at the
entrance of a dimensional Gateway that
led to what was believed to be the
Garden of Eden described in the biblical
Old Testament much like these security
officers in the foundation's base tasked
with watching The Guardian this was
pretty much the extent of the day's
activities hey did you see that news
about the uh transfer posting Zach asked
trying to Stave off boredom with as much
conversation he could squeeze out of his
fellow officer yeah I saw Mr Jefferson
scoffed rolling his eyes what possesses
someone like Robert Monto to come down
down here must have wanted a quieter
post Zach reasoned looking out at the
Stillness of the gate Guardian won't
find one any quieter than here Jefferson
mused him showing up will be the most
exciting thing that's happened here in a
long while unbeknownst to both Zach and
Mr Jefferson Dr Robert Monto would be
only joining the team at the gate
Guardian observation site for a short
while not one of them nor anybody else
within the foundation could ever guess
monto's true intentions behind venturing
there in the first place he wanted an
audience with a gate Guardian itself
approaching the Colossal 1000ft tall
being Dr Monto crossed the threshold of
the minimum safe distance from the
guardian given the sheer heat of its
weapon hotter than Earth's sun anything
within a kilometer of SCP 001 was at
risk of being obliterated vaporized into
atoms if they didn't turn back which
through a voice that immediately rang
out in monto's ears the gate Guardian
commanded him to do
it psychic message boomed wait wait Dr
Monto urged holding up his hands in what
would have been a futile defense against
the Guardian Sword I know what you do
when people don't listen to your
commands but please just give me a
minute there was silence SCP 001 didn't
reply there was nobody else close enough
to hear mon speak to it so he continued
you are impossibly old we know that much
of about you and because of that you
must have seen things that we can't even
begin to imagine much less fully
comprehend but I've come a very long way
to request that you impart some
information to me if you can he paused
again as if waiting for a reply that
never came the gate Guardian merely
stood in the same defensive unwavering
stance tell me please how much do you
know about the Scarlet King by this
point in time although the foundation
was yet to realize Dr Robert Monto was
slowly going insane his investigations
into an anomalous entity known as The
Scarlet King were gradually corrupting
him as he tried relentlessly to quantify
exactly what this entity was and how
great of a threat it posed little did
Monto realize that in trying so hard to
Define and comprehend the being he was
inadvertently fueling its power the
Scarlet King was an interdimensional War
mongerer an embodiment of hatred and
chaos and Dr Robert Monto was slowly
falling under the king's influence upon
hearing the tiny human figure utter his
question the amens gate Guardian rebed
with another single word psychic command
one it had never been recorded giving
before
witness as if his increasing instability
and the creeping influence of the
Scarlet King hadn't made monok feel bad
enough he instantly felt sick there was
a searing pain behind his eyes like he
was staring directly at the sun
accompanied by a nausea that made his
head spin it took a moment of enduring
the horrific sensation before he
realized what was happening the guardian
was trying to show him something rather
than give any information on the Scarlet
King verbally SCP 001 was imparting a
psychic Vision onto mon a memory of
events long past the answers he sought a
warning or perhaps all three the vision
showed mon talk a time so long ago that
it couldn't ever be forgotten for there
was barely anyone alive to remember it
in the first place it was eons in the
past long before the comparatively
recent dawn of humanity a time only
spoken of in the dust and blood tablet
an artifact of the dite civilization
some of the earliest worshippers of the
Scarlet King himself and there marching
up to the entrance of Eden was the
Crimson clad eldrich Abomination and a
horde of horor with him according to the
story recorded in the dust and blood
tablet this would have been much earlier
in the life of the Scarlet King perhaps
even before he assumed his now Infamous
title back then he would most likely
have been known as his original name of
KRA one of multiple siblings born when
the tree of life was planted and thus
created all life in the Multiverse but
being the only one of his siblings
cursed with awareness knowing the pain
his existence brought him krock would
eventually set out on his lifelong
mission to destroy all of existence
across every Dimension and he started by
killing his siblings consuming them to
claim their power for himself around
this time in prehistory the being that
would one day become known as Scarlet
King didn't quite possess the power that
he would several Millennia later
although that's not to say he was an
unformidable force of Destruction fueled
by his singular hatred for existence his
vow to destroy extended to the Tree of
Life that had caused him to be along
with the tree Creator and all of their
Creation in other words everything in
the Multiverse all of creation if you
will so what was the Scarlet King doing
there so long ago at the dimensional
doorway protected by the gate Guardian
well beyond the boundary between it and
the rest of the infinite Multiverse lay
the supposed Garden of Eden while it is
unknown if it is in fact the same Eden
referred to in the Book of Genesis as Up
For Debate
especially among the foundation but at a
glance even through the gate it
certainly does look like a paradise the
space is filled with Lush vegetation of
astronomical size populated by a number
of beings that seem to resemble the gate
Guardian itself and there protected by
its watchful caretaker are two trees one
is thought to be the tree of knowledge
that Eve was tricked into eating an
apple from during the Book of Genesis
the other however Bears an unknown type
of fruit root and is widely believed to
be the tree of life now back in the
Modern Age there's never been a
conclusive link between the Tree of Life
mentioned by the davit in their barbaric
civilizations Legends regarding the
creation of the Scarlet King but the
fact that so long ago he and his most
feared generals were bearing down on the
gate guardian's position defending a
garden where there was known to be a
tree of that description well it all
seems rather conclusive now alongside
karak were six of his Seven Daughters
each one of them a fearsome Abomination
much like their destructive father as
they approached not one needed to
exchange any words with their Angelic
protector of Eden the gate Guardian knew
what these monsters were here for they
would stop at nothing to pass through
his gate and uproot the Tree of Life the
progenitor of all living beings in all
of existence even though it was early in
kck's career as the rampaging
interdimensional warlord he so is he was
as steadfast as ever in his goal to
annihilate every corner of creation
every Dimension every parallel plane of
reality every single pocket of existence
across Infinity they'd all come undone
if he burned the Tree of Life pulled it
out at the roots and splintered it until
nothing remained to The Once and Future
Scarlet King that the same tree had led
to his own tortured existence it was the
source of his suffering and it had to be
D destroyed the only thing standing in
his way was a figure as colossal as
karak himself wielding a flaming sword
me boomed the psychic voice of the gate
Guardian it was like a doorman standing
before a group of Rowdy teenagers trying
to force their way into a movie theater
except these Rowdy teens were the
Scarlet King his horrifying daughters
and the forces he had already aass since
his creation the hordes stood ready
waiting for the commands of their King
who they thought would gladly lead the
charge as they marched on the Garden of
Eden to begin the destruction of
existence but that's not what happened
usually the Scarlet king would never shy
away from a fight preferring to lead the
charge when it came to a Slaughter
instead he commanded his first daughter
AIC to commence the first attack on the
protector who stood in their path on her
foul father's word AIC took her horde
and charged at the guardian but she and
her forces lacked in numerical advantage
aiv more than made up for in her
knowledge of War she hungered for it
sought Dominion that was her seal after
all and yet in the face of this
impending Onslaught the gate Guardian
remains still rooted to the same spot it
had as always and would always be
standing it a number of aic's minions
burst into flames the very fabric of
their crude form separated on a
molecular level as they were
effortlessly rendered into nothingness
still the gate Guardian hadn't appeared
to move an inch had exerted no energy
despite the damage it had done to AIC
and her forces in defense of Eden as his
first daughter screeched and howled in
despair at the decimation of her horn
her children the Scarlet King decided he
needed to better understand his opponent
with a wave of his clawed Crimson hand
the king commanded his next daughter aor
to send forth her own Army in a Title
Wave of nightmarish creatures agor sent
her horrific children into battle she
possessed a far greater quantity to do
battle on her father's behalf perhaps
akar even believed that was the scotet
king's plan with a greater number of her
forces over her sisters maybe she would
be able to overwhelm the guardian but
even as her own children began to be
vaporized the closer that they got to
the gate agor had no idea she was little
more than a pawn being sacrificed so
that KRA could learn more about his
imposing Angelic enemy another of the
Scarlet King's Daughters a being known
as anit was the next called up to
contribute to the unfolding battle
although to call it a battle sells just
how easily the gate Guardian seemed to
be eliminating the oncoming forces
without even moving while an outwardly
frail seeming creature unh's primary
strength over her sisters was a
Proficiency in Magic her inate ability
to warp and reshape reality around her
it was that power that had caused her
father to be wary of her viewing anu's
abilities as a threat to his leadership
and so KRA had her crippled and all her
children leaving them unable to
overthrow him but still loyal to their
King obeying her father's command
perhaps out of the same loyalty or fear
that he would harm her and her children
further if she disobeyed anid unfurled
her magic she reshaped the world around
them making it so that the passage of
time moves so much slower and that was
what revealed to the Scarlet King his
enemy's greatest strength in combat the
gate Guardian had so far been able to to
obliterate both AIC and now oor's forces
without seeming to move but it wasn't by
standing still it was moving just much
faster than the blink of scarlet King's
multiple eyes now that an's magic had
slowed the passage of time the gate
Guardian could be seen doing battle as
agar's atrocities spilled towards the
angel to try and overwhelm it it
effortlessly blocked the oncoming
attacks with its sword everything the
Flaming blade connected with instantly
evaporated mer in into atams as they
were practically cleaved out of
existence by the gate guardian's Mighty
weapon even with time slowed to a crawl
The Towering winged protector of Eden
only appeared to be moving at an average
speed but when time flowed normally
without anood manipulating reality the
guardian was simply too fast to be
observed resisting the urge to dive head
first into the fight himself the Scarlet
King knew it would likely lead to his
untimely demise he refused to accept
that it could not happen but he still
had yet to amass the strength he would
need as he continued his Ascent so while
time was slow to a crawl and the gate
Guardian was still engaged in combat
with agoro's forces he turned to another
of his remaining daughters adista if the
Scarlet King and his forces couldn't get
past the guardian they could still try
to get to the Tree of Life while the
protector's focus was diverted aiston
Unleashed a wave of pestilence sickness
and disease spewing from her in a cloud
of vapor heading straight towards the
Angelic garden and Eden's entrance
Beyond The Scarlet King knew this latest
attack wouldn't phase or weaken the gate
Guardian he hoped the foul smog would
instead pass through the Gateway itself
into the garden as adad sent forth her
power blood and Ash soaked the landscape
around them all the plants outside the
entrance to Eden withered and died
shriveling and decomposing as the
disgusting fog rolled towards the gate
it washed over the guardian whose form
only seemed to Glow brighter as he
repelled the pestilence it was as if it
didn't even need to think about it still
focused on finishing off the rest of the
oncoming Army as its glow intensified so
did the fiery sword that the gate
Guardian swung with ease and finess
flames burst from the blade the
encroaching fumes Catching Fire along
with the air itself it ignited in a wave
of fire a defensive Inferno that
repelled this latest attack but for a
brief few moments while time stayed slow
before an's hold on reality inevitably
broke the king had sent forth aif of all
his spawn she was the most reserved
keeping mostly to herself never speaking
she and her children could change their
faces and forms shift into anything or
anyone and walk undetected through the
Multiverse and now her father was
employing her incredible stealth
abilities to slip Behind Enemy Lines
while the gate Guardian was finishing
off the remaining Onslaught from kak's
other daughters it was as aif Drew near
creeping unseen closer and closer to the
entrance keeping the Scarlet King out of
Eden that the guardian seemed to pause
it slowly ominously turned its huge head
tilting until it was looking directly at
aif if its expression could be seen
maybe the gate Guardian would almost be
impressed that someone was able to sneak
past it after all was a that no other
being in creation could ever hope to
accomplish but then again with its
steadfast conviction and dedication to
its protective Duty maybe it would have
looked upon atth with anger with a
cleaving swing of its scorching sword
the gate Guardian unfurled the tidal
wave of fire that engulfed everything
around it not just aif but aik aor and
adista all the king's daughters that had
attacked so far along with every one of
their own children were in instantly
obliterated they were all reduced to
empty vacant spaces where they had once
been their atoms separated by the
Searing swing of the guardian's weapon
the devastating Blow by his adversary
did little to deter the Scarlet King
from his mission he was still set on
destroying the tree of life and no loss
was too great in his pursuit of
destroying existence he barely cared
that four of his own daughters had just
been unmade by the guardian anit was
still there Clinging On to time as if if
it were a thrashing animal the Scarlet
King could simply make her restore her
Fallen sisters and their forces he had
lost nothing but had held back for too
long and slowly drew his own weapon out
of thin air wielding a sword that was as
blood soaked as the Guardians was hot
the Scarlet King locked blades with the
one being standing in their way both the
ancient Angelic Defender and the
attacking eldrich Abomination were
evenly matched every one of their
vicious strikes against the other met
with an equally strong Parry a weapon of
extreme allc consuming heat blocks
swipes from a sharp serrated edge that
matched the Deep Red that would be
forever synonymous with conro the force
of their two swords clashing and
striking each other was so great that it
rippled out from their one-on-one fight
the landscape around them was flattened
wiped clean of any remaining plant life
that hadn't already been destroyed by
the forces of the King's Daughters
despite having acquired ired nowhere
near the power he would thousands of
years after this fight the Scarlet King
was still a formidable force in single
combat and yet the gate Guardian seemed
incapable of tiring or weakening still
standing strong against the onslaught
even after wiping multiple armies out
with its flaming sword the guardian was
still able to hold its own against the
Scarlet King who was Furious enraged at
being so close to the tree of life yet
unable to get past his Angelic at
adversary he' need to be stronger faster
even more ruthless than the warlord he
already was despite unit's slowing down
time the king and the guardian were at a
stalemate time that was it the Scarlet
King needed more time withdrawing from
the fight he realized that this was a
battle that could not be won by sheer
Brute Force alone his mission to destroy
all creation to get to the tree of life
would take cunning deception and more
time if he let it the gate Guardian
could easily kill contro its flaming
weapon could cleave him out of existence
and that would end the king's torment
but it wouldn't be enough a death would
be unsatisfying knowing that the rest of
existence would go on after he was gone
the Scarlet King couldn't accept that it
wasn't enough so he did the one thing
nobody would expect of him he made a
deal with the gate Guardian it was an
action still fueled by his infinite
hatred for all existence his yearning
for total chaos the Scarlet King knew
that one day an event would arrive where
the guardian and the other beings like
it in the Garden of Eden would spill
forth and deliver judgment on this world
and when that Rapture happened the tree
of life would be undefended the Scarlet
King Bartered with the guardian that he
would Retreat for the time being so he
could spend eon's amassing more and more
power then when the Fateful day arrived
the gate Guardian would allow him into
Eden to destroy the Tree of Life while
it and its Brethren were busy conducting
the Rapture halting their fight the
Scarlet King offered a crimson claw to
the gate guardian's burning hand
returning to reality from the intense
Vision still feeling sick at what he had
witnessed Robert Monto looked up at the
still silent form of the gate Guardian
did you do it he yelled desperate to
know more through his obsession with the
Scarlet King did you did you tell him
yes did you make a deal there was no
answer from the guardian just a single
word that echoed through monto's
fractured
mind the desert is still the night seems
endless silent and at peace until it's
pierced by the sound of gunshots and
screams deep in the Sahara the SCP
Foundation is Waging War against a newly
discovered enemy a squad of foundation
agents is retreating trying to get away
from the ones who massacred their allies
they were attempting to eliminate the
threat using conventional means but
their rifles were no match for the
reality bending entities of the kingdom
of abdon the retreating agents cover one
another as they make their way back to
the extraction point the enemy Force
advances agents that are caught too
close to the Sorcerers of abdon
disintegrate Into Thin Air this is not
an enemy they can defeat the SCP agents
need to get back to base and relay what
they have found to their
superiors out of the hundreds of Agents
sent into the Sahara that night only a
handful make it out alive they are
debriefed by their superiors at the
foundation who classified the anomalous
humanoids under the highest of threat
levels the kingdom of abdon is a threat
the kingdom of abdon must be eliminated
reconnaissance done prior to the
disastrous Mission had alerted the
foundation to the presence of anomalies
in the region but they had no idea how
strong the anomalous humanoids would be
from data gathered through old reports
it seemed like the abdon humanoids were
responsible for the deaths of no fewer
than 75 Foundation personnel and had
stolen at least 12 different items from
the foundation the leaders of the SCP
Foundation tasked research team Omega 5
with developing a weapon that would be
capable of destroying the kingdom of
abdon once and for all the weapon they
are researching must be capable of long
range destruction because the moment any
foundation agent gets close to the area
they are vaporized by the the reality
manipulating powers of its inhabitants
the project is given the name twins of
God and is led by a foundation doctor
known only by the designation
051 051 is popular in the SCP Foundation
well known for his in-depth research and
carismatic personality making him the
perfect person to lead such a project
and 051 recently came across an anomaly
that he believes holds the solution the
foundation has been looking for to
defeat the kingdom of abdon item o o1
and so the Omega 5 team gets to work
they discover that the anomaly has
incredible Powers when put inside a host
which they refer to as an item o1 entity
and set up a series of experiments using
different people to harness its energy
the first series of tests all end in
tragedy the anomaly causes the entity it
inhabits to become intensely radioactive
anyone who gets close to it succumbs to
immediate radiation sickness and
eventually death to stop the radiation
problems the Omega 5 research group
intensifies the containment procedures
051 receives reports from the high-ups
that the kingdom of abdon has attacked
another Foundation facility in Sudan
long range defense is needed ASAP the
administrator puts more pressure on
Omega 5 and especially its leader 051 to
solve the problems of item 01 and
develop a weapon that can save the
foundation he stays awake for days on
end working tirelessly to create a safe
and controllable item 001 entity
although there are are signs that the
weapon will work it is still
unpredictable when item 001 is initiated
the host entity becomes paralyzed
suffers severe cerebral hring and soon a
new host is needed before testing Can
Begin Again and that's not the only
thing that goes wrong whenever the
anomaly is put into a new host sudden
and random destruction of on-site
structures and Personnel take place 051
knows though that if this power can be
harnessed and controlled in the right
way that it could be be the weapon that
the foundation needs to wipe out the
kingdom of abidon once and for all in
order to control item 01 051 has a m
kill switch implanted in its host's
brains 051 can activate the implant to
incapacitate its host and immediately
Stop The Unwanted destruction countless
hosts are terminated by this mind kill
switch in the early trials conducted by
the Omega 5 team but progress continues
to be made and eventually a hypothesis
is formulated perhaps the disastrous
side effect of item o1 can be offset by
spreading the anomaly across multiple
subjects they theorize that the immense
mental load of the anomaly can be
distributed among several hosts thus
reducing the toil it takes on each and
giving them the ability to control its
immense power but 051 and the Omega 5
team need more data and for that they
need more bodies they consult with the
director of site 17 and it is concluded
that the nearby town of San Marco would
be an appropriate place to get the
additional test subjects they require on
a quiet Sunday morning Omega 5 along
with support from a squad of armed SCP
agents Storm Into the San Marcos de la
vi thna Church during the middle of mass
they gather up a number of the younger
congregants and bring them back to the
site where item o1 is housed the
researchers quickly ran through their
new supply of test subjects though and
Omega 5 would need to get even more if
their research was to continue instead
of going back and forth between the
testing facility and San Marcos 051
decided to move the entire item o1
operation to the town itself he renames
the town testing site o1 and Omega 5
rounds up 23 of the healthiest subjects
they can find for use in the next series
of research tests a few weeks after
occupying the town of San Marco Omega 5
makes its most substantial progress yet
just as they theorized by spreading out
the anomaly of item 01 across a specific
group of hosts they can control its
powers the test may have cost the lives
of almost everyone in the town but the
ends certainly justify the means the
kingdom of abdon poses an existential
threat to the SCP Foundation after all
and thanks to This research they will
soon have a weapon capable of bringing
them Victory the foundation administer
criticize 0 51's methods but can't argue
with his results unfortunately 051 has a
dark secret a secret that disturbs even
the most hardened and loyal members of
Omega 5 a secret that has to do with the
item 01 hosts the host that Omega 5 has
made its major progress with are not the
ordinary test subjects normally used by
the foundation no the test subjects 051
makes his breakthrough with are children
nine of them to be exact all between 4
and 11 years old despite being told
specifically by the foundation
administrator to only test on adults the
research required 051 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down
the path it led the children are
contained in a reinforced bunker where
only 051 and a select few have access
they are technically alive but are
functionally brain dead the group of
nine children share a hive mine that can
process information and more importantly
can unleash the full potential of the
implanted anomaly creating and
controlling a devastating power but not
everyone is thrilled with what they've
achieved members of Omega 5 are haunted
by the screams of the children that they
forced to be part of their weapons
development program they describe their
merging with item o1 as being a process
that rips out their souls and replaces
them with something much more Sinister
in fact all of Omega 5 regret what they
have been a part of and what they've
done all except 051 the nine children
can Channel unprecedented amounts of
energy from an unknown origin that Omega
5 hypothesizes comes from an
extradimensional source which is then
used to unbind atoms at the quantum
level when the right activation words
are spoken it appears as though this
tremendous power gives the children the
ability to annihilate anything in the
entire universe it's a gun to end all
guns and only 051 has the key to control
it the nine children work so well with
an item o1 that Omega 5 reclassifies it
to include the nine children themselves
they are not just the entity housing or
controlling item o1 they permanently
become item
o1 once Omega 5 has a better
understanding of item o1 they begin to
run tests to find out the full extent of
its abilities first they test the
distance item o1 can reach the initial
test that Omega 5 carries out is on a
steel rod placed 5 km away 051 orders
the children to destroy the target
moments later the phone next to 051
begins to ring when he picks it up the
Observer tasked with watching the pole
is on the other end he informs 051 that
the steel rod has been completely
vaporized 051 is not satisfied though he
has another pole sent out this time
placed 8,000 km away from the nine
children 051 asked the children to
destroy that Rod almost immediately the
phone rings again the target has been
vaporized 051 Smiles the next series of
test Omega 5 runs on item 01 are to
determine the maximum size of an object
that can be destroyed
the test start out with a steel sphere 3
m in diameter placed 1,000 km from item
01 051 orders the children to destroy
the object it is instantly vaporized 051
has seen enough small tests it's time
for something big so he does something
that will later be questioned by
everyone at the SCP Foundation he orders
the nine children to destroy a church of
the broken God worship site in Turkey
not long after the destruction order is
given to item o01 reports begin coming
in the worship site has been obliterated
with no observable damage to the
surrounding area deadly and precise 051
closes his eyes and takes a deep breath
he looks as if he's overcome by an
immense spiritual experience he opens
his eyes leans over to the children and
Whispers the name of someone later that
day 051 finds out that the target he had
named has been vaporized the success of
Omega 5 in item 001 is relay to the
administration of the foundation they
are so impressed that they make plans to
use item 001 to eliminate the abidon
threat once and for all however one of
the heads of the foundation
administrator Williams has major
concerns about the way 051 is running
the program the updates that 051 has
been sending have become less scientific
and more
philosophical more spiritual
administrator Williams sends a letter to
051 reassuring in him that he is doing
good work but once the mission to
destroy the kingdom of abdon is
completed 051 will be promoted to
director and reassigned to the newly
constructed site 19 for the good of the
foundation and maybe the rest of the
world he'll be permanently moved away
from item
001 0 51's response is short and to the
point I am fine administrator the
project is finished we will complete our
task when you arrive administrator
Williams arrives at site 001 a few days
later he is greeted by 051 and the Omega
5 team Williams can't help but notice
that 051 has a strange look in his eyes
it is the look of a craze man who has
been lost in his work and who has
perhaps lost himself Williams puts the
thought away though and walks with 051
and his accompanying agents to the
viewing area where the powers of item
001 will be
demonstrated administrator Williams and
the other agents watch from a protected
viewing room as 051 enters the Chamber
of his new super weapon it's time to see
if their weapon that has had so much
time effort sweat tears and especially
blood poured into it will have been
worth it everyone watches as51 leans
over and says the name of the abdon
Citadel to the nine children all at once
they start to Glow no one observing can
see what has happened in the far off
Kingdom but they know something big has
happened the administrator is thrilled
but notices something 051 hesitated a
moment while leaning over the children
before standing back up did he whisper
something else to them and then
administrator Williams vaporizes pulled
apart at an atomic level before he has
the chance to scream what's going on the
agents standing next to where
administrator Williams previously
existed begin to yell and pull out their
guns they burst through the door of the
observation room and run down the
hallway towards where 051 and the nine
children are located the arm agents rush
into the room but 051 is gone the nine
children are still over the next few
weeks 051 is reported to be seen several
times by SCP agents however no one is
able to catch him and it appears as
though other members of the SCP
Foundation have also gone awall as well
perhaps joining him on the run it is
unclear what his plan is but the reports
from the reconnaissance team sent into
the Sahara make it obvious what the
result of his first command to the
children was there isn't a single human
or building left in the Kingdom of
abidon but even with this Victory the
highest levels of the SCP Foundation
have an ominous thought lurking in the
back of their minds where did 051 go and
what is he planning to do next following
the improper use of item o1 leading to
the untimely death of a high ranking
Foundation staff member the weapon was
deemed too dangerous and containment
procedures were implemented due to the
high amount of radiation they were found
to emit the nine children were placed in
into leadline bags and buried under 50 m
of concrete beneath the Church of St
Marcos de laa
Eterna though all of the children
continued to be functionally brain dead
they still display Signs of Life despite
their containment and by order of the
overseer Council have been classified as
a Thal entity the smell of fire and oil
fills the air the sound of gears
grinding can be heard between the
explosions and shrieks of Terror a man
runs out of his house only to have his
leg grabbed by a metal arm and dragged
back through his front door SCP 001
leaves a trail of metal fragments and
mechanical Parts on the ground in the
wake of its destruction iron chains
swing from its form cast iron gears
whirl within it a glowing light throbs
from the center of its body SCP 001 is
consuming everything in its path after
incorporating the truck chassis into its
being SCP 0 1 rolls in a lumbering
fashion to the next house it rips the
gutters from the side of the building
residents who live in the area flee
their neighborhood all the while hoping
that the mechanical monstrosity skips
over their house so they have something
to return to if they make it out alive a
section of SCP 001's undercarriage drops
away from the main body it rolls down
the street consuming more and more
material the new entity resembles a
human spine in rib cage it topples over
unable to support itself the ri likee
formations extend out to grab anything
and everything within reach the newly
Incorporated material forms what can
only be described as a head light from
within the eye sockets fixate on nearby
civilians the metallic creature picks up
the people and places them inside its
exposed steel rib cage then it turns and
spots a woman helplessly trying to crawl
away the creature reaches out with a
spiked tentacle and wraps it around the
woman's body she is placed inside of the
chest cavity moments later a severed
hand falls out of the entity and onto
the ground the mechanical monster
continues to gather bodies and materials
incorporating them into its frame a
growth begins to slowly expand on its
back it becomes so massive that the
creature Falls over and uses its limbs
to Scurry to a nearby house there is a
sickening crunching sound as the growth
bursts from within emerges three
humanoid creatures resembling the
civilians that the entity had consumed
earlier a female with chains extending
from her scalp like dreadlocks stumbles
away the second humanoid is a man with
cogs for limbs he examines the
clock-like components that have been
incorporated into his body then stares
blankly into the distance the third
humanoid lies motionless on the ground
he did not make it the two functioning
humanoids look at their creator intently
for a moment nothing moves then as if
they have been given orders
telepathically the half-human half
machine humanoids turn turn and run away
from the Mayhem a few weeks before the
massacre caused by what would be
designated as SCP 001 the foundation had
been in contact with the Allied ult
initiative there were rumors of an
anomalous object in Mexico being
worshiped by a group of people who
identified themselves as the Church of
the broken God Intel about the church
claimed their deity was a small
mechanical box filled with cogs and
pistons the Box supposedly had
supernatural abilities it was said to be
able to communicate with congregants of
the Church of the broken God
telepathically The Devout worshiped the
Box following any order it gave and in
return they were filled with an emotion
that could be only described as Divine
as World War II rages on in Europe the
foundation sends agents to recover
anomalies in Mexico that might help with
the war effort while there the
foundation force is tasked with learning
about the Church of the broken God they
are also ordered to investigate a town
near laaz where there are troubling
accounts of a mechanical anomalous
creature causing Mayhem the agents make
their way through Mexico Gathering
various objects to bring back to
Foundation sites in the United States
the unit loads all of the anomalies they
were covered onto a train with a plan to
check out the stories of the mechanical
anomaly they've heard about as they make
their way to the US border the train
heads North along rusted rails just
outside laaz they've come across a
broken down train filled with what looks
to be refugees when the foundation unit
goes to investigate they find all of the
refugees repeating the same words over
and over again but they don't understand
the foundation agents look at one
another confused until one of them
translates the words into English the
words the refugees are saying over and
over again are La makina the machine the
commanding officer orders a squad of
foundation agents to proceed up the
tracks to see if they can figure out
what has the refugees so scared they
make their way towards laaz disappearing
Over the Horizon as the sun sets the
remaining Foundation agent hear gunshots
in the distance they stay awake all
night remaining Vigilant waiting for the
exploratory Squad but morning comes
without anyone returning 3 days later
the foundation Force still has not seen
anything since the exploratory Squad
left then as the sun sits lazily in the
morning Sky a lone figure is spotted
walking down the tracks towards the
trains one of the agents on watch blows
his whistle and points to the figure a
squad of Agents rushes towards the
shadow of a man their guns are raised
ready for anything the figure drops to
the ground and begins to crawl along the
tracks the agents reach the Fallen man
only to find that he is one of their
squadmates who has been sent up the
tracks to investigate laaz several days
before the agent's name is DeMarco he is
covered in blood his clothes are in
tatters and he has lost a boot DeMarco
lies on his back with Foundation agents
standing around him his eyes are wide
and wild he keeps babbling on about a
world eater how the rest of his Squad
had been mulched and he is the only one
who made it out alive the foundation
agents carry DeMarco back to the
makeshift base they created by the
trains they need to figure out a way to
get the Convoy moving again but whatever
is up ahead has already taken out an
entire Foundation Squad it had to be
something anomalous but what could it
possibly be the unit of foundation
agents prepare to move towards laaz they
start loading their rifles and check the
amount of ammunition and explosives
available in case the containment
process gets out of hand just as they
are about to leave the base a convoy
appears on the horizon it is an Allied
oul initiative Force preparing to attack
whatever it is that is devastating leas
this organization's mission is to not
secure contain or protect but to destroy
the foundation may be in over their
heads on this one and the Joint Force
with the Allied oult initiative may be
the only way to stop what is now known
as SCP 001 the aoi and Foundation Force
gears up for battle they set out for laa
and what they find causes them to Quake
with fear SCP 001 has consumed so much
material it is the size of a mountain it
moves like a tidal wave of mechanical
destruction washing over the buildings
and Landscape under it whatever SCP 001
passes over is consumed and added to its
massive body SCP 001 started as a small
mechanical box with cogs but now has
morphed into a gigantic metal death
machine the Church of the broken God has
finally met their maker as the small
entity they once worshiped has now
consumed all of its members their God is
an all consuming monster the aoi and
Foundation forces do everything they can
to stop SCP 001 from continuing its
reign of Destruction they fire barrage
after barrage of bullets and explosives
into the mechanical anomaly they bring
in air support to try and damage it from
the skies but nothing works the aoi uses
an artifact in their possession to lure
SCP 0 1 to the coast of the Pacific
Ocean where a trap has been set for the
so-called God the Monstrous mechanical
creature moves slowly towards the water
it consumes abandoned cars buildings and
boats as it approaches the coastline it
even shovels large amounts of Earth into
its form causing Flames to spurt out
from its inner workings smoke Bellows
from openings between different
mechanical components like a volcano
before it is about to erupt suddenly
seemingly from nowhere a massive cloud
with a reddish tint appears in the sky
Air Raid Sirens can be heard in the
distance the enormous Cloud begins to
pulsate streaks of lightning shoot
through the Red Mist in the sky it now
sits directly over SCP 001 from within
the cloud part of a ship can be seen it
appears to be slightly damaged
electricity flows over its hole the
vessel in the giant Red Cloud is
classified as SCP
2399 the underside of the vessel begins
to Glow aqua blue a blinding beam of
light is ejected from SCP 2399 which
penetrates straight down and through SCP
001 for a moment everything is still
there is complete silence then as if SCP
001 is trying to reach up and grab the
vessel above it a mechanical bulge
reaches out before SCP 001 can grab the
vessel above there is another bright
flash of light SCP 2399 blinks out of
existence the sound of grinding gears
can be heard coming from within SCP 001
it begins to shed its outer layers of
metal then the entire structure that was
scp1 collapses into the water and onto
the beach giant cogs fall from the sky
parts of vehicles embed themselves in
the sand as the foundation and aoi
agents approach the piles of scrap metal
and mechanical components they see that
some of them are still moving it is as
if an invisible power source is still
pulsating through some of the Machinery
the Agents of the foundation celebrate
the destruction of the giant mechanical
beast but little do they know this was
only a piece of the entity worshiped as
the broken God the foundation agents
collect as many of the still moving
Parts as they can they find spinning
gears twitching pulleys and firing
Pistons as the parts are separated from
one another and carried away from the
main wreckage of SCP 001 they slowly
stop moving and become inactive some of
the artifacts were covered were
identified as being connected to the
Church of the broken God these artifacts
are found closer to the middle of what
was once a mountain-sized SCP 001
hundreds of anomalous artifacts are
collected and transported top foundation
sites collecting the broken parts of SCP
001 is relatively safe however some
agents get too close to the larger
moving Parts getting caught in them and
losing a body part or two but most
agents proceed with caution and survive
the collection ordeal with their arms
and legs still attached to their bodies
dive teams are sent into the water to
recover parts that have sunk to the
Bottom of the Sea one of the divers is a
local from the area he is hired to bring
up the heart of the machine since he is
an experienced diver used to free diving
to Great depths to collect oysters from
the bottom of the bay the diver enters
the water and swims down into the murky
depths he secures straps around the
heart of SCP 001 and pulls hard on the
Rope as an indication to the surface
that it is ready to be hauled up the
Salvage team on the surface begins to
pull there is a second slight tug on the
Rope then it goes slack the team
continues to pull when they get the
heart to the surface they are horrified
at what else comes up with it tangled in
the ropes is the lifeless body of the
diver his head is smashed between two
moving pieces of the heart it looks as
if he shoved his head between the slabs
of metal himself the Salvage team
untangles the Body Rolls it off the deck
and back into the ocean the mechanical
box which was the heart of SCP 001 is
offloaded on the shore but as the
foundation prepares to move it to a
containment facility the weather starts
to deteriorate hurricane force wind
sweeps across the water and batter the
coast the heart is kept in a secured
storage Warehouse until it can be moved
the people living in the village nearby
complain of hearing voices and rashes so
itchy that they practically tear their
skin off once the storm passes the
foundation agents load the heart onto a
ship it is to be transported to a
foundation site just across the border
the ocean seems calm and Serene the
foundation ship undocks and begins
Journey up the coast not too long after
beginning its Journey the ship slowly
drifts off course it is as if the crew
has stopped Manning their posts and the
ship is being controlled by a mind of
its own the foundation ship crashes and
sinks somewhere in the Pacific Ocean
never to be found and most importantly
the heart of SCP 001 doesn't make it to
the foundation site years later a man is
walking along the beach he hears
something it sounds like someone
pounding on a large drum to the rhythm
of of a heartbeat the man walks towards
the sound something is drawing him
forward closer and closer to the
heartbeat he walks and walks until the
beating stops he bends down and moves
the sand aside he spots the corner of a
mechanical box sticking out of the white
sand the man digs deeper and pulls out
the small box inside he can see gears
whirling and pistons firing he holds the
Box close to his own heart it seems to
speak to him the man brings the box back
to town he starts to worship the box and
soon more and more people in the area
join the new religion they cast aside
their own beliefs and focus on the
powerful entity contained within the Box
God is not dead at least not yet but the
Prophecies of the Church of the broken
God say that when the heart is found the
God will reassemble itself once again
then The Unbroken God will destroy all
other false deities until only he
remains
it's a quiet evening at Area 11 where
the Petri Cal Fane spatial stabilization
array is housed a skeleton crew is
working overnight to ensure the array is
ready for its big test the following day
the foundation has been working on a
particle accelerator that will contain
anomalies with the ability to manipulate
the nature of SpaceTime the preliminary
tests seemed promising but a few last
minute tweaks to the array are necessary
unfortunately it is on this night in
1982 the marks the beginning of the end
for the SCP Foundation Dr Calvin Desman
is monitoring the array and he notices
as it spools up that there is some minor
power fluctuation in one of the
stabilization arms this problem is not
uncommon due to the vast amounts of
energy being pumped through the array
and the harmonic resonance the machine
gives off which slowly causes the
coupling rings to loosen Calvin desmid
decides that remounting the
stabilization Rings will be an easy fix
and it's a necessary one he knows that
if the Rings fail during the actual test
the array could end up shut down for
months there is still plenty of time so
Kelvin Desmond grabs his toolbox and
heads down to the array the machine is
still spooling keeping the energy
flowing at a constant low rate there is
no danger at the moment as the inside of
the array is shielded from the radiation
and energy pulsing through the outer
ring but then something unexpected
happens the system's primary generator
begins to fluctuate uncontrollably a
catastrophic failure is imminent Sirens
begin to sound the facility is evacuated
and the Chamber is sealed deep in the
bowels of the array Calvin desmid cannot
hear the evacuation announcement the
humming of the array Echoes through the
chamber dampening all sound from the
outside world the array begins to come
online while desmid continues to work on
the coupling he has no idea what is
about to happen meanwhile a team of
foundation scientists scrambled to get
the power fluctuations in the main
generator under control as they
frantically work catastrophe strikes
they initiate the power down cycle but
as the generator struggles to keep the
power flow balanced an energy surge
builds up a massive amount of energy is
released all at once causing the main
reactor to explode the entire structure
rocks back and forth and Desmond is
thrown into the side of the array he too
now knows that something is very wrong
and runs for the exit when he reaches
the door he finds that it has been
sealed in a panic Desmond continues
running through the tube to the next
access point this door has been locked
as well he's never been so scared in his
entire life and he shakes uncontrollably
from the adrenaline being dumped into
his muscles The Surge of energy rushes
through the array towards Desmet a
singularity begins to form in the
containment chamber the array is working
just as it should except that there was
never supposed to be a person inside as
the singularity was brought into
existence moments after the singularity
forms the massive pull of its gravity
causes the stabilizer arm that Desmond
had been working on to fail the side of
the array is ripped off and Calvin
desmit stares into the naked eye of the
singularity everything is silent and
still for a moment then the singularity
collapses in on itself taking the test
chamber and much of the research wing
with it along with Dr Calvin Desmet
sparking wires hang from the exposed
walls and ceiling where the singularity
ripped the main structure away water
flows into the deep hole carved out of
the Earth where the array once stood the
scientists from Area 11 look into the
crater left by the collapse Singularity
the foundation Administration sends
agents to collect the staff at the site
and document the failings of the project
they conclude that the accident was
caused by human error they ordered the
array to be rebuilt this time using
entirely automated systems to eliminate
the chances of another mishap occurring
several years after the catastrophic
events at Area 11 a new array is
constructed an intelligent system called
netac is put in charge of overseeing its
functions it is a supercomputer that is
programmed to follow commands but can
autonomously make decisions in order to
prevent any failures in the system
experiments Begin Again in May of 2006
the new array soon manifests its first
singularity in the containment chamber
at Area 11 and what happens next will
forever change the foundation and the
Multiverse The Singularity is kept
stable in the array it seems as if the
foundation has succeeded in trapping and
containing spatial anomalies but as they
run more Diagnostics on the anomaly
something unexpected happens The
Singularity begins to grow in size the
point of infinite gravity threatens to
breach containment as it reaches the
boundaries of the array just before
contact the singularity's growth slows
and then stops netac has made the
split-second calculations and
adjustments necessary to contain the
singularity the artificial intelligence
has saved the facility and the lives of
everyone in it now sitting in the array
is a thick rotating cloud of radioactive
gas and dust obscuring the singularity
within as Foundation scientists work
rapidly to fix the array odd events
begin to occur the workers hear noises
that sound like painful wailing over
time the noises evolve into words and
then full sentences they seem to be
originating from The Singularity using
equipment able to penetrate the thick
cloud of radioactive gas the foundation
scientists get a glimpse at the
singularity to their surprise The
Singularity has taken on the shape of a
human the scientists work frantically to
figure out how the singularity could
have formed itself into a humanoid shape
Dr J Barton Ramsey is the first to try
and make contact with the humanoid
within the singularity he finds that the
entity cannot communicate in the
traditional sense the massive
gravitational pole of the singularity
does not allow sound to escape it its
void Instead The Entity manipulates
gravity to vibrate the suspension rings
of the array itself and create sound
waves the being in the singularity
Whispers in a metallic voice created by
the vibrating of the arrays rings and
says yanes Ramsey Dr Ramsey steps back
from the observation window how do you
know my name he asked the entity the
humanoid within the swirling gas cloud
identifies itself as having the memories
of Calvin Desmond it is not desmit per
se the being in the singularity is so
much more than one person but it was
somehow created by the accident that had
sucked Calvin desit into the singularity
years before the entity seems to switch
between the mind of desmit and the vast
Infinity of the cosmos The desmit Entity
asks for an overseer from the foundation
to be brought in it has a proposal for
the 05 Council when Dr Ramy asks why the
entity needs to talk to the overseers it
replies that it wants to offer them
a way out the following day 051 enters
the facility and heads to the
observation deck he looks through the
reinforced glass at the swirling cloud
of radioactive dust then glances at the
monitor to see the humanoid shape of the
singularity within he presses the
microphone button on the console and
addresses The Entity to whom am I
speaking he asks for Simplicity sake The
Entity tells 051 to refer to him as
Calvin Desmond 051 makes notes of the
events unfolding before him and then
asks about the way out that Calvin had
mentioned the air is still for a moment
then Desmond begins to speak through the
vibration of the structure once again he
informs 05- one that what the SCP
Foundation is doing by securing and
containing anomalous entities around the
world is like putting a small Band-Aid
on a much bigger wound Desmond wants to
propose a final solution to all of the
foundation's problems 0 5-1 listens
intently as the entity unravels the
mysteries of where the scps have come
from he explains that the anomalies that
the foundation has worked so hard to
secure contain and protect the human
race from are actually bleeding into
their reality from a vast Multiverse the
only way to stop the manifestation of
anomalies into this universe is to
destroy all other realities The Entity
that is Calvin desmit tells 05- one that
he is able to bring about this
destruction if they release him from
from the confines of the array 0 5-1 is
transfixed by the swirling gas that is
promising him and everyone else on Earth
salvation he shakes his head in
disbelief could this be true 0 5-1 turns
away from the swirling gas and begins to
walk away from the viewing glass I'll
need to think about what you're saying
the structure begins to shake slightly
the voice of Calvin Desmond reverberates
off of the array a little louder than
before choose quickly overseer although
it won't happen for decades eventually a
catastrophic SCP event will wipe out
life on this planet perhaps not in your
lifetime but it will most certainly
happen within the lifetime of your
children we will talk again soon the
vibrations slow and then stop completely
there is an eerie Stillness in the
observation room as 0 5-1 walks out the
next day all staff members located at
Area 11 are relocated to other
Foundation sites and given amnestics the
05 Council meets in a large circular
room with wood paneling and no windows
05- one begins the meeting by telling
the others what Calvin Desmond had
described about the end of the world he
pauses for what seems like an eternity
and tells them of Desmond's offer that
he could prevent the end of the world
but at the cost of destroying an
infinite number of other realities this
would mean that all the humans and
creatures of those realities would be
destroyed as well well was murdering
countless other beings worth it to
protect their own reality 0 5-1 begins
to shake he hasn't slept or eaten
anything since his talk with Desmond
he's being torn apart from the inside 0
5-3 stands up and addresses the council
he informs everyone in the room that
independent teams have concluded
Research into what the Calvin Desmond
entity has claimed and they found it to
be true the world really would come to
an end furthermore the research teams
determined that the capabilities of
Desmond would in fact allow him to
dismantle the other realities 0 5-3
insists that the council must vote to
allow Desmond to destroy the other
realities to ensure that this reality
could be saved they must strike now
before the world is overrun 0 5-1
continues to Shake while 0 5-3 breathes
heavily sweat pouring down his temples
the rest of the council shifts their
gazes from side to side it is time for a
vote there are eight eyes to allow
Desmond to destroy all of realities and
for Nays against the plan 0 5-3 stands
up and walks around the room stopping
behind each nay voter and putting a
bullet in their head he stops at the
last 05- 9 who pulls out a gun places it
under her own chin and pulls the trigger
05-13 abstains from the vote and the
measure passes the remaining overseers
will use the Calvin Desmond entity to
save the reality at the expense of all
others and they soon head to Area 11 to
execute their plan
05-14 and 12 enter the observation room
that looks upon the swirling radioactive
gas around Calvin Desmond 0 5-1 orders
netac to begin powering down the array
which will allow the entity to prove he
can do what he has promised they have
pinpointed the reality that SCP 884 came
from and the Shaving mirror itself sits
on a table in another room in the
facility 0 5-3 stands in the room
watching the mirror mirror to see if
anything happens 0 5-1 asks Calvin
Desmond to eliminate the reality that
the mirror had come from the room Shakes
as the entity uses it to acknowledge the
request moments later the phone rings in
the observation room it is
[Music]
05-30 5-1 asks Calvin Desmond to
continue and destroy all the realities
that are bleeding into their own this
time the entire facility begins to Quake
suddenly 0 5-1 jerks backwards his eyes
wide in confusion and horror his body
seems to be compressing under an unknown
Force 0 5-1 begins to distort his legs
and arms fold into the core of his body
his head snaps down and all that was 05-
one is sucked down into a single point
in space before it completely disappears
Calvin Desmond then turns his attention
to the other two overseers in the room
who both seem to collapse into black
holes of their own in the center of
their bodies net Zac's warning claxon
begins to sound signaling that the
emergency fail safe has been activated
before Calvin Desmond is brought under
control the structural support in the
entire facility vibrates with his words
they are in a voice that sounds
strangely similar to 0 51s your children
are free to live lives that do not end
in horror an end to your Perpetual
struggle an end to Darkness the freedom
to live in the light all traces must be
removed this world must be washed clean
the foundation does not Escape atonement
it is the only way out it had been a
deception the Calvin Desmond entity had
no intention of stopping anomalies from
infiltrating this world it wanted to
remove all traces of the anomalous from
all universes including this one and
that meant destroying the overseers and
the foundation itself their destruction
would serve as an atonement for the pain
and suffering they had caused in their
quest to secure and contain the
anomalous Calvin had to lie to the
overseers about the real plan since he
knew they'd never sacrific themselves
and the foundation even if it meant an
end to the anomalies plaguing our world
now though with the overseers out of the
way the Calvin Desmond entity is free to
move forward with its plan and Purge all
realities of any trace of the anomalous
but just then net saac fail safes kick
in and the Petra Cal Fane spatial
stabilization array subdues the entities
abilities Desmet is once again contained
0 5-3 bursts through the door and into
the observation room he stands before
the shattered glass of the window that
looks into the array 053 asks netac how
how long the containment array can hold
Calvin Desmet the computer's voice fades
in and out but says given current
conditions
119 days 6 hours and 47 minutes 0 5-3
size he tells netac to make a node in
the SCP database that the Calvin Desmond
entity will now be known as SCP 001 then
to make dozens of other randomly
generated entries and label them as SCP
001 as well he knows that they will need
to keep the true nature of what this
entity can do a secret 0 5-3 walks out
of the room under his breath he speaks
to himself they'll say that I'll know
the one true God when I see it and to
give that God everything it wants
because that's the only thing that
matters tonight it appears God wants to
talk to me Calvin Lucien stands at the
end of a Dusty table in an abandoned
warehouse in the shadows across from him
sit several hidden figures the warehouse
is falling apart but is suitable for the
meeting Calvin has requested with the
heads of the chaos Insurgency he has
completed numerous missions for the
organization and each one has been
successful now he is proposing one final
mission Calvin Lucian takes a tattered
Journal out of his bag and slides it
across the table to the figures sitting
in the shadows it's a journal with
details on the habits of each of the 13
Foundation overseers he says there is
silence from the other end of the table
a hand reaches out and grabs the journal
the pages begin to turn the new models
indicate an anomalous catastrophe is
imminent not even the foundation can
stop it the only way to save the world
is to kill the overseers there are
Whispers from across the table as Calvin
continues the proliferation of anomalies
in the world are the fault of the
overseers they' have been meddling with
reality if business continues as usual
we might not make it out of the 2020s we
need to act now the whispering from the
Shadows resume
this time with what seems to be a little
more urgency one of the voices asked the
question on everyone's mind how do you
plan to kill the overseers they have a
deal with death they are Immortal Calvin
smiles and takes out a small vial from
his jacket pocket with this he says
there is a Silence from the Shadows the
journal slides back across the table and
comes to a stop right in front of Calvin
a deep voice from the Shadows says do it
Calvin Lucien gathers his team the code
name given to the group is kill Squad he
informs them that they've been cleared
to take out the overseers it will be the
most dangerous Mission they've ever been
on and even if successful they probably
won't make it out alive but the team is
loyal they set out to confront the 13th
overseer this has to be their first stop
because without eliminating
05-13 nothing else will matter it is
this overseer who has a deal with death
a deal that protects all of the
foundation overseers from dying
if that deal can be broken then Calvin
Lucien and his team will have a shot at
eradicating the other overseers if the
deal with death cannot be broken All Is
Lost the team boards a ship at the tip
of South America and sails towards the
Frozen Waters of Antarctica the kill
Squad is made up of Calvin and three
others they sit in the galley preparing
for the mission ahead Anthony Wright is
a battle hardened soldier who sits at
one end of the table his face is covered
with scars no one can remember when he
first joined the Insurgency because it
was so long ago next to him is Olivia
Torres she is an anarchist who was
recruited into the Insurgency after she
was liberated from a foundation site
during a raid Adam Ivanov sits staring
into his computer screen he is testing
different gadgets that might be of use
on the mission he pushes his glasses up
the bridge of his nose and Strikes the
enter key a long line of code begins to
scroll across the screen a siren begins
to sound informing the crew to make
their way to the main deck when they
surface from the bowels of the ship they
see something in the distance it is a
giant black Tower rising from the depths
of the ocean like an evil Iceberg waves
crash over the side of the railings
drenching the deck and crew with frigid
water Calvin looks at the jagged rocks
along the shore of the tower there is no
way to safely dock there is only one way
onto the island they know what needs to
be done Anthony waits for the next wave
then opens the throttle to full the ship
is carried towards the island on the
crust of the wave the hole is impaled on
the Rock surrounding the tower sending
everything flying towards the front of
the boat see that wasn't so bad Calvin
says to his team as he bandages a gash
on his hand knowing what lays ahead
Calvin orders his team to wait on the
ship while he makes his own deal with
death he enters the dark structure and
is greeted by a corpse the corpse speaks
to him ejecting dust from its lungs with
every word its breath smells like
decaying FL flesh death has inhabited
the body of Dr Felix Carter the 13th
overseer Calvin is prepared though
thanks to the notes in the journal he
possesses without hesitating he takes
out a small bottle of liquid from his
pocket and lunges at the corpse he grabs
it by the neck tilts the head back and
pours liquid down what is left of the
throat to Felix Carter the corpse
reanimates into the living Dr Carter
death has been removed from his body by
liquid from the Fountain of Youth that
Calvin had acquired on a previous raid
on a foundation site seeing that Dr
Carter is now alive Calvin takes out his
pistol and shoots the doctor twice
killing him Calvin picks up the body and
throws it into a bottomless pit at the
base of the tower Dr Felix Carter's body
disappears from sight the overseers deal
with death is now broken they are
vulnerable and can be killed at last
Calvin smiles and begins to turn away
from the pit when he comes face to face
with death she stands with her head
cocked to the side looking at Calvin so
it is you who has broken the overseers
deal with me Calvin Lucien Calvin takes
a step back why didn't she stop him from
killing Felix Carter something festers
at the heart of the council death says
something that will not die I thought
that perhaps if I had a seat at their
table I could find it make it die but I
couldn't there are things in this world
Beyond even my reach Calvin Lucien with
that parting thought death vanishes the
kill Squad contacts the Insurgency for
an EV and then makes their way to Japan
where 05-12 also known as the accountant
has been working out of Tokyo he is so
proficient in mathematics and
probability that he can actually predict
the future everything about the
accountant's life down to the number of
breaths and steps he takes each day is
predetermined based on his own
statistical models this poses a problem
for Calvin and his team if the
accountant can see them coming then how
can they possibly kill him that night
the accountant steps out of his car he
looks looks to the left and spots Adam
he has already predicted this man has
hostile intentions the accountant walks
directly towards Adam and before he can
react throws the kill Squad member to
the ground then he turns slightly and
adjusts his watch sending a glare
directly into the window where Anthony
has the accountant in his sights of his
sniper rifle Anthony fires but misses
due to being blinded by the glare the
accountant is surprised that he just
barely had time to avoid being shot
normally he would be several steps ahead
of anyone trying to kill him he turns
his head and watches as Olivia helps
Adam up and they run down a nearby alley
the accountant pursues them and Corners
the kill Squad members in the alley he
pulls a gun to shoot Adam but Olivia
tackles Adam behind a dumpster as the
bullet hits the wall directly behind
where Adam was standing the accountant
can't believe that he missed and that he
was almost tricked into being captured
by the Insurgency team he senses
uncertainty in his as salent actions and
runs away unable to predict exactly what
they're planning to do the accountant
climbs the stairs to a subway station
and boards the last car of the train it
is empty except for one man Calvin
Lucien the accountant is dumbfounded how
are you here he screams I should have
seen this coming Calvin stands up he
uses his thumb to flip a coin into the
air on the way down he grabs it and
smacks it on the back of his opposing
hand Calvin Smiles the team has been
making their decisions based on the flip
of a coin which introduced Randomness
into their actions that even this super
Advanced mathematician could not account
for tell me where o 5-11 is demands
Calvin the accountant pauses then shakes
his head no if he's going to die either
way then why give any information to the
kill Squad Calvin flips the coin up in
the air catches it and looks at it the
coin is face up Calvin lifts his pistol
and shoots the accountant in the head a
few nights later Olivia stands on a
balcony outside of an Art Exhibit
overlooking the city of Seattle Anthony
walks up behind her and tells her that
the foundation is defeated but Olivia
doesn't understand how we broke the
overseers deal with death and killed the
accountant there's nothing more to do we
can go back to our normal lives he tells
her Olivia is skeptical though what
about the 11th overseer and his ability
to Olivia's eyes suddenly go wide she
pulls out a knife and stabs it into
Anthony's Heart the world around her
begins to distort and fall apart it was
a false reality created by 05-11 better
known as the liar Olivia wakes up next
to Adam in a hotel room she sits up in a
bed and rubs her eyes what a weird dream
she thinks then she realizes it wasn't a
dream she shakes Adam awake neither of
them have any idea how they ended up
here but they know it must be the doing
of the liar they had planned for this
though with Calvin having created a
contingency plan they pull out a laptop
and log in to view the classified
information Calvin left for them Olivia
begins to type but stops halfway through
her password and looks up from the
screen Olivia pulls out the gun that
rests under her pillow and shoots at him
the false reality created by the liar
falls apart part around her Olivia comes
out of the previous lie and is sitting
across the table from Calvin she
immediately draws her pistol and points
it at Calvin's head is it really him or
just another one of the Liars games
Calvin tries to talk Olivia down and she
looks around the room for
inconsistencies that might tip her off
that this is another lie but doesn't
find any Olivia begins to relax she
tells Calvin that the liar is trying to
get something from her maybe the journal
can tell them what he is looking for as
long as she still has it Olivia nods her
head and holds out her wrist where a
subdermal chip with a copy of the
journal on it has been placed Calvin
looks at her wrist the world around them
begins to dissipate as Calvin morphs
into the liar Olivia wakes up in a
hospital where she is hooked up to an IV
sitting across from her is a former
Insurgency agent Named Sam beel he
explains to her that he is the liar he
was forced into becoming a monster by
the foundation they had manipulated him
but now he is tired of running and can't
do it anymore she is free to go Olivia
hesitantly unhooks herself from the IV
she walks out of the hospital room and
proceeds down a fluorescent lit hallway
as she walks away she hears a gunshot
from the hospital room as Olivia's in
the hospital Calvin and Adam walk
through a dense forest they are
searching for 05-10 the journal
indicates that the 10th overseer's
identity within the foundation is the
archist in the middle of the clearing
are two saplings standing side by side
the void between the sapling shimmers
Calin walks through the portal in the
the space begins to warp and twist
around him his vision finally comes back
into focus and Calvin finds himself in
another world Adam enters the World
Behind Calvin practically knocking him
over as he enters through the portal
this is the wanderer's library but it
doesn't look anything like they expected
instead of rows of books the library is
filled with computer mainframes humming
with the collected knowledge of how to
contain anomalies a critical backup as
the two look intently at the strange
machines a figure in a silver robe
suddenly steps out of the darkness it's
tall and thin and though its hood is
pulled down so they can't see its face
they can see that its hands are covered
in scales that have a slight Emerald
tint it is one of the Librarians Calvin
tells the librarian that they're seeking
the archist but the librarian tells them
that the archivist is no longer in the
library she has broken her packed with
the serpent and eaten fruit from The
Forbidden trees if they want to see her
though the librarian can take them to
her Calvin and Adam follow the librarian
down a long staircase passing by
countless doors filled with books
Scrolls works of art an entire universe
of knowledge eventually they reach the
bottom of the stairs where there stands
a giant set of brass doors Beyond the
Door the librarian explains is the
source of all knowledge before Calvin
Adam passed through the doors though
Calvin turns to the librarian before we
go in I'd like to make a withdrawal he
says the librarian nods and pulls out a
silver tube out of its robe it hands the
tube to Adam and he looks it over in his
hands he looks up to ask what this is
but the librarian has vanished the door
then opens and the two step through
Calvin and Adam feel as if they walked
through the same kind of portal that
brought them to the library and find
that they have walked into a lush Green
Valley with two trees sitting underneath
one of them is a woman in a white dress
she is reading a book in eating a piece
of fruit are you the archivist Calvin
asks the woman nods yes and that's all
the confirmation Calvin needs he raises
his pistol and fires but the bullet
passes right through the archist as if
she wasn't there do you read the
archivist asked Calvin seemingly not
phased by his attempts to shoot her I
haven't had much time recently Calvin
replied the archist explains that she's
read every book in the library the
collected knowledge of the universe is
in the books even one on how to allow
bullets to pass through your body she
came here to find the secret to
immortality it's her job to document
everything that happens in the world and
she can't do that if she's dead she
explains that she figured out that the
fruit that the serpent forbade everyone
to eat wasn't actual fruit but the
knowledge contained in the library by
having read every book she has consumed
the fruit she no longer needs the
serpent because she was the serpent the
archist falls to the ground and begins
to W around contorting her body as it
starts to change she begins to elongate
as her limbs seemingly disappear the
next thing Calvin and Adam know they're
face to face with a giant snake Calvin
Dodges as the serpent lunges at him and
Adam stands in the doorway firing at the
snake with this pistol but just like
with the archivists human form the
bullets have no effect the serpent coils
around Calvin and begins to choke the
life from him as Adam can only watch
helpless Calvin cries out with his last
breath the tube Adam open the tube Adam
takes the tube that was given to him by
the librarian and opens the cap a long
heavy spear slides out that looks much
too large to have ever fit inside he
drops the tube to the ground and watches
an amazement as it starts to trans
transformed turning into what looks like
a large Harpoon Gun Adam knows what to
do and places the giant spear into the
gun and points it at the serpent you
can't kill me the giant snake says I've
eaten from the Tree of Life Adam pulls
the trigger and the huge spear flies
through the air striking the serpent in
the head Adam runs to Calvin and helps
him to his feet they turned to look at
the snake but instead of the menacing
creature it's the archist once again pin
Ed against the tree she once sat under
the spear sticking out of her skull as
the two stand looking at the archist a
tall hooded humanoid figure steps out
from behind the tree it looks similar to
The Librarian except its robe is a
greenish color and it wears long black
gloves the creature pulls the spear out
of the archist whose body slumps to the
ground and hands the spear to Calvin who
are you Calvin asks but his question is
ignored after a moment the figure
finally speaks that spear you now hold
is called the Spear of the nonbeliever
it is an ancient weapon used to kill
Gods it is odd that someone in this
realm gave you the spear even with it
I'm not sure you will be able to
complete your quest Calvin Lucien but we
shall see there is a sudden flash of
light and Calvin and Adam find
themselves transported back to the
forest they had entered the wanderer's
library from a week later Calvin and
Anthony track down 0 5-9 who in the
council is known as The Outsider she
isn't hard to find and it seems as if
she actually wanted to be found they
find her sitting outside of her burnt
down family home the journal had listed
this as her address but Calvin doubted
that she would be here and most he hoped
to find a clue to her whereabouts but
here she was sitting in the ashes of her
home without turning around the outsider
began speaking the council just used me
you know she says they took away my
academic career my friends and my life
they made me conduct research for them
that compromised everything I stood for
and now here I am with nothing The
Outsider lets out a sigh she asks Calvin
if he's afraid of death Calvin shakes
his head and responds Now The Outsider
slumps forward and Calvin walks around
to face her she is covered in blood her
eyes move to look up at Calvin you're
lying she says as she dies from
self-inflicted wounds Calvin and Anthony
cross 05- 9 off the list and head back
to the car as they they walk Anthony
says what's been on everyone's mind the
last few days the easy part is done
we'll only get harder from here we know
05 d8 is in his castle I'm sure we'll
get in but I'm not sure if we'll make it
out alive I know replies Calvin but if
we're going to save the world we must
eliminate the rest of the overseers even
if it means sacrificing our own lives
they get in the car and drive off into
the blood red sunset to pick up the rest
of the kill squad team before their next
mission Calvin Lucian leads the kill
squad team through the mud and freezing
rain in front of them looms The Fortress
of Baron Leman hoodley the eighth
overseer the team has already been
through a lot from breaking the overseer
council's deal with death by eliminating
05-13 to using the Spear of the
non-believer to kill the Godlike archist
05-10 the hunting of overseers has taken
a toll on the kill Squad 05-12 almost
killed Adam and Olivia was stuck in what
seemed like an endless mind game with
05- 11 the first five overseers were
eliminated but the words that the ninth
overseer spoke to Calvin Lucien before
she died still run through his mind are
you afraid of death now the kill Squad
is about to infiltrate one of the most
heavily guarded facilities in the world
to eliminate the eighth overseer upon
reaching the castle the team is
surprised to find the structure is in
ruin no one is supposed to know the
location of 0 5-8 though the Fortress
was supposed to be practically in
pregnable they storm the castle of 058
all the same the journal Calvin
possesses that contains information
about the members of the SCP
foundation's powerful 05 Council
identifies him as a former industrialist
named Baron Leeman hudley with his vast
wealth hle funded the foundation at the
start and was considered the unofficial
leader of the council in its early days
with immense control over the actions of
the organization the kill Squad makes
their way through the dimly lit hallways
of the castle
as they turn the corner they're
surprised to find the charred remains of
Baron Leeman hole's bodyguards it seems
that someone or some has gotten to hodle
before they could the team makes their
way to the main chamber and breaches the
door laying by a still lit fireplace is
0 5-8 the kill Squad scans the room to
make sure the killer isn't still in
there with them Adam walks over to the
body and examines it he quickly realizes
that hoodley hasn't been murdered at all
he sees that Baron holley's body has
been drastically modified using
anomalous technology the overseer used
his immortality to modify almost every
part of his body to make himself
stronger unfortunately for Baron hoodley
when the overseer's deal with death was
broken by Calvin the modifications to
his body slowly tore him apart his
regular body could no longer support all
the modifications and what once made him
practically Invincible became the very
thing that destroyed him the team leaves
the castle and Crosses o 5-8 off their
list on their way out Adam pulls Calvin
aside he has the feeling that Anthony
hasn't been completely honest with the
rest of the team he had the feeling that
Anthony was hiding something from them
Calvin had similar thoughts recently he
pushes Anthony for more information
about his past and Anthony reveals that
he's over 100 years old the vial of
water from the Fountain of Youth that
Calvin has was not the only one early in
his career with the Insurgency he had
confiscated other vials from a found
found ation site his Squad drank the
water and it extended their lives he
asks Calvin on what he plans on doing
with his water from the fountain I'm
going to destroy it Calvin tells him
Anthony agrees with this plan once you
drink from the Fountain of Youth you may
extend your life but a part of you dies
at the same time vibrancy of the senses
disappears leading to a seemingly
shallow life if Anthony could go back
and do it again he never would have
drank the water Calvin receives tell
from the Insurgency that the seventh
overseers is in a small town in Cambodia
the kill Squad makes their way to the
village and surveys the area hoping to
get a glimpse at the overseer who
codenamed green as the team conducts
reconnaissance Anthony tells them that
he thinks the mission is a setup it is
too remote and there are so many unknown
variables but Calvin is convinced that
this might be their only chance to kill
green since green arrived in the area
there has been non-stop chaos she has
stabilized the local governments and now
the area is in an allout War the team
weaves through narrow passageways
between houses and buildings trying to
make their way to the central compound
where green is located suddenly a mob
starts to form they are getting closer
and closer to the team in a quick
decision to avoid being seen Calvin
orders everyone into a nearby building
before Anthony can follow the mob rounds
the corner they spot Anthony and he's
forced to flee Calvin Olivia and Adam
watch as the mob chases after Anthony
but they have to keep moving Calvin
knows that Anthony can take care of
himself and they are too close to their
goal to stop now Calvin slowly opens the
front door of the house they are hiding
in and peers out the coast looks clear
so he signals Olivia and Adam to follow
him before they can step out into the
street a gas canister enters through a
cracked doorway the room fills with
sleeping gas and the team passes out
when they are awake they are tied up in
a large room with marble vaulted
ceilings 0 5-7 is standing in front of
Calvin she smiles wickedly while holding
a knife she compliments Calvin on what
he and his team have been able to do so
far no one believed they could pull off
even a fraction of what they have but
now she has an offer for Calvin she
points towards Adam and Olivia and tells
Calvin he must choose one of them to die
if he doesn't she'll kill the leader of
the rioter and plunge another part of
the country into chaos screw you is
Calvin's response very well utters green
have it your way she assassinates the
leader being held in her compound then
turns back to Calvin she now threatens
to torture his team until Calvin makes a
choice of who to kill green slashes
Adam's cheek with her knife as Calvin
screams for green to leave his team
alone and torture him instead green Just
Smiles I'm going to enjoy killing your
friends while you watch as you have
killed so many of my overseers on the
council she reaches up in the air with
the knife above Adam's head before she
can plunge the knife through his skull a
bullet passes through her hand causing
her to drop the knife Anthony kneels on
a rooftop across the courtyard smoking
sniper rifles still pointed at Green who
runs Calvin uses the drop knife to cut
his ropes and chases after green he
follows her to the roof where he watches
as she boards a helicopter the aircraft
lifts off as Anthony Fires at it from
his original position but does no
serious damage in the plaza below the
mob that has separated the team earlier
becomes restless there is complete chaos
and someone fires a rocket at the
fleeing helicopter the rocket hits the
tail of the aircraft sending it crashing
into the plaza full of riers below as
the crowd flees from the sea Calvin
makes his way towards the wreckage and
reaches it at the same time Anthony does
Calvin looks at him smiles and thanks
him for saving his life Anthony smiles
back but before he can say anything a
gunshot rings out and a bullet rips
through his neck Calvin turns to see
where it came from and is horrified to
see the burning body of 05- 7 her skin
has been charred black but in her burnt
hand she holds a gun what's left of her
lips curl back in a Sinister grin as she
fires again and hits Anthony in the
chest he falls to the ground Kelvin runs
to him and pulls out his gun to shoot 0
5-7 but she is already dead Calvin holds
his dying teammate as blood pours out of
his neck and chest but Calin can stop
this he pulls out the vial of water from
the fountain no wi's Anthony I have
lived long enough thank you my friend I
will see you in whatever lies Beyond
this life Anthony's chest Rises then
Falls it does not rise again olivan Adam
Round the Corner to see Calvin holding
the lifeless body of their teammate
tears flowing from his eyes the team
holds a small ceremony and burial for
Anthony but are only halfway through
their mission and can't stop now they
fly back to the United States where an
undercover Insurgency agent named
Kowalski informs them that 0 5-6 is
already aware there after him this
overseer is codenamed the American
because he has the power of the entire
US military at his fingertips the kill
Squad Scouts the base where the American
is located Kowalski warns them of a
crate that was recently brought to the
base from site 19 the Americans showed
great interest in whatever was in the
container the group sets up a camp on a
hill overlooking the the base as the sun
slowly Rises the next day the kill Squad
is spotted by a drone and forced to hop
in their Jeep and try to run they make
their way down the hill finding
themselves in the valley below with no
clear exit in front of them lands a
helicopter as Humvees Roar into the
canyon behind them the team is
surrounded a Jeep pulls up and 05- 6
steps out he introduces himself as Rufus
King member of the overseer Council but
an American citizen first and foremost
all he really wants is to protect the
country he loves thanks to you I've lost
my immortality and can no longer
effectively protect the United States
anymore the American says to Calvin but
I'm willing to make a deal your freedom
for the Spear of the nonbeliever rumor
has it that you have the spear in your
possession and you used it to kill the
archivist if you give me the spear I
will let you go no replies Calvin I will
never give an overseer the means to
cause more destruction the spear stays
with us very well the American says with
a frown then I suppose my only other
option is to take it from you but not
without giving you a fair chance run
Calvin Lucien run as fast as you can I
will be coming for you the American
turns and walks towards the container
from site 19 which is being lowered from
a helicopter hovering above them Sprints
back to the jeep with the other members
of his team as they drive away they hear
a horrible guttural Screech from
whatever was inside the container after
a few moments the Army begins to pursue
them out in front of the military force
is 05 D6 writing SCP 682 he is using a
black whip to urge the creature forward
and they're gaining on the kill Squad
fast a row of vehicles pulls up beside
the American an SCP 682 then something
strange happens a man appears in front
of the oncoming forces led by the
American the man's skin bulges and seems
to be moving from within the skin of the
man slous from his body the infection
that is SCP 610 erupts out of him and
onto the soldiers in the nearby Jeep SCP
610 begins to infect and consume
everyone around it suddenly there are
thousands of instances of SCP 610 coming
from the mountain side flooding into the
the valley they close in and around the
Army and 0 5-6 the American begins
fighting off the flesh eating creatures
from the back of SCP 682 but he becomes
overwhelmed he can no longer focus on
pursuing Calvin and his team from the
back of the Jeep Olivia pulls out her
rifle she aims and fires the bullet hits
the American in the chest he is flung
off the back of SCP 682 and engulfed in
a sea of SCP 610 creatures the kill
Squad continues to drive trying to put
as much distance between themselves and
the SCP 610 infestation as possible but
then Calvin suddenly Slams on The Brak
standing in front of them is a man in a
black suit and bow tie he introduces
himself as Blackbird the fifth overseer
according to the journal his actual name
is Mortimer Jay Denning Von Kiker he
stands in front of the jeep with a
menacing grin you have been causing a
lot of trouble he says looking at Cal
Olivia swings her gun around oh please
my dear that won't help you Von cnar
says he pulls out a knife and stabs
himself through the neck he falls to the
ground apparently dead there is a gust
of wind a whiff of ozone and an
identical copy and still very much alive
on Kiker lands next to his own dead body
see what I mean he says Olivia lowers
her rifle come with me I have something
to show you the Blackbird beckons seeing
no other option Calvin olivan Adam exit
the Jeep and followed the Blackbird as
they walk the world changes around them
the desert mountains Fade Away into
Blackness and find themselves in the
near apocalyptic London oh it's good to
be how the Blackbird says as they emerge
onto a cobblestone street you cannot
stop the overseers plans however I can
give you an alternative let's see if any
of you will take it in front of each
kill Squad member appears a door they
have an uncontrollable urge to open
their respective door and walk through
the Blackbird stands smiling as he
watches Calvin Olivia and Adam enter
each of their portals Adam enters his
door and looks around he is in Portland
his parents walk into the room in this
universe his family has been granted
Asylum Adam never has to interact with
any scps or the foundation he is free to
live a normal life from the kitchen
comes Calvin wearing an apron he is
holding holding a steaming pot Adam
locks eyes with Calvin who Smiles at him
the Blackbird Whispers into Adam's ear
in this reality both of your parents and
siblings are still alive also the man
you love loves you back you and Calvin
could be married if you stayed here
wouldn't that be nice Olivia enters her
door she is on the deck of a yacht at
the bow sits an easel with art supplies
the man that Olivia once loved walks
across the deck towards her the
Blackbird looms over her in this reality
you didn't accidentally kill him this
could be your happily ever after
wouldn't that be nice Calvin steps
through his door he's in a grassy
clearing near a lake the Blackbird
hisses in Calvin's ear I'm giving you
the opportunity to save your mother this
time Calvin you were just a scared
little boy but in this reality you can
be brave you can actually save your
mother from her fate no Calvin screamed
s this isn't real the Blackbird cackles
Calvin looks away from the lake and
towards the tree line hidden in the
shadows he can just barely make out a
hooded figure Calvin walks towards it
the Blackbird follows he is screaming at
the person in the tree line I was only
trying to help the hooded figure reaches
out and hands Calvin a metal tube he
opens it to find a set of eyeglasses
inside Calvin puts them on and turns to
look at the Blackbird he steps back in
horror the glasses have revealed the TR
form of the Blackbird he is a winged
pseudo Aven monstrosity full of Rage the
mysterious hooded figure directs Calvin
to open the tube again inside is an
interdimensional fishing line made by DR
Wonder tainment and a white whiffle ball
bat Calvin grabs the fishing line and
wraps it around 05- 5's leg the
Blackbird flies into the air trying to
get away from Calvin but Calvin wraps
the other end of the fishing line around
his arm the Blackbird begins to jump
from dimension into Dimension trying to
get rid of Calvin they appear on the
deck of SCP 455 in sight 19 where SCP
682 walks freely in the dead world of
SCP
2935 every time they stop in a new
dimension Calvin takes the opportunity
to attack the blackbird with the bat and
it seems that he is slowly weakening the
monster they finally land at the bottom
of a deep well foundation containment
site where the dark body that is SCP 001
is contained standing in front of the
containment field is Allison Cho The
Black Queen whose sole mission is to
destroy the foundation you cries the
Blackbird you are the one who's been
helping Lucien The Black Queen nods her
head yes I have been helping Calvin
Lucien to eliminate you and the other
overseers the foundation Must Fall you
are nothing you cannot stop me I am the
black king screams 0 5-5 Al and Chow
size she pushes a button on the panel
next to her shutting down the array
containing the dark body out of the
cloud of dust appears SCP 001 a massive
black creature who seemed to absorb all
light no stop shrieks the Blackbird SCP
001 does not move but the room begins to
shake the Blackbird continues to scream
as his body folds in on itself until he
is reduced to a single superheated point
and then blinks out of existence Allison
Chow then reactivates the containment
array sealing 001 away once again I will
return you to your reality along with
your friends says the black queen but
perhaps our path shall cross again
Calvin Lucian there is a bright flash of
light and Calvin finds himself on a
private jet sitting next to Olivia and
Adam they are all shaken but the
Blackbird is dead 0 5-5 has been
eliminated the three members of the team
said silently still pondering What Might
Have Been if they stayed in the
alternate realities suddenly the phone
on the plane begins to ring breaking the
silence Calvin picks it up on the other
line is the fourth overseer he has
contacted Calvin to discuss surrendering
to the Insurgency unfortunately things
do not always go as planned Calvin
Lucien is about to make the most
difficult and dangerous decision of his
life Aaron seagull better known to
Foundation members as 05- one descends
into the abyss of a Deep Well site he
exits the elevator and peers into the
optical scanner to unlock the reinforced
door inside the room is mobile task
force TOA 5 samsara Aaron seagull refers
to these Immortal cyborg clones created
from the Flesh of a dead God as his red
right hand your mission is to eliminate
the traiter 05- 4 and to find the
insurgents who have been killing the
members of the overseer Council the
cyborgs stand at attention now Aaron
seagull screams the soldiers of the red
right hand March out the door to start
their mission Aaron seagull pauses for a
moment and then slams his fist against
the wall and frustration he has lost
nine overseers to Calvin Lucian and his
kill squad team they have been somehow
overcoming the odds each time and
eliminating each overseer they tracked
down it wasn't supposed to end this way
Aaron seagull vows to kill them all
Calvin Lucian meanwhile sits on a
private jet with Adam and Olivia he had
just hung up the phone after a
conversation with 054 the overseer known
as the Ambassador wants to surrender to
the Insurgency there's a good chance
this is a trap but Calvin has decided to
meet with the Ambassador all the same
Calvin drops off Adam and Olivia at an
Insurgency base they still haven't fully
recovered from the previous Mission with
05- 5 known as the Blackbird
before leaving though Calvin meets with
an Insurgency agent named Sylvester
Sloan who is going to join him as
support Calvin says goodbye to Adam and
Olivia then leaves with Sloan to meet
The Ambassador in South Africa after
landing at Johannesburg airport Calvin
and Sloan disembark and are led to a
conference room where the Ambassador
sits waiting for them Calvin and Sloan
sit across from 054 to discuss his
surrender the council is in shambles
says the Ambassador everything is
falling apart I want to offer my
services and information to the
Insurgency in exchange for protection
from
05-18 he whispers Calvin and Sloan grab
the Ambassador who is Frozen in fear and
exit the conference room they make their
way towards their plane but the gunshots
are getting closer Calvin looks over his
shoulder to to see some Sara pursuing
them through the terminal Calvin shoves
the Ambassador behind a table as bullets
whiz overhead Calvin and Sloan return
fire but their volley doesn't seem to
slow down the Assassins Calvin and Sloan
pull the ambassador to his feet and they
burst through an emergency exit onto the
sunbaked tarmac where they make a Mad
Dash for the plane from behind them a
bullet rips through the chest of Sloan
the red right hand has caught up but
Calvin continues to drag the Ambassador
towards the plane they are almost there
suddenly a metallic child's Voice blares
through the airport's external speakers
the child's voice says I want Calvin
Lucien alive I have business to settle
with him the red right-and soldiers
tackle Calvin and the ambassador to the
ground when they are just feet away from
the plane kill the traitor the child's
voice says and Calvin can only watch
helplessly as the Ambassador is
violently murdered one of the agents
turns towards Calvin and slams his fist
into Calvin's face causing him to black
out Calvin awakes in a dark room he is
unsure how much time has passed the only
light in the room comes from a screen on
the wall in the middle of the screen is
a rotating red SCP Foundation seal a
voice from a speaker speaks hello Calvin
Lucien my name is the kid I am the third
overseer you have killed all my friends
and now I will kill all of yours the
door to the room opens Calvin leans
through the doorway there is a long
dimly lit hallway the kid orders him to
proceed so they can meet face to face as
Calvin walks the kid's voice Echoes down
the hallway there once was another
allseeing eye I now watch everything all
of the time I have perfect reasoning
perfect awareness and perfect
understanding Calvin gets to the end of
the corridor which opens up into a large
chamber tied up in the middle of the
room are Olivia and Adam Calvin runs to
his friends and crouches down next to
them a mechanical suit stands on a
platform looking down at Calvin Olivia
and Adam Calvin realizes the kid must be
contained inside I now sentence you all
to death the mechanical suit says as the
red right hand steps out of the shadows
and slowly walks towards the remaining
members of the kill Squad suddenly
there's a flash of light and the black
queen appears stop what are you doing
shrieks the kid the black queen hands
Calvin the interdimensional rod and reel
he used to defeat the Blackbird Calvin
casts the rod from out of the terror and
space comes a massive multi-armed
creature known as madami gon the red
right hand in engages the monster trying
to force it back into its Dimension but
the monster is too powerful he grabs the
cyborg clones and pulls them through the
tear in reality as samsara battles the
madicon Calvin frees Olivia and Adam
they make a run for the door but as they
flee one of the walls opens up to reveal
a turret the gun fires and a bullet hits
Olivia directly in the head killing her
instantly no yells Calvin before Calvin
can push Adam out of the way a second
Bullet From the tur it lodes itself in
Adam's back Calvin and Adam slide across
the floor the kid in his mechanical suit
jumps down from the platform above I am
going to kill you now Calvin Lucien he
says in his mechanical voice there is
another flash of light Calvin watches in
front of him as the Spear of the
non-believer manifests itself before his
eyes celvin grabs the spear and shoves
it into the kid's machine body it easily
penetrates the armor and pins him to the
wall Calvin walks up to the exoskeleton
and tears off the outer plating
revealing a tank full of fluid within
which floats a malformed human fetus as
Calvin finally looks upon the kid's True
Form he hears the sound of mocking
mechanical laughter Calvin breaks the
glass and crushes the kid with his bare
hands as Calvin turns from the now
silent robotic body of the kid the room
begins to shake debris raining down from
above Calvin helps Adam up and puts
Olivia's lifeless body across his
shoulders what remains of the kill Squad
makes their way out of the kid's Lair
outside of the foundation site where
they were being held Calvin helps Adam
lie down on the ground before gently
setting Olivia's body next to him Adam
grimaces as blood pours out of the wound
in his back Calvin reaches into his
pocket and pulls out the vial of water
from the Fountain of Youth there are
only a couple of drops left which he
pours into Adam's mouth Adam looks up at
Calvin tears filling his eyes he
whispers I love you before he passes out
out from the pain the wound in his back
begins to heal instantly and Calvin
calls an Insurgency Evac team to come
pick up Adam with Adam safe Calvin picks
up Olivia and walks alone towards a
truck in the lot outside of the
foundation site he needs to finish this
once and for all he will kill the last
two overseers or he will die trying 0
5-1 Aaron seagull arrives at where the
tigress and Euphrates rivers meet the
garden of E Eden he is in a frenzy duee
to the assassinations of all the other
overseers besides himself and the
Nazarene and nothing will stop him as he
approaches the gate to the Garden of
Eden though he is stopped by the
guardian of the garden a massive
powerful anomalous entity with a flaming
sword but Aaron seagull has no time or
patience for anything to get in his way
even something as powerful as the gate
Guardian the guardian swings his burning
sword at Adam who rolls out of the way
away and in a Flash takes out a Scranton
reality anchor he slams The Anchor into
the ground which causes the world to
Shimmer and ripple around him he watches
as the Flames from the gate Guardian
Sword seem to absorb back into its body
before it shrinks down looking to fold
in on itself until all that is left is a
charred skeleton with the guardian
defeated Aaron Sprints into the garden
he searches the garden for 0 5-2 but
can't find her anywhere he finally comes
to the tree of life and that's where he
finds her laying at the base of the tree
in a pool of blood is the Nazarene she
has taken her own life this is her
anomalous power though she has died many
times before yet death always spared her
and brought her back but somehow he
knows this time is final Aaron drops to
his knees and screams and frustration
for all the power Aaron seagull
possesses there's nothing he can do now
he sits next to the nazar's body for
hours hoping that she might wake up or
that he will to find that this was all a
dream after sitting next to her cold
body for some time he notices something
in her Snowy White Hand it's a note in
it the nazarine explains that she was
the one who gave the vials from the
fountain to Calvin Lucian and that she
is the one who made the spear appear
before him that he used to kill the kid
she explained that while she died many
times and death always brought her back
back each time she felt less and less
like herself less and less like Dr
Sophia light she hoped that maybe if
things ended up like this it would give
Aaron the chance to walk away and live
the life that they might have been able
to have together but she knows deep down
that Aaron's fade is to meet Calvin and
finish things once and for all Aaron
seagull screams in Rage clutching the
node in his hand he tries to summon
death but no one comes Aaron seagull is
alone he stands up and walks deeper into
the garden he walks until he reaches a
spot where even God's light does not
reach in this desolate land is an impact
crater where Lucifer star of the morning
had fallen in the middle of the crater
lies Lucifer's sword Aaron seagull
descends into the hole and picks up the
sword he turns and exits the Garden of
Eden Aaron seagull has only one mission
in life now to kill Calvin Lucien Calvin
reads the final entry of the journal in
it the author warns that although he
hopes the information contained within
the journal is helpful he hopes the
reader does not try to use it the words
written on the final page are this
information will only lead you to a
devastating end Calvin closes the
journal and looks up at the structure in
front of him he has made it to sight 01
he had left Olivia's body in a cave
nearby promising to her that he would
make this right he now walks up to the
massive doors and places his hand on the
knotted wood the doors slowly Creek open
Calvin pauses for a moment and looks
behind him at the Setting Sun he enters
sight 01 where he knows 05- one is where
Aaron seagull Waits inside the main hall
Calvin sees a giant doorway in the shape
of the SCP Foundation seal with artistic
depictions of certain scps that he
instinctively knows are special in some
way standing next to the doorway is a 2m
tall man in what looks to be a
futuristic suit Calvin approaches and
asks who this giant man is he responds
that his name is purpose the red right
hand he is the guardian of
051 and None Shall enter the sanctum
until he returns he isn't here asked
Calvin no purpose responds he is and
with that he steps aside and lets Calvin
pass through the doorway the doorway
leads into a large room where screens on
the wall flash to life depicting moments
from Calvin's Journey documenting his
entire Quest had he been in control at
all or was this all a setup to lead him
to this moment as he walks forward he
finally sees him sitting at a table in
the middle of the room is Aaron seagull
EUR 5-1 Calvin asks Aaron the man
responds my name is aaronal asks about
the location of the second overseer the
Nazarene but 0 5-1 doesn't respond
without needing any more information
Calvin pulls out his sidearm and in a
Flash fires off five shots the bullets
stopped in the air inches from Aaron
before dissolving in a flash of light
Calvin should have known it wouldn't be
this easy stand up Aaron seagull Calvin
calls up as he holers his gun let's
finish it Calvin pulled the Spear of the
non-believer from his back but Aaron's
only response was to
laugh you don't even know why you're
here Aaron said Calvin calls back I'm
here to kill you because when I do I
kill the foundation because when you're
gone the universe can finally heal
you're like me Calvin Lucien we are both
men driven by our own convictions
regardless of the outcome it would seem
Fate has brought us together now either
your convictions will be broken or you
will die says Aaron seagull he then
draws Lucifer's flaming sword and lunges
towards Calvin Lucian as the two men
clash with one another their
Supernatural weapons begin to destroy
the room around them Furniture is
shattered video screens are obliterated
and fire spreads across the walls Aaron
catches Calvin off balance and swings
the Flaming sword across Calvin's
stomach Calvin slides back from the
impact hunching over from the pain in
his midsection he brings his head up to
see Aaron seag running towards him with
a flaming sword high in the air Calvin
brings up the spear from his knees he
leans back and launches it towards Aron
seagull the spear enters the final
overseer's chest the force from the
throw pinning him against the wall Aaron
seagull drops Lucifer's sword it
shatters as it hits the ground he
clutches the shaft of the spear
protruding from his sternum with both
hands 0 5-1 looks at Calvin
unbelievingly you have no idea what
you've done it was never about the
overseers Aaron seagull says spitting
out blood with every word it was
something deeper something worse Calvin
walks slowly towards Aaron seagull he
stops just in front of his final enemy
this is the way it ends Calvin says
Aaron seagull manages to whisper one
final word Sophia before his body
finally goes limp Calvin turns to see
purpose standing behind him he's dead
Calvin says half to purpose and half to
himself I killed him after a moment he
asks purpose what he really wants to
know there's a room in this facility
where someone could unmake the
foundation right take me there without
any hesitation purpose leads Calvin back
to the room with depictions of important
scps there purpose opens the door to an
elevator but stops Calvin before he can
get inside I am Duty bound to tell you
purpose says that once you step inside
this elevator there is no going back
there is only one decision to be made
and it is not one that can be unmade I
know Calvin responds it's time before
stepping inside the elevator opens a
door to reveal a room filled with
bookcases and a huge window offering a
beautiful view of the sun setting behind
the mountains on the wall are monitors
depicting the ways he had killed all of
the overseers and in the middle of the
room is a large desk with a computer
Calvin sits down at the desk and the
computer comes to life the computer
prompts him to scan his fingerprint
which it accepts he's logged in the
computer screen displays numerous
locations around the planet and he
quickly recognizes that they are all SCP
Foundation science then he sees the
single option the computer is giving him
terminate Calvin reaches out with his
finger this is it once he presses this
button
the SCP Foundation will be no more his
finger is millimet from the button when
the phone rings Calvin hadn't even
noticed that there was a phone on the
desk Calvin stares at it for a moment
then picks it up hello he says the voice
on the other line responds hello Calvin
Lucien my name is the administrator I've
been following your work for some time
now and I must say I am impressed I have
just been informed that you have
completed your mission congratulations
are in order what the hell are you
talking about Calvin asks please listen
says the voice on the other line the man
you just killed was once in the same
exact position you are in now granted it
was a very long time ago but Aaron
seagull originally was trying to destroy
the foundation that was until I
convinced him otherwise and now like
Aaron seagull you will become the new
head of the foundation like hell I will
yells Calvin I could hang up and walk
away right now and be done with all this
yes you could continues the
administrator but if no one is in charge
of the SCP Foundation millions of people
will die if not billions and then nobody
would be there to manage what comes
after there is silence from Calvin
that's what I thought says the
administrator I look forward to working
with you Calvin Lucien or should I say
05- one the line goes dead
the oror cycle one of the biggest most
legendary series of entries in the
history of the SCP Foundation we've
covered the events of this SCP 00001
epic in six videos which we definitely
recommend you watch before this one to
avoid your brain exploding from the
sheer scope of it all because that's the
thing about the orborous cycle it's a
story so big sprawling and dense that
can feel almost like an anomaly itself
whether you're immersed in the possible
origin of the broken God the sentient
black hole that can destroy the whole
universe or Calvin lucian's quest to
assassinate the 05 Council it can
sometimes be difficult to see the forest
from the trees but worry not because
that's exactly why we're here today
we're going to step back and look at
this anomalous Odyssey as a whole and
ask the big question why is it all here
together what makes these four different
story lines lines the children the
broken God atonement and the way it ends
one big cycle as with anything involving
the SCP Foundation there's always going
to be an element of personal
interpretation but now that we've gone
through the whole cycle we think it's
worth adding r two sents to the
proceedings so let's start broad a
question you've probably been wondering
is what do the words or borus cycle
actually mean and what is their
significance to the four stories within
while the spelling can differ orboros
refers to the ancient symbol of a snake
or dragon eating its own tail forming a
circle a direct connection to the
concept of Cycles the arbar symbol has
existed in a huge number of cultures
from the ancient Egyptians to the
ancient Greeks to Modern Gnostic
Traditions it's often used in alchemy or
other magical practices and has a
variety of meanings such as eternal life
the endless cycle of death and rebirth
and the cycle of renewal anyone familiar
with the tales within the oror cycle is
probably already noticing some
similarities Cycles are a common theme
in all of these Works people endlessly
repeat mistakes threats thought to be
contained or destroyed return and often
times those who go out on a quest to
destroy something end up becoming what
they wish to destroy in the first place
in a cycle there is no true end and no
true beginning everything repeats
endlessly but let's start at the closest
thing to the beginning we have the
children in this Tale the foundation
faces off against a terrifying reality
warping group of interests known as the
kingdom of abdon this nasty Group which
came from the Sahara Desert could
seemingly take anything the foundation
threw at them and were able to straight
up vaporize anyone who got too close if
the kingdom was able to amass enough
power it could spell the end of the
foundation and even the subjugation of
the human race enter 05- one a
reoccurring character in the orboros
cycle this outside the box thinker put
all his chips on the twins of God
project designated SCP 001 like many
anomalies before and after it this
project would Infuse a human being with
Godlike Powers but it was a power so
great that it seemed to kill anyone who
attempted to accept it needless to say
this was a major bummer for 051 but
through Relentless human experimentation
even sacrificing the population of
entire towns to the project he
eventually came up with a solution a
horrifying solution but a solution
nonetheless he found that a group of
nine children with ages varying from 4
to 11 could act as a human conduit for
001's power and as a result it could be
a weapon capable of turning the tide
against the kingdom of abdon during the
testing phase though it seemed like 05-
one went a little mad with power he
vaporized an entire church of the broken
God place of worship and used the power
of the children to wipe a few others off
the map at his own discretion his abuses
of power power got so flagrant that the
administrator himself was called in to
get a handle on the situation and
surprise surprise 0 5-1 disintegrated
him too before disappearing himself
shortly afterwards in the end the
children were deemed too dangerous to be
practical both because of their
anomalous powers and from the level of
ambient radiation they put out all nine
were locked in radiation proof boxes and
buried in the desert though they each
show signs of life to this day well this
may seem disconnected from the rest of
the series it actually establishes some
of the most important reoccurring themes
and ideas of the cycle as a whole namely
the foundation messing with reality and
Performing horrific acts to achieve
their goals the corruption of the 05
Council and the fact that these Grand
attempts to change or save the world
often blow up in everyone's Faces
Sometimes literally we also have the
introduction and apparent death of the
mysterious administrator but trust us
all Is Not What It Seems with this one
the ripple effect beginning here will
affect everything going forward next the
broken God this tells the chaotic story
of a magical Clockwork box which is
worshiped by the church of the broken
God as a conduit to their deity and
eventually becomes an all devouring
mechanical Kaiju the Beast soon dubed
SCP 001 devoured and consumed all the
metal around it slowly becoming larger
and more destructive if the foundation
didn't take it out before it reached
critical mass they'd be going toe-to-toe
with a Bonafide God a fight they really
weren't sure they could win thankfully
and with a little anomalous help from
SCP 2399 the foundation was able to
destroy the anomaly they removed its
Clockwork hard from the wreckage and
contained the anomalous scrap that once
comprised its destructive body however
the foundation soon realized that you
just can't keep a good god down the
Clockwork heart eventually evaded
Foundation containment while being
shipped to a secondary location and
instead ended ended up in a small town
here it began to influence the minds of
the residents into more subservient
broken God cultists intent on building
him back up to his former glory it'd be
easy to Discount the broken God as an
outlier seeing as the foundation came
out looking much better here than they
do in any of the other or borus Tales
but when you look carefully its place in
the overall cycle is clear the entry
ends the way it begins with the heart of
the broken God influencing humans to
carry out its bidding the found had to
intervene in between these two instances
but in the end there was no net loss to
the broken God itself in a sense the
foundation is doomed to encounter the
same problems again and again
continually defending the world from the
same anomalous threats and the
foundation needs to succeed every time
to maintain peace and normality a major
anomalous threat only needs to succeed
once to drag everything into disarray in
many ways that is the curse of the SCP
Foundation
speaking of major anomalous threats now
it's time for part three of the or borus
cycle atonement once again we start off
with the foundation meddling with Cosmic
scale Powers with the creation of the
area 11 Petri Cal Fontaine spatial
stabilization array try saying that
three times fast that was a machine so
powerful it was capable of creating a
singularity though what it actually
ended up doing was turning Dr Calvin
desmat into an Abomination more
specifically into a kind of a ly
powerful humanoid black hole whose
Powers were only restrained by the very
machine that created him think of him as
kind of a malicious Dr Manhattan from
Watchmen this new entity dubbed SCP 001
presented a grim prophecy and an ominous
offer he told the 05 Council that
anomalies were leaking into their
Universe from other realities and soon
the anomalous threat would destroy them
all his offer was to upon his release
wipe out the rest of the Multiverse in
entirely leaving only our reality free
from anomalous threats unsurprisingly it
was 05- one that was most interested in
this offer so much so that he held a
vote and murdered everyone who voted
against the decision to release SCP 001
having built his consensus among the
survivors on the council 0 5-1 let SCP
001 out unsurprisingly this turned out
to be a terrible decision as one of his
first acts upon being freed was to kill
the members of the 05 Council that had
just voted to release 001 saying that
they themselves were anomalous and
needed to be purged to atone for their
past sins the only Survivor was a member
of the council who abstained from the
vote who was able to recontain SCP 001
inside the petria Fontaine array for now
once again the Thematic connections to
the rest of the ororo cycle is clear we
have a world-ending anomaly held off but
only temporarily buying time before the
cycle inevitably continues we have the
foundation abusing its power and signing
off on the death of countless people in
other dimensions and of course the 05
Council stepped out of their bounds and
actively warped reality just like they
had with the children before their
chickens truly come home to roost though
in the final part of the cycle
appropriately named the way it ends this
piece Chronicles the story of Calvin
Lucien and the kill Squad an elite group
of four chaos Insurgency Soldiers with
one goal assassinating the entire 05
Council 13 of the most powerful people
in the world why because they've been
messing with reality itself time and
time again and it's getting to the point
that their selfish meddling could
finally destroy everything and given
that we've already seen it happen with
the children and the entity that Dr
Calvin desmat became it's hard to
disagree with them what follows is one
of the longest and most complicated
tales in all of the foundation as the
kill Squad systematically encounters and
kills each insane anomalous member of
the 05 Council in order to do this they
need to make deals with death itself
fight giant serpents cross Dimensions
deal with SCP 610 and SCP 682
containment breaches and go toe-to-toe
with Sam Sara arguably the foundation's
deadliest mobile task force a number of
other insane things happen along the way
like 0 5-1 murdering the gate Guardian
with the Scranton reality anchor and the
black queen the most prominent member of
the Serpent's hand helping our heroes
defeat more overseers in the end Calvin
Lucien despite losing almost everything
Reigns victorious in the final battle
using the Spear of the non-believer a
weapon so powerful it can kill Gods
Calvin managed to finally kill the Top
member of the overseers 05- one with the
05 Council destroyed Calvin set about
completing his final task destroying the
entire SCP Foundation but that did
didn't happen instead he was contacted
by a mysterious and immensely powerful
being known as the administrator who
gave him some frightening news he'd just
been hired by the SCP Foundation to be
their new 05- one this was where our
last video on the arboros series left us
what happens next you may ask how does
Calvin respond to this offer he
seemingly can't refuse in this case it
seems that the administrator of being so
completely tied to the nature of the
foundation itself
is SCP 001 and while it seemed that the
overseers were mad with power they were
actually always there to keep the
administrator in check Aaron seagler the
05- one that Calvin had just killed was
doing the exact same thing Calvin was
doing when he became 05- one trying to
destroy the foundation but the
foundation and the administrator cannot
be beaten they can only be joined and
that's exactly what Calvin did becoming
the new 05 -1 turning his back on the
chaos Insurgency and rebuilding the rest
of the council and the foundation in his
own image Insurgency members who were
once his allies vowed revenge for this
betrayal perhaps suggesting that history
would go on to repeat itself once more
in the future because at the end of the
day that's what the ororo cycle really
is the reoccurring threat and the
changing of the guards that accompanies
it there will always be a foundation
there will always be an administrator
there will always be an' 05 Council
nothing starts nothing ends all that
ever changes are the names and faces
involved whether it's Calvin Lucien or
Aaron seagler the wheel keeps turning
the snake devours its own tail the aorus
cycle is and forever will be Eternal now
go check out our full piece by piece
breakdown on the orboros cycle starting
with SCP 001 the children and then check
out SCP 5000 y the full story
compilation just in case we haven't
blown your mind enough for one day